THE SENATE SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
PANDEMIC RESPONSE WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN THE CAPITAL WITH
SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PREVENT PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
TODAY WE HAVE EIGHT MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SENATORS
GORGEOUS DODD. DORADO GLAZER
JACKSON MCGUIRE AMBERG AND
WIENER IN THE SENATE CHAMBER
WITH ME ARE SENATORS GONZALEZ
PAN AND WILK. WE ALSO HAVE
WITNESSES WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY THEY ARE DAVID MY
CHERYL FROM THE CAJON VALLEY
UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT MELISSA
BASS AND ELLIE FROM THE SAN
JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
SHANNON BROWN FROM THE SAN JUAN
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. MARY JANE
BURKE FROM THE MARIN COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION I NEED A
SURELY FROM THE CORONA NORCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TONY
THURMOND FROM THE TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. MARTHA GUTMANN S.
SERVICE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
CAROLYN MCINTYRE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION.
DANE JASPER FROM SONIC AND JORI
WOLF FROM MAGELLAN ADVISORS.
FOR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MOVE YOUR YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. ACID EVERYTIME YOU
WISH WE RECOGNIZE THAT USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE ON YOUR
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN MUTE
PLEASE SELECT UNMUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. OUR I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOUR READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS FOUR FIVE SO.
SEVEN FIVE FIVE NINE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL BE
HEARING ALL OF THE PANELS OF
WITNESSES ON THE AGENDA PRIOR
TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
ONCE WE HAVE HEARD ALL THE
WITNESSES WILL HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO COMMENT ON THE TOPICS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA. AS NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE YOUR
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WELL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS. AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT OF ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. WITH THAT. WELCOME TO
TODAY'S HEARING A VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC OF DISTANCE
LEARNING AND OTHER WAYS OUR
STUDENTS ARE CURRENTLY
RECEIVING INSTRUCTION. AND
RELATED SERVICES WE WILL HEAR
ABOUT DISTANCE ONLY
INSTRUCTION. IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION VIA THE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL WAIVER AND HOW STUDENTS
ARE RECEIVING INSTRUCTION AND
SERVICES IN THE AREAS OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION. ENGLISH
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT AND MENTAL
HEALTH. THE SECOND PART OF THE
HEARING WILL FOCUS ON THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND STEPS BEING
TAKEN TO CONNECT THE EDUCATION
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS WORLDS
TO ENSURE STUDENTS CAN ACCESS
DISTANCE LEARNING INCLUDING
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR SHORT AND
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS. TO FINALLY
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. THE
PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING IS
TO LEARN FROM SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND WHAT THEY'RE
DOING TO SERVE STUDENTS DURING
THE COVERED OCCURRED AB. COBIT
PANDEMIC SKEWS ME THIS HEARING
IS NOT ABOUT WHETHER SCHOOL
SHOULD FULLY RE OPEN OR ABOUT
ISSUES OF SAFETY. TODAY'S
HEARING IS MEANT TO EXPLORE ONE
FACET OF K. TWELVE EDUCATION
THE ASSEMBLY HELD A HEARING
THAT FOCUSED ON THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE AND ITS IMPACT ON
STUDENTS. THE ASSEMBLY WILL
HOLD ANOTHER HEARING TOMORROW
TO DISCUSS THE SAFE RE OPENING
OF SCHOOLS. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC I'M PERSONALLY WORRIED
ABOUT THE LOSS OF LEARNING AND
THE LIGHTLY WIDENING OF THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP. IT IS CRITICAL
THAT EVERY STUDENT CALIFORNIA
HAS ACCESS TO QUALITY
pENVIRONMENT WHETHER THEY'RE
LEARNING VIRTUALLY OR IN
PERSON. I'M ALSO WORRIED ABOUT
OUR STUDENTS WITH EXCEPTIONAL
NEEDS THOSE NEEDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND STUDENTS WHO NEED
THEIR SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE A
TRUSTED ADULT. IN A SAFE PLACE.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE KEEP THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP IN MIND AS WE
CONSIDER WHAT IS BEST FOR
STUDENTS AND SCHOOLS AND AS WE
DESIGN OUR EDUCATIONAL AND
SUPPORT PROGRAMS. SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES AT ALL LEVELS HAVE
BEEN WORKING INCREDIBLY HARD TO
ADJUST TO BE INNOVATIVE AND TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THEIR
STUDENTS WELL. AND I APPLAUD
ALL OF YOU FOR THAT.
FORTUNATELY THIS HEARING CANNOT
COVER ALL ASPECTS OR
REPRESENTATIVES FROM SEVERAL
CRITICAL AREAS THAT DO DESERVE
ATTENTION SUCH AS CHILD CARE
FOSTER AND HOMELESS YOUTH.
MEALS AND HEALTH SAFETY
VULNERABLE OR NEGLECTED
CHILDREN AND MIGRANT STUDENTS
AND HIGHER EDUCATION. ONE OF
THE CRITICAL AREAS THAT WE
WON'T BE COVERING TODAY IS THE
VAST SCOPE OF WHAT WORK. DONE
BY CLASS OF FORTIFIED EMPLOYEES
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO RECOGNIZE THOSE EMPLOYEES.
MANY OF WHOM PROVIDE
INSTRUCTION AND SERVICES OFTEN
TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
ARE ESSENTIAL TO THE DELIVERY
OF KEY SERVICES. FROM THE I. T.
STAFF WHO ENSURE SCHOOLS CAN
PROVIDE DISTANCE LEARNING. A
TENNIS COURTS TO TRACK ABSENT
STUDENTS TO SEVERAL
CLASSIFICATIONS WORKING TO
ENSURE STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
MEALS. ON THAT NOTE WE WILL BE
HAVING A WE WILL BE JOINING THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
ON NOVEMBER SEVENTEENTH. TO
DISCUSS FOOD IN SECURITY AND
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT STUDENT
ACCESS TO SCHOOL MEALS. THANK
YOU ALL AND THANK YOU TO ALL
THE WITNESSES I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM ALL OF YOU AND
HEARING YOUR TESTIMONY. AT THIS
TIME I'D LIKE TO ASK SENATOR
GONZALEZ IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE ANY OPENING REMARKS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND CENTER
LEYVA AS CHAIR OF THE SENATE'S
AS SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND
AS A MOM- WITH CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
TODAY'S WITNESSES FROM THE
EDUCATION COMMUNITY AND OUR
FIRST PANEL. AS WELL AS THE
STAKEHOLDERS TACKLING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE WITH US HERE IN
THE STATE- AND- FIGURING OUT
WHAT WE CAN DO TO SUPPORT AND
HELP OUR STUDENTS PARENTS
TEACHERS CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
TO WHAT- THIS IS. TO WHAT IS A
NEW WORLD OF DISTANCE LEARNING
AND IN GENERAL A NEW WAY OF
ADOPT ADAPTING TO THIS PANDEMIC
INDUCED WORLD- WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE BEST
PRACTICES AROUND THE STATE THAT
WE CAN LEARN FROM. HOW DO YOU
MAKE SURE THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS
OF ALL OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
BEING MET ARE WE ADDRESSING THE
INEQUITIES THAT EXISTED. FOR
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC FOR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES AND CHILDREN WHO
ARE HOMELESS- I KNOW IN MY DOES
TRICKS MENTAL HEALTH. TO BE A
OF A BIG ISSUE IS. WITH THE
COMPLIANCE SPANISH SPEAKING
COMMUNITIES AND HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS. OF THOSE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
PARENTS. AND THERE'S ALSO ONE
POINT TWO CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
ADEQUATE OR NO. INTERNET ACCESS
WHATSOEVER SOMETHING THAT I AM
CERTAINLY- GOING TO HONE IN ON.
YOU KNOW THERE'S NO SUBSTITUTE
FOR IN PERSON LEARNING AS SOON
AS A SCIENCE SAYS IT IS SAFE
FOR T. K. THROUGH TWELVE
STUDENTS TEACHERS AND OTHER
STAFF TO RETURN TO CLASSROOMS
ACROSS THE STATE. WE WILL SEE
MORE AND MORE. OF THAT
HAPPENING UNTIL ALL OF OUR
CHILDREN HAVE RETURNED TO THEIR
CLASSROOMS. BUT IN IN THE
MEANTIME WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND WHAT MORE WE
CAN DO. MANY OF OUR A MANY OF
US REPRESENT COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE ALL BEEN. NEGLECTED AND
IGNORED BY COMPANIES. AND THE-
MANY STAKEHOLDERS THAT NEED TO
BE ABLE TO COME TO THE TABLE TO
COOPERATE WITH US. WE CANNOT
CALL OURSELVES THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY WITHOUT.
TACKLING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE- IN
A SERIOUS WAY. AND WITH THAT I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH SENATOR LEYVA FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
EVERYBODY'S TESTIMONY TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER DAHLE
GONZALEZ I APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE ON THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH
OUR SPEAKERS I'D LIKE TO OPEN
UP TO OTHER SENATORS
PARTICIPATING FOR ANY BRIEF
COMMENTS. SEEING NO HANDS HERE
I'M LOOKING REMOTELY. I DON'T
SEE ANY HANDS BUT I THINK I DID
GET A TEXT MESSAGE THAT- CENTER
DORADO WOULD LIKE TO MAKE AN
OPENING RE- REMARK CENTER
DORADO ARE YOU ON. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE
FORWARD. BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH
OUR SPEAKERS I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL AND NOW.
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. 844-291-6364 WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS
CODE. FOUR FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE FIVE NINE NOW LET'S HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST PRESENTER MISTER
DAVID ME CHERYL WHO IS THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF CAJON VALLEY
UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT WELCOME
MR MAYOR SHE WROTE PLEASE TAKE
IT AWAY. THANK YOU SIR MAY I
PLEASE HAVE CONTROL THE SCREEN.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THERE IS
A OKAY YES WE CAN I'M GONNA
START MYSELF ON A FIVE MINUTE
TIMER TO BE RESPECT FOR MY
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE- IN TERMS
OF THE DIGITAL DIVIDE THIS OUR
CURRENT EIGHTH GRADE CLASS
THEY'VE HAD THEIR OWN COMPUTER
AND UBIQUITOUS WIFI FOR THEIR
LEARNING SINCE THEY WERE IN
KINDERGARTEN WE STARTED THIS
JOURNEY IN TWENTY THIRTEEN.
ASKING HOW CAN WE USE DATA
SCIENCE MACHINE LEARNING AND
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE TO MAKE
IN THE CLASSROOM MORE HUMAN
USING TECHNOLOGY NOT SIMPLY
REPLACING THE TEXTBOOKS WITH A
CHROMEBOOK HARDWARE GETS OLD
REALLY FAST WE KNOW THAT IN
CALIFORNIA. THE CONVERSATION
HAS TO BE ABOUT SOFTWARE TOOLS.
AND THE DIGITAL PROGRESS THAT'S
HAPPENING GLOBALLY SO WE CAN
USE THAT AND HARNESS THOSE. IN
THE CLASSROOM. WHEN OUR KIDS
SIGN ONTO THEIR COMPUTERS-
THEY'RE AUTOMATICALLY LOGGED
INTO ALL OF THEIR APPS AND
PROGRAMS. THIS IS PART OF THE
DATA SECURITY AND DATA PRIVACY.
THAT HAS TAKEN AS A COUPLE
YEARS TO BUILD. BEHIND THE
FIREWALL. BUT REALLY TECH
EMPOWER THE TEACHERS TO LEAVE
THAT THE SAGE OF THE STAGE. AND
ENTER A MORE PERSONALIZED
LEARNING BLENDED ROTATION TYPE
APPROACH. AND SO TWENTY
FOURTEEN WE BEGAN USING SUMMER
SCHOOL. AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TRAIN OUR TEACHERS AND OUR
STUDENTS ON HOW TO USE THE
DEVICES SMARTLY. HOW TO
MAXIMIZE INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL
GROUP INSTRUCTION. SO THAT IF
YOU LOOK WHAT KIDS ARE ON THEIR
DEVICES ARE NOT ALL ON THE SAME
PROGRAMS THERE'S ADAPTIVE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE HELPING
THEM. PERSONALIZE THEIR
LEARNING SO WE CAN PROGRESS
MONITOR AND MAKE SURE THAT EACH
CHILD. WHETHER THEY'RE LEARNING
LANGUAGE LEARNING CONTENT. OR
ARE INVESTING IN THEIR MODERN
CURRICULUM WE KNOW EXACTLY
WHERE THEY ARE. AND SO ARE
MONITORING GIVES ARE ARE BUILT
INTO THE PROGRAM YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR SHORTLY FROM OUR STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND SOME OF OUR
PARENTS. AND THIS. IS WHAT
DISTANCE LEARNING LOOKS LIKE IN
APRIL. SINCE TWO FOURTEEN WITH
TWENTY ON A PLAN LEARNING MODEL
WHERE WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
STUDENTS IN PERSON WITH THEIR
LEARNING BUT WE'RE ALSO WORKING
WITH SOMEONE. AND THAT
TRANSITIONS RIGHT NOW
BEAUTIFULLY TOWARDS DISTANCE
LEARNING. IT'S ALLOWING US TO
KEEP THOSE PERSONAL CONNECTIONS
AND ALLOWING US TO WORK WITH
THE STUDENTS TO THEIR
COMPUTERS. TO CONTINUE THE
SUCCESS THAT WE'VE HAD WITH
THEIR EDUCATION. WE GET TO DO
OUR WEEKLY VIDEO CHATS THERE'S
NO. KIDS GET TO SEE THEIR
TEACHERS. THEY GET TO SEE THEIR
FRIENDS. WE'RE ABLE TO START
THAT ENABLE BECAUSE OUR KIDS
AND TEACHERS ALREADY HAVE THEIR
OWN TECHNOLOGY. AND PROGRAMS
YES THE WAY WE OPERATE SCHOOL
NOW RIGHT IT JUST DEPENDS ON
YOUR DEFINITION AIRINGS ON THAT
THE PROGRAM IS ACCESS. TWENTY
ONE PILOTS BASIC SKILLS.
SUBJECT MATTER AND HOME VALLEY
MODERN CURRICULUM WHICH
INCLUDES TO ADD. COMPUTER
SCIENCE. SOCIAL. EMOTIONAL
LEARNING AS WELL AS WORLD. SO
WE BE ABLE TO. STUDENT PROGRESS
AND- USING COMPUTERS. HONORING
THE NEED FOR. PLAY AS WELL AS
FAMILY TIME FOR ALL MEMBERS IN
OUR LEARNING COMMUNITY. THAT
WAS THE FIRST ITERATION IN
APRIL ONE OF THE THINGS WE
LEARNED RIGHT AWAY IS THAT A
LOT OF OUR OUR KIDS WEREN'T
ENGAGING AND THE DISTANCE
LEARNING LARGELY BECAUSE BOTH
PARENTS NEEDED TO WORK AND IN A
LOW INCOME COMMUNITY PARENTS
ARE GONNA GO TO WORK BUT- FOOD
ON THE TABLE. AND SOME OF THE
BEST NINE FOURTH GRADERS BEGAN
BABYSITTERS FOR THE YOUNGER
CHILDREN AND SO WE PUT TOGETHER
A THREE CHILD CARE CENTER
WORKER PROGRAM. SHAMAN LONG
FORCE MY WIFE IS A NURSE. YEAH
KIDS SECOND AND THIRD GRADE.
WHEN WE HEARD THIS PROBE. IT
WAS IT WAS REALLY A RELIEF FOR
US BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN A LITTLE
STRESSED IS NOT KNOWING HE SAID
WHAT THE GONNA DO THIS WITH
BOTH WORK. LESS FOR US WE
ACTUALLY WAS WEAK THE FOR
LEARNING. WE DIDN'T KNOW THAT I
WHAT WE'RE BUT- GIBBOSA TO GO
TO WORK AND DIDN'T HAVE A
OPTION. WE OUR SCHOOLS IN
PROVIDED THE LEARNING.
ENRICHMENT IS A GLITCH. AND THE
MEALS THAT THEY RELY ON AS WELL.
WE CAN USE THE SUMMERTIME CARE
ACT. SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
SAFETY ROLES AND CINNAMON
INCREASED. LEARNING PROGRAMS
ALL TWENTY SEVEN OF OUR SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES. WITH THE GOAL OF
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING AND
CONNECTEDNESS IN MIND. SOME OF
MY FAVORITE TAKE AWAYS. ARE
SEEING OUR STUDENTS AND STAFF
BEING EXCITED. TO BE WORKING
WITH ONE ANOTHER. TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE A LAUGH ON THE FIELD
SAFELY TO BE ABLE TO COOK TO BE
ABLE TO CREATE. IN OUR
MAKERSPACE AND IT'S BEEN A FUN
AND EXCITING WAY. FOR OUR STAFF
AND STUDENTS TO PRACTICE WHAT
OUR NEW SCHOOL YEAR MIGHT LOOK
LIKE IN THAT GAVE OUR UNIONS TO
TRUST. OPEN UP THIS IS A GREAT
CLIP I DON'T HAVE TIME I THINK
THE WAY LEARNING- THAT ALL OF
OUR SCHOOLS ARE OPEN WE
PRACTICE SUCH A DISTINCT ALL
THE RULES IN PLACE AND CONTINUE
THE OPTION OF DISTANCE RUNNING
OR IN PERSON LEARNING. AS YOUR
BROTHERS WILL BACK UP. WHEN
THEY'RE ABLE TO. OUR SCHOOLS
ARE PLACE FOR. GO FIRST. FOR
FOOD AND THAT IN THAT ROUTINE
AND TIME OF OUR LIVES WITH. THE
SCHOOLS ARE JUST REALLY MAKE A
C. PLACE FOR. PERSONAL FEEL
THAT WHEN STUDENTS WALK IN THE
DOOR THERE WATCH INTO A TO. AND
BE THERE FAST SINGLE DAY. IT'S
GOING BE. WEARING A MASK THIS
IS BE TEARING SANITIZING AND
LAW IN. BECAUSE AND ONE LAST
ACTUALLY THAT WAS THERE LAST
MUCH MORE TO BUT IT'S FIVE
MINUTES INTO SECOND THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU MISTER SUPERINTENDED
THAT WAS REAL HARD TO SEE AND
THANK YOU FOR STAYING SO CLOSE
ON TIME THAT IS MUCH
APPRECIATED. NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM SAN JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOTH FROM A SUPER BOWL
FROM A DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT
AND A TEACHERS REPRESENTATIVE
WE'LL BEGIN WITH MS BENSON
ELLIE AND THEN GO TO MS BROWN.
YOU MAY PERCEIVE AS WELL AS AN
ALLEY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
JUST GONNA SET UP SO. YOU CAN
SEE MONEY. EVERYBODY CAN SEE
THAT WE CAN GREAT. AGAIN MY
NAME IS MELISSA BASS MILLIE I
AM THAT DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT
FOR SAN JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I HAVE SHANNON
BROWN WITH ME WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE ST
ONE TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SAN JUAN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WE'RE
LOCATED IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND INCLUDES BOTH URBAN AND
SUBURBAN NEIGHBORHOODS ACROSS
SEVENTY FIVE SQUARE MILES. OUR
CURRENT ENROLLMENT IS JUST A
BAD NIGHT. THIRTY NINE THOUSAND
STUDENTS ACROSS OUR SIXTY FOUR
SCHOOLS. AB ARMAMENT 47% ARE
IDENTIFIED CURRENTLY AS LOW
INCOME THIS IS A DECREASE FROM
LAST YEAR WHERE IT WAS FIFTY
FOUR PERCENT. 12% OUR
IDENTIFIED AS STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND 15% ARE
IDENTIFIED AS ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. WITH 12% OF OUR TOTAL
POPULATION HAVING AN IMMIGRANT
STATUS MEANING THEY WERE NOT
BORN IN THE US AND HAVE
ATTENDED SCHOOLS U. S. SCHOOLS
FOR FEWER THAN THREE YEARS. AND
YOU CAN SEE OUR TOP THREE
LANGUAGES IN OUR SYSTEM OR
SPANISH DARI AND PASHTO. IN THE
SPIRIT OF CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT THERE WERE SEVERAL
LESSONS WE LEARNED IN THE
SPRING THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
BUILD UPON FOR IMPROVE DISTANCE
LEARNING. PROGRAM IN THE FALL.
AS WE PRESENT YOU TODAY WILL
PRESENT WE WILL TOUCH UPON EACH
OF THESE LESSONS LEARNED AND
HIGHLIGHTED HOW OUR PARTNERSHIP
HELPED US IMPROVE UPON OUR WORK
IN THE SPRING. GIVEN TIME
CONSTRAINTS WE PUT KEY TOPICS
AND IDEAS ON OUR SITES
RECOGNIZING THAT WE WILL NOT
HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO GOING TO
EACH AREA IN GREAT DETAIL.
RIGHT SO ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS THAT WE REALIZED IS THAT
WE HAVE TO SUPPORTER
PRACTITIONERS IN THIS
ADJUSTMENT. AND HONESTLY IN
NORMAL TIMES IT'S DIFFICULT TO
COVER ALL OF THE STANDARDS AND
IN OUR VIRTUAL MODEL OR IN A
HYBRID MODEL THAT CHALLENGE
INCREASES. SO ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS WE SET OUT TO DO OVER
THE SUMMER WAS TO TASK
ADMINISTRATORS AND
PRACTITIONERS. IN REVIEWING
STANDARDS BY GRADE LEVEL AND
CONTENT AREA AND LIFTING UP THE
POWER STANDARDS TO IDENTIFY
EITHER THE POWER CENTERS OR
BUILDING BLOCKS STANDARDS. ONCE
THEY IDENTIFY THOSE WE NAME
THEM THE ESSENTIAL STANDARDS.
IDENTIFYING THESE STANDARDS IT
CREATED MORE SYSTEM ALIGNMENT
AS WELL AS ALLOWING TIME FOR
TEACHERS TO PRIORITIZE
RELATIONSHIPS. AND COMMUNITY
BUILDING SO THAT STUDENTS DO
FEEL CONNECTED EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE IN A VIRTUAL WORLD. YOU
CAN ALSO SEE SOME AND TRAINING
MODULES THAT WERE CREATED- I
WOULD DO WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
LESSEN BANKS. SO WE CO SELECTED
PRACTITIONERS TO DESIGN LESSONS
TO- SERVE EITHER FOR A FLIPPED
CLASSROOM WHERE STUDENTS WATCH
THE LESSON DURING ASYNCHRONOUS
TIME AND THEN WHEN THEY'RE IN
SYNCHRONOUS TIME WITH THEIR
CLASSROOM TEACHER. THEY THE
TEACHER CAN PROVIDE
DIFFERENTIATION. THE LESSON
BIKE LESSONS ALSO SERVED AS
MODEL LESSONS FOR COLLEAGUES.
AS YOU CAN SEE WE ALSO HAD TO
IDENTIFY TIME TO PREPARE. ALLOW
PEOPLE TO PREPARE TO ALLOW THEM
TO COLLABORATE AND WE
PRIORITIZE SOCIAL JUSTICE. IN
OTHER LESSONS LEARNED WAS THE
NEED TO STRENGTHEN SCHOOL HOME
CONNECTIONS. AND SO WE CAN IN A
LEARNING LESSONS FROM THE
SPRING WE REALLY FOCUSED ON
STRENGTHENING OUR COMMUNICATION
EFFORTS REALLY KNOWING THAT
CLEAR AND TIMELY COMMUNICATION.
IS OFTEN A CHALLENGE BUT IT'S
SO IMPORTANT DURING THIS TIME
WHERE INFORMATION IS CHANGING
AND WEEKLY AND AT TIMES DALY.
ANOTHER PIECE OF STRENGTHENING
SCHOOL TO HOME CONNECTIONS WAS
REALLY VALUING FAMILY CHOICE
AND WITHIN OUR SYSTEM AS A PART
OF OUR PLANNING FOR A LEARNING
MODEL CONTINUE M. DURING THE
SPEED INTERNET. AND SO BETWEEN
THE DISTRICT AND THE
ASSOCIATION THERE'S A SHARED
GOAL AND THAT WE HAVE EXPANDING
PROVIDING CHOICE- ACROSS OUR
LEARNING MODEL CONTINUE ON SO
THAT WE CAN POSSIBLY MEDICAID
AS IT DECLINE ENROLLMENT. AND
SO THERE'S A COUPLE EACH KEY
AREAS WHERE WE IDENTIFIED THAT
WE WOULD WORK TOGETHER TO
EXPAND. AND ONE WAS OUR K.
EIGHT HOME SCHOOL PROGRAM THAT
EXISTED PRE COALBED. IT GREW
FROM SEVENTY THREE STUDENTS IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
STUDENTS THIS CURRENT SCHOOL
YEAR. IN ADDITION WE HAD
ANOTHER INDEPENDENT STUDY
PROGRAM FOR GRADES NINE THROUGH
TWELVE. AND CREE COVE MADE IT
WAS A HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN THAT
PROGRAM AND CURRENTLY WORKING
HEARING ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
STUDENTS THAT PROGRAM. AND SO
WE BELIEVE THAT BY WORKING
TOGETHER TO EXPAND TO THESE
OPTIONS AND IT EXPANDED IN THE
TERMS OF THE SCOPE OF STOCKING
AS AS TRAINING AND THE SUPPORT
FOR THE PRACTITIONER. THAT BY
EXPANDING THE OPTIONS AND
HELPED US MITIGATE POTENTIAL
DECLINING ENROLLMENT AS WE ONLY
SAW A DROP IN OUR OVERALL
MOMENT JUST UNDER TWO HUNDRED
STUDENTS BELOW OUR PROJECTIONS.
ANOTHER AREA THAT WAS A LESSON
LEARNED FOR US WAS TO INCREASE
OUR SAFETY NETS AND ARE TIERED
RESPONSE AND THIS VIRTUAL
WORLD. AND SO ONE PIECE THAT WE
WORKED ON TOGETHER AND THAT WAS
TO REESTABLISH OUR INITIAL PRE
CODED INDICATORS THAT WOULD BE
AN INITIAL INDICATORS
TRIGGERING AND LAYERS OF
SUPPORT FOR OUR STUDENTS. AND
SO REALLY DIGGING BACK INTO THE
ATTENDANCE TAKING PRACTICE AS A
FIRST RESPONSE SYSTEM Q. AND
IDENTIFY STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT
ENGAGING OR PARTICIPATING IN
DISTANCE LEARNING. AND THEN
LAYERING AND CRATES AND OTHER
ASSESSMENT PRACTICES THAT WE
JOINTLY WORKED ON TOGETHER. IN
ADDITION WE ALSO HAD TO
REIMAGINE OUR SUPPORTS THAT WE
ARE FORMALLY PROVIDED. I AM AN
IN PERSON FORMAT TO SEE HOW WE
MIGHT PROVIDE THOSE IN VIRTUAL
SENSE. AND SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
STAFF WHO WORK AND SUPPORT
CENTERS THESE ARE STAFFS THAT
ARE SOCIAL. OR SAYS FOR VARYING
FROM TECHNO NEEDS AND HOW IS
BEING TO FOOD. MOST SUPPORT
SESSION THROUGH. HE WHICH IS
EITHER ONE TO ONE AND SMALL
GROUP OUR WHOLE GROUP SESSIONS
WE ALSO HAD AN ACADEMIC
SUPPORTS THAT ARE LAYERED IN
ANOTHER KEEP PEACE THAT WE WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT IS AND HER SOUL IS
A PARTNERSHIP THAT WE ENTERED
AND BUDGET IS A CONCIERGE
SERVICE THAT CONNECTS
COMMUNITIES TO RELIABLE HIGH
QUALITY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND I AM IT IS OFFER TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN EITHER BY PHONE OR
WEBSITE DOES IT SUPPORT
SERVICES OFFERED TO OUR
STUDENTS FAMILIES AND STAFF AND
WE LAUNCHED A AND MID AUGUST
WITH NEARLY A THOUSAND
ENQUIRIES AND FROM OUR STUDENTS
AND STAFF WITH MOST OF THE
ENQUIRIES BEING FOCUSED AROUND
STUDENTS. AND ALSO LOOKING AT-
SUPPORTS IN ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION. RIGHT SOURCE A
LITTLE BIT INTERNET LINE HOW
POSSIBLE BUT WE WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU THE ALL OF OUR SIDE
LETTERS OF AGREEMENT DURING
THIS TIME HAVE BEEN CREATED A
SHARED GOOGLE DOC WE DID NOT
EXCHANGE FORMAL PROPOSALS. WE
IDENTIFIED THAT WE HAD SHARED
INTERESTS FROM ME THAT. WE
WANTED TO IMPROVE UPON WHAT WE
DID IN THE SPRING. SO OUR
PROCESS INCLUDED REFLECTING ON
WHAT WORKS IN EDUCATION AND IN
PERSON SCHOOLING. AS WELL AS
REFLECTING ON- WHAT WE NEED TO
APPROVE IMPROVE UPON IN THE
SPRING. SO ONE OF THE MAIN
THINGS THAT WE IDENTIFIED WAS
THAT EACH SO WE NEED TO CREATE
A SYSTEM. THAT ALLOWS EACH
STUDENT TO GET WHAT THEY NEED
RATHER THAN ALL STUDENTS
RECEIVING THE SAME THING. SO WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. TO CALL
OUT THAT OUR DISTANCE LEARNING
SIDE LETTERS ARE CONSISTENTLY
MISUNDERSTOOD. IN ORDER TO
UNDERSTAND UNDERSTAND THE
STRUCTURE OF AGREEMENT YOU NEED
TO CAN WHAT IN PER SCHOOLING.
LIKE STUDENTS DON'T RECEIVE
FIVE JUST HOURS OF DIRECT
INSTRUCTION IN FACT I WOULD
ARGUE THAT'S NOT GOOD PEDAGOGY.
ARE THEY RECEIVING. AND THEN
ENGAGING. PRACTICE AND THAT IS
PACKED IT GOES BACK AND FORTH
THROUGHOUT THE DAY. VERY
CONTENT. SO WE COMPARE OUR IN
OF SYNCHRON TIME TO DIRECT
INSTRUCTION AN INDEPENDENT WORK
TO ASYNCHRONOUS TIME IN OUR
AGREEMENT OUR MINIMUM
SYNCHRONOUS TIME IS VERY
SPECIFICALLY- DEFINED TO MEAN A
CLASSROOM TEACHER ALL STUDENTS
AND INTERACTING ON ZOOM. OUR
SECONDARY AGREEMENT IS
STRUCTURED MUCH MORE LIKE A
TRADITIONAL SECONDARY DAY WHERE
THE KIDS ATTEND SCHOOL IN
PERIODS. IN ELEMENTARY
RESTRUCTURED THE SCHEDULE BY
FIRST IDENTIFYING THE CLASSROOM
TEACHER TIME AND THEN ALLOWING
THE OTHER RACK ON SERVICES. THE
PLANNED AROUND A TEACHER
INSTRUCT. THIS THEY GO UP AND
THE MEN INCLUDE KIND AREA. IN
AREAS SUCH AS MUSIC ART HE
SCIENCE SPANISH FOREIGN
LANGUAGE THIS. WE ALSO HAVE OUR
EMAIL DE TIME FOR TO SUPPORT
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS. THIS
IS. IN ADDITION TO THE GREAT.
MENASCO DESIGNATED GIVEN US FOR
THE STUDENTS THAT ARE LEARNING
ENGLISH ADDITIONALLY WITH
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES DOES
HAPPEN- VARIETY OF WAYS
DEPENDING ON THE- SO IN LAYERED
ON SERVE LIKE SPEECH AND A- HE-
THEY WOULD WORK WITH CLASSROOM.
CHOI THE OF TIME TO DELIVER
THAT SERVICE. RESOURCE THOSE
THOSE TEACHERS WOULD WORK WITH
THE KERR T. EITHER TO JOIN THE
ZOOM OR TWO WHOLE
DIFFERENTIATION SESSIONS OR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SESSIONS
AFTERWARDS. THE ACADEMIC
INTERVENTION SUPPORT THAT WAS
PROVIDED THAT COULD BE PROVIDED
BY A CLASSROOM TEACHER IT CAN
ALSO BE PROVIDED BY SOMEONE WHO
IS AN ACADEMIC INTERVENTION
SPECIALIST WITHIN OUR SYSTEM.
SO HOW ARE TO START WITH HOW WE
STARTED OUR ON THIS JOURNEY WAS
WE HAVE A FOUNDATION OF TRUST.
AND THE UNDERPINNINGS OF THAT
IS THAT WE DON'T ARGUE ABOUT
WHO CARES MORE ABOUT KIDS WE
CARE ABOUT CATS. ALL OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN OUR SYSTEM
CAME INTO THE WORK BECAUSE WE
WANT TO CREATE THE HIGHEST
QUALITY EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT
WE CAN'T. IN ADDITION OUR
PARTNERSHIP ALLOWS US TO
CALIBRATE WITH EACH OTHER AND
BUILD THAT SHARED UNDERSTANDING
THROUGH THE TRUSTING
RELATIONSHIP WHICH ULTIMATELY
IN TURN REDUCES CONFUSION FOR
FAMILIES BECAUSE THERE'S
CLARITY AND PROGRAM WHEN WE'RE
ABLE TO START. DISTANCE
LEARNING IN THE FALL. AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY OUR PARTNERSHIP
WHAT WE SITE IS B. WE SITE DEEP
IN EXPANSION THROUGH THIS WORK
TOGETHER WHETHER IT WAS BECAUSE
WE HAD TO SEND THE SIZE
TOGETHER B. ON TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION. AND
FEEDBACK THAT WAS AND THAT'S
CONTINUING TO COME OUR WAY- SO
WHETHER IT'S- IT'S FANTASIZING
AND SHARING UNDERSTANDING
AROUND THAT OR WORKING TOGETHER
TO IMPROVE SERVICES AND
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS. WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO RESPOND TO THE
CHALLENGES WITH CREATIVE
CREATIVITY AND INNOVATION. AND
CLARITY WHICH ULTIMATELY HAS TO
HELP TO MINIMIZE CONFLICTS AND
CONFUSION ON OUR SITE LEVEL. IN
AND THIS IS THE KIND OF OUR-
AND RIVER GRATEFUL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY SHARE OUR WORK WITH
YOU. LADIES YOU BOLT THAT WAS
EXCELLENT I REALLY LIKE THE
LIST LESSONS LEARNED AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT WAS BUILT ON A
FOUNDATION OF TRUST WE SHOULD
ALL. GET TO THAT LEVEL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM A MERRY JANE BURKE WHO IS
THE MARIN COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS. MS BURKE PROCEED
WHEN YOU ARE READY. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M VERY- VERY
HONORED TO BE WITH YOU AND WANT
TO EXPRESS MY THANKS TO ALL OF
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE. AS I GIVE
YOU INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING IN OUR
COMMUNITY. IN MARIN AND I JUST
WANTED BALLOTS THAT. MIGHT
COLLEAGUES OTHER SEVEN COUNTIES.
WHAT ALL HAPPENED VERY SIMILAR
STORY TO YOU I DON'T WANT I'LL
BE. THAT THEY ARE FOR. ON DOING.
WE CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
OUR KIDS TO SCHOOL. AS SOON AS
WE SAY. ODD TEND NOT WORK AND-
BUT YOU CAN COLLABORATE HOW
OTHERS IN A WAY THAT. ONCE NEED
CAN BE. SO I'LL BE SPEAKING
PRIMARY ABOUT SPECIAL ED. SO I
ALSO TO START BY GOING BACK.
FOR MOMENT AND NOT JUST TO WHAT
YOU. FROM US OF MY- A WEEK TO
SEE. PLANNING TAKE BACK TO AND-
AS SOON AS WE- OUR OWN. OF WHAT
WAS. IN TERMS. MOVING TO A JUST
MY- AND IN MARCH WE ARE. AT
CHILD CARE. FOR FIRST RATE.
DOCTORS NURSE OTHER ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. AND DURING THAT TIME.
ALL BEGAN I DO. THE PROGRAM. IN
STRUCTURES THAT WERE. NOT BE
PASSED FOR TO OPEN OUR
ESPECIALLY CLASSES PERSON.
EVERY HAS BEEN BY BY FINES
FIVE. HEALTH. ART SHOULD LOOK
LIKE. HOW DO WE CHECK THAT A
CHILDREN AND STAFF ARE HEALTHY
WHEN THEY COME INTO CLASS ON
HOW TO WE ESSENTIALLY DECLINED
OUR CLASSROOMS SO THAT THEY'RE
SAFE ONCE THE PP THAT'S-
NECESSARY SO DURING THE PILOT-
POP UP CHILD CARE WE WERE ABLE
TO PUT TOGETHER. VARIETY OF
PROTOCOLS BEGIN TO DOCUMENT
THEM AND PROVIDE TRAININGS TWO
THOUSAND THE COMMUNITY RELATED
TELLS ALL. HE WE BECAME AWARE
AS ABOUT ACROSS STATE. THAT FOR
ME OF OUR WITH SPECIAL NEEDS-
AS MENTIONED BY SOMEONE ELSE
THOSE CHILDREN THAT NEED WORK
TO GET THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES
THAT DISTANCE LEARNING WHAT NOT
WORKING THE PROGRAM THAT OUR
OFFICE OPERATES PRIMARILY. IS
FOR STUDENTS HAVE HAD VERY
COMPLEX LEARNING NEEDS IT WOULD
BE CONSIDERED IN THE MODERATE
TO SEVERE RANGE MANY WITH
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS.
AND SO IT DEFINITELY WASN'T
WORKING HOW THE INFORMATION WAS
COMING NOT JUST FROM PARENTS
BUT FROM OUR TEACHERS AND SO
KNOWING THAT ARE SPECIAL AND
PROGRAMS ARE PRIMARILY SMALL
COHORTS BETWEEN. EIGHT TO
TWELVE STUDENTS WE DECIDED TO
GO AHEAD AND DEVELOP A PILOT
FOLLOWING THE PROTOCOLS THAT WE
LEARNED AND IN CLOSE CONTACT
WITH ALL THE STAFF WHETHER IT'S
ADMINISTRATORS. LIVESTOCK OR
THE TEACHER SO I STARTING IN
MAY WE HAD HIGHLIGHTS THAT WERE
BEING OFFERED IN DURING THAT
TIME WE LEARNED MORE REFINED
FOR THERE ARE PROTOCOLS.
PROVIDED FOCUS GROUPS FOR STAFF
FOR PARENTS AND THEN ULTIMATELY
DECIDED TO OPERATE ALL OF OUR
SPECIAL ED PROGRAMS IN PERSON
ALL FOR THE SUMMER SO THIS LAST
SUMMER. WE HAD STUDENTS COME
INTO PLAY IN PERSON ALL WE DID
A SURVEY WITH PARENTS 92% WERE.
RAISING THEIR HANDS SAYING YES
WE LOVE OUR STUDENTS BACK AND
BACK IN SCHOOL- WE HAD TEACHERS
WHO WERE. SAFE AND WE WERE ABLE
TO OPERATE VERY VERY
SUCCESSFULLY HOW WE WORKED WITH
DOCTORS- WHO HAD. ESSENTIALLY
PROP PROVIDED APPROVAL THAT
MORE MEDICALLY FRAGILE STUDENTS
WOULD BE ABLE TO. ATTEND SCHOOL
IN A PHASED MANNER AND WERE
ABLE TO STAND UP ALL OF OUR ALL
OF OUR PROGRAMS I'M AT THIS
POINT- WE HAVE FIFTY CLASSROOMS
THAT ARE OPERATING ONE IS
TOTALLY VIRTUAL AND THAT
STUDENTS WHO ARE. PARENTS ARE
EITHER NOT READY OR ARE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY THINK
THEIR MEDICAL SITUATION. DOES
NOT YET LET THEM SCHOOL AND
OTHER THAN. OF THE REST OF OUR
PROGRAM ARE EIGHTY FIVE PER OR
STUDENTS WHO ARE IN PERSON AND
OTHERS WHO ARE CHANGING USING A
BLENDED APPROACH WE HAVE A LIVE
STREAMING STRUCTURE SO THAT
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO I CAN'T
ATTEND IN PERSON THEY CAN STILL
BE THERE FOR- ACTIVITIES. WITH
THEIR CLASS AND- I'M- SORRY I
DON'T TOO LONG WITHIN IT THAT
WAS MY- BUT WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT. WHEN A PARENT HAS NOT.
RISKY TO PARTICIPATE IN CLASS
ON A DAILY THAT THEY RAISE
THEIR AND SAY HEY WE'RE CHECK
BACK SO. BOB LINE IS WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH ALL
OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS AND DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO BRING BACK
THE MOST VULNERABLE A STUDENTS
IN OUR UNITY. NOW I NEED THESE
OPPORTUNITIES IN ORDER TO
ACCESS LEARNING I'LL STOP THERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS BURKE OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HIGHLIGHTING
PUBLIC CHILD CARE THAT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND ALSO
THE GREAT WORK THAT YOU HAVE
DONE AND SPECIAL ED BEING DONE
IN PERSON. ALL RIGHT NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO PROCEED TO OUR LAST
WITNESSFOR THIS PANEL IT IS A
NEEDED SHIRLEY FROM CORONA NO
COURT NORTH. CORONA NORCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT SURELY
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. BUT AFTERNOON THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME THIS AFTERNOON.
AND SIMILAR TO OUR PREVIOUS
GUESTS I DO NOT HAVE A
PRESENTATION BUT I HAVE WRITTEN
UP. SOME INFORMATION THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU
AND WHEN ASKED TO SPEAK TODAY-
THERE THREE SPECIFIC AREAS
THAT. I WAS ASKED TO GIVE UP SO
I AM THE COORDINATOR. OF OUR
SCHOOL COUNSELING SERVICES. SO
SIMILAR TO. THE DISTRICTS THAT
WERE C. TODAY AT MANY OF OUR
JUST. ACROSS UNITED. PROBABLY
THE WORLD. OUR MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS ARE EXTREME. BRANCH
AND SO BUT I TO SPEAK TO TODAY
IS WHAT ARE WE JUST SEEING HOW
WE ADDRESS THE CONCERNS AND SO-
THREE AREAS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT. CABOT LOOK TOWARDS THE
DRESSING OUR BUT OUR SCHOOL
COUNSELORS AND ONE IS THAT WE
HAVE A POSITION CALLED AND
DINNER XIN COUNSELOR AND THIS
INTERVENTION COUNSELOR IS. ONLY
AT OUR HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL AT
THIS TIME BUT WE DO HAVE SCHOOL
COUNSELORS TO K. THROUGH TWELVE
AND ARE VERY LARGE DISTRICT BUT
AT THE INTERVENTION COUNSELOR.
IS IT ONE OF OUR HIGH SCHOOL
COUNSELORS WHO PREDOMINANTLY
WORKS WITH SOCIAL EMOTIONAL- IN
THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL DEMAND FOR
SCHOOL COUNSELING AND IN THE
TIER TWO AND THREE WHICH IS THE
MORE INTENSIVE- SERVICES THEY-
WORK IN SMALL GROUPS INDIVIDUAL
COUNSELING AND ALSO IN THE
REFERRING OUT OF SERVICES. THEY
WORK WITH IT STUDENTS WHO ARE
IDENTIFIED AS HIGH RISK THEY
PRESENT WITH SEVERE BEHAVIORAL
OR EMOTIONAL CHALLENGES AND
THESE SERVICES ARE PROVIDED
THROUGH. SHORT TERM CRISIS
COUNSELING GROUP COUNSELING AND
OR A REFERRALS TO THE
COMMUNITY- AND COMMUNITY
AGENCIES BECAUSE SIMILAR TO-
ALL OTHER DISTRICTS IN OUR
STATE WE ARE NOT ON CAMPUS OUR
COUNSELORS ARE PROVIDING THESE
SERVICES TO RESUME. THROUGH
PHONE CALLS THROUGH GOOGLE ME-
THEY ARE DOING WHAT THEY CAN TO
REACH OUR STUDENTS TO GET FROM
THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED.
ANOTHER ASPECT- OF OUR SCHOOLS
COUNSELING PROGRAM IS A FOSTER
YOUTH COUNSELOR AND SO I KNOW
EARLIER USE INTERNET WE WERE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT FOSTER
CANCELING YOUR FOSTER YOUTH
BUT- I LIKE TO REALLY HIDE I
HIGHLIGHT OUR FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAM- WE HAVE EIGHT
COUNSELOR. ON A SIGN EVEN TWO
IS DEVOTED TO WORKING WITH OUR
FOSTER STUDENTS ALONG WITH
WORKING WITH OUR FOSTER-
COUNSELORS AT THE SCHOOL SITE
SO ALL OF OUR COUNSELORS WORK
WITH OUR FOSTER STUDENTS THEY
PROVIDE- MONTHLY MEETINGS FOR
OUR SCHOOLS. FOR OUR SCHOOL
COUNCIL FOR STUDENTS AND MAKING
SURE THAT THEY ARE CONNECTED
WHAT SERVICES DO THEY NEED DO
WE HAVE COMPUTERS THAT WE CAN
OFFER THEM DO WE HAVE RESOURCES
EVE SOMETHING. LIKE TOOTHPASTE
BOOKS CLOTHING AND WE- GO ABOVE
AND BEYOND FOR OUR FOSTER
STUDENTS AND ACTUALLY WE- COLOR
FOSTER STUDENTS THE ALL STARS
AND WE- OFFER ALL STARRED
PROGRAM AT ALL AND CHIEF TWELVE
SCHOOLS IN OUR DISTRICT. AND IT
ACTUALLY- JUST RECENTLY WAS
ANNOUNCED THAT OUR ALL STAR
PROGRAM IS A GOLDEN BALL WINNER
SO WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING WITH OUR
FOSTER STUDENTS- ARE FOSTER
CANCERS NAME IS JANICE SHE ALSO
WORKS REALLY CLOSELY WITH OUR
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO
MAKE SURE THAT. OUR DATA IS
ACCURATE- ONE THING. TO NOTE
ABOUT FOSTER YOUTH AND THE DATA
IS THAT OFTEN TIMES THEY GET
LOST IN THE SYSTEM AS WE MOVE
FROM SITE TO SITE DISTRICT TO
DISTRICT COUNTY TO COUNTY AND
SO SHE WORKS REALLY CLOSELY TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR DATA IS UP
TO DATE AND ACCURATE. AND THAT
WE ARE KEEPING TRACK OF OUR
STUDENTS. ONE OTHER. IS MAKING
THAT OUR STAFF TREE AND SO WHAT
WE RECOGNIZED IS THAT. OUR
TEACHERS ALTHOUGH IN THE PAST
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN FIRST AND
FOREMOST IN FRONT OF THE
STUDENTS IT IS EVEN MORE LIKELY
THAT THEY ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ENGAGING FULLY WITH THEIR
STUDENTS BEFORE OUR SCHOOL
COUNSELORS BEFORE
ADMINISTRATORS AND SO OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS THROUGH THE
ADOPTION OF THE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO FORTY SIX AND EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN WE DO
AND HAVE HAD SUICIDE PREVENTION
POLICIES AND BOARD POLICY IN
PLACE FOR OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND WE HAVE ALONG WITH THAT
ASSEMBLY BILL ADOPTED COUNTRY
NEEDLE WHICH IS A SELF PACED
COURSE THAT OUR STAFF TAKES. TO
LEARN ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUICIDE PREVENTION SO ALL OF
OUR TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATION
TAKE THIS COURSE AND WE HIGHLY
HIGHLY RECOMMEND OUR CLASSIFIED
STAFF TO TAKE THIS COURSE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT OFTENTIMES
ARE CLASSIFIED STAFF ARE FIRST
AND FOREMOST WORKING WITH SOME
OF OUR AND MOST AT RISK
STUDENTS. WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
AND TO ENGAGE WITH OUR STUDENTS
THROUGH THIS VIRTUAL TIME IS
ALSO CONDUCTING NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE MEETING THEM
WHERE THEY ARE AT WHAT. AND
WHAT DO THEY NEED FROM US IS IT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IS IT A
COMPUTER IS IT FOOD WHAT ARE
THOSE NEEDS THAT WE CAN OFFER
FROM THE SCHOOL DISTRICT. WE'RE
OFFERING OUR SCHOOL COUNSELORS
OFFERING GROUP AND INDIVIDUAL
COUNSELING. WHERE OFFERING
MORE- CLASSROOM LESSONS AND I
THINK THEY'VE EVER- OFFERED IN
THE PAST THEY'RE ALSO WORKING
WITH STUDENTS THROUGH WHAT
THEY'RE CALLING LUNCH BUNCHES
AND SO OFTEN TIMES MAYBE THEY
DON'T HAVE TIME TO OFFER A
CLASSROOM LESSON. BUT THEY'RE
OFFERING THEIR TIME DURING A
LUNCH BUNCH. TO WORK WITH
STUDENTS TO JUST LEARN AS A SKI.
OR A COVER. OUR STUDENTS ARE
SO- ENGAGED BUT DISENGAGED AT
THE SAME TIME THEY DON'T HAVE
THEIR COMPLETE CAMERAS ON THERE
MAYBE NOT PARTICIPATING IN
CLASSES THIS LUNCH BUNCH OFFERS
THIS KIND OF ENGAGEMENT AND
SOCIALIZATION. WHAT WE ARE
DOING DIFFERENTLY SINCE-
COLLUDED IN SINCE WE BEEN OUT-
SIMILAR TO- ADD MARY JANE
BEFORE WE I THINK THAT THE SAME
THING OKAY IT'S GONNA BE ABOUT
A MONTH- BUT WHAT CAN WE DO-
BUT WHAT HAVE WE BEEN DOING SO.
EVERYTHING IS BEING OFFERED
VIRTUAL MY COUNSELORS HAVE
LITERALLY TURN ON A DIME TO
SERVE OUR STUDENTS AND THEY ARE
WORKING AS A TEAM THEY ARE
PLAYING TO PEOPLE STRINGS THEY
ARE LOOKING TO INTERESTS. WE
ARE PUSHING OUT NEWSLETTERS TO
FAMILIES HOW CAN YOU BE
INVOLVED WHAT SHOULD YOU BE
LOOKIG FOR WHAT ARE SOME
IMPORTANT THINGS TO BE-
INFORMATION TO HAVE. AND THEY
HAVE ALSO. AND I DID SEND SOME
INFORMATION BEFORE AND I'M
HOPEFUL THAT YOU WILL ALL BE
ABLE TO REVIEW IT AND ART WE'VE
HAD AYE WHATEVER CANCERS CREATE
A VIRTUAL CALL IN A ROOM. THAT
IS A REALLY COOL AND UNIQUE
RESOURCE AND- WE'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN RECOGNIZED ACROSS THE
WORLD FOR IT WE GOT SOME
INFORMATION HAT PEOPLE IN ASIA
ARE USING IT- PEOPLE IN ENGLAND
AND- DISTRICTS FROM ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES ARE ASKING IF
THEY CAN UTILIZE A VIRTUAL
CALMING ROOM AND IT'S A PLACE
FIRST. FAMILIES AND STUDENTS TO
GO AND- COLOR PLAY A GAME I
TAKE SOME DEEP. AND IT'S A
REALLY FIND IT UNIQUE I'M KIND
OF COOL INVENTIVE WAY TO ENGAGE
WITH OUR STUDENTS. ALL MANY OF
OUR SITES HAVE BEEN CREATED
WITH- CAN UNIVERSAL CANCERS
HAVE CREATED WEBSITE SO THAT
THEY CAN ENGAGE WITH THEIR
FAMILIES. WE'VE ALSO RECENTLY
HAD A DISTRICT COLLEGE FAIR ON
VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING IS DONE
VIRTUALLY AND THEN MANY OF THEM
ARE. ALSO NAVIGATING AND
REACHING OUT TO FAMILIES
THROUGH FACEBOOK AND INSTAGRAM.
AND SO I JUST HOPE THAT YOU CAN
SEE THAT HERE IN CORONA NORCO
WE ARE ENGAGING- WITH OUR
STUDENTS ON THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS BUT- AT A GREATER
LEVEL ALSO IN MANY OF THESE-
TACTICS CAN BE EXPLORED AND-
REALLY REPLICATED ACROSS-
ACROSS THE STATE AND ACROSS.
THE US SO THANK YOU ALL FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS SURELY BUT I
THINK THAT MENTAL HEALTH IS
BEEN TOP OF MIND FOR MANY OF US
ABOUT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS. SO
THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
PRESENTERS BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
MEMBERS QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE THE
PUBLIC WANTING TO PERSIST
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW.
WILL DO QUESTIONS AT THE END OF
BOTH PANELS BUT THIS WAY YOU'LL
BE READY PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL
FREE NUMBER. 844-291-6364 WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS
CODE. FOUR FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE FIVE NINE WE WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS DO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS I SEE SENATOR MCGUIRE
SENATOR MCGUIRE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND DAD MADAM
CHAIRS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
ASK A- QUICK QUESTION- IN
PARTICULAR WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO. THE PANELISTS AND A
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO I'M MORE
IN CASE YOU PRETEND MAYOR GENE
BURKE SHE IS TRULY ONE OF THE
BEST AND- SO GRATEFUL FOR HER
LEADERSHIP. WOULD LIKE TO. HEAR
ABOUT AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE
HEARD ABOUT HOW YOU'RE BRINGING
STUDENTS BACK. THERE'S BEEN
SOME CONFUSION IT SEEMS IN
REGARDS TO WHO'S RESPONSIBLE
FOR WHEN. STUDENTS GO BACK
BASED OFF OF THE TEARS UP
WHETHER IT'S RED OR YELLOW IS
THERE A CAN YOU TALK TO US
ABOUT THAT AND WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE. AND THEN ALSO- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD HERE INTO THE SPRING
SEMESTER AFTER DECEMBER. CAN
YOU TALK TO US ABOUT. HOW
YOU'RE COMMUNICATING WITH YOUR
PARENTS AND YOUR STUDENTS. IF
WE START SEEING VIRUS LEVELS GO
UP- IN WHAT THE MESSAGES THERE
NO THAT WERE TALK ABOUT ACCESS
TO DISTANCE LEARNING BUT- IF WE
HAVE TO START RIGHT AB MATCHING
BACK WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE
AND HOW DO YOU. TURN BACK TO A
MORE. DISTANCE LEARNING FOCUS.
MY FIRST ANSWER THAT IS TO ME.
TO NOT TO THE RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR. QUICK SO IN THE CHAIRS.
RIGHT AS THAT HEREBY ORDERED TO
OPEN IN. YEAH A WAIVER RIGHT SO
WE ALL KNOW WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE AN THEN WHEN YOU GET INTO
THE RIGHT YOU'RE YOU'RE ABLE TO
OPEN AND THEN OR- RIGHT NOT. WE
ARE WITH THAT YOU KNOW A
THERE'S CAN WITH. PRESSURE A
SCHOOL BOY. YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
YOU SEE THE BECAUSE THERE'S A
OF FACT THAT GOING OPENING.
IT'S BASED ON YOU CAN IF YOUR
WRITER YEAH IF YOU ARE TO TALK
ABOUT THAT. SO MAKING THE. THE
BILL WAY TO FRAME THAT IS THAT
THERE'S- MORE. OR THAN
TRANSPLANT. AND COMMUNITY. ON
ONGOING. AS OFTEN AS WE CAN
PROVIDE IT BECAUSE- EVEN WHEN
YOU PROVIDED. THAT SOMEONE MY
NOT BE READY HEAR IT. SO THIS.
THAT WE BEEN USING.
COLLABORATING WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH. YOUR ALMOST WEEKLY.
CALLS FOR ENTIRE YEAR ACTUAL
ASK FOR. ASK QUESTIONS TO. AND
I FEEL THAT. IN TERMS OF THE
IMP. THAT THAT PEOPLE THE WHY
CAN HAPPEN THAT THE PIECE THAT
OUR NATION ARE WHAT WE DONE IN
MY AND FRANKLY AUSTIN ARE
SPORTS SPECIFIC PLANS WHICH ARE
ON TRACK. OPPORTUNITY FROM OF
THE- WHETHER A STOP OR DEFEATED.
WHAT IN PLACE AT A PARTICULAR
SIDE TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
AND STAFF CAN RETURN. TO
SCHOOLS FORTY AND THAT SHE
SEEMS TO BE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WHY IS ON IDENTIFIED BY THE
SCHOOL CITES TWO OF THEM WELL
ACTUALLY. ACT WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH AND RECEIVED A- AND
TRAIN NEW WEEKLY SO THAT'S ONE
OF THE STRATEGIES THAT WERE
USING AND I KNOW OTHERS HAVE.
STRATEGIES THAT ARE PROBABLY
HAS AFFECTED MORE MORE
EFFECTIVE. NO THANK YOU ONE
LAST QUESTION. MADAM CHAIR.
CHARLIE NINE CERTAIN SAUCES-
I'M- READING YOU SEEN SOME
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS GO BACK
SCHOOL TALK WITH US IF YOU
WILL- ABOUT THE COMMUNICATION
TO PARENTS AND STUDENTS ABOUT
IT THERE IS A NEED TO BE ABLE
TO GO BACK TO. FULL DISTANCE
LEARNING NOT PROVIDING THOSE
OPTIONS RATHER GET THE HEIGHT
RELIGION WELL CAN YOU TALK TO
US ABOUT WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE.
AS HONESTLY WE HAVE TO ALWAYS
LOOK AT WHAT A WORST CASE
SCENARIO MAY BE ESPECIALLY AS
WE GO INTO WINTER ACCIDENT
BURKE. SURE SO AT THIS POINT.
IN MARIN COUNTY I WOULD SAY ALL
OF OUR- HE CAME THROUGH- THREE
SCHOOLS WILL HAVE IN PERSON
OPPORTUNITIES FOR KIDS AS EARLY
AS MADE NO. AND THEY ARE.
MODELS THERE IS JUST. WHERE IT
IS NOW OKAY ARE RIGHT IT IS
PROVIDING PROPER. TEN THAT THE
ABILITY AND WITH JUST LEARNING
SO THAT'S NUMBER ONE. WELL WE
HAVE STRONG PROTOCOLS PLACE
RELATING TO SEND THEIR- THAT WE
WOULD TO PUT INTO PLACE IN THE-
OF. A COPEPOD THAT. FOR JUST
THAT POINT WE'VE HAD A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND. GAINES IN
OUR COUNTY PERSON AND OF THOSE
DAYS THERE HASN'T BEEN A SINGLE
SCHOOL TRANSMISSION OF STUDENTS
TO STUDENTS STUDENTS AND STAFF
BACK TO FAT PERSPECTIVE
STUDENTS OR SEEN. NO BERRIES. A
PROTOCOLS BUT WE KNOW THAT IN
THE EVENT THAT WE- CANNOT
WITHOUT PRACTICE DOING THAT-
WELL WE DIDN'T DO IT AS WELL AS
I WOULD HAVE HOPED IN MARCH BUT
WE WILL BE SO MUCH. STRONGER
AND READY TO GO IN THE EVENT
THAT THAT. HAPPENS YOUR- THANK
YOU MCGUIRE OF DOC. MY SHE
WROTE I THINK YOU HAVE YOU HAVE
UP TO ALL RESPOND THAT QUESTION
IS CORRECT IN QUESTIONS PART OF
A SANTA COUNTY. ARE WAIVER
PROCESS ALSO NOW WORLD OUR PLAN
HAS T INCLUDE MULTIPLE
SCENARIOS LIKE YOU. YOU ASKED
ABOUT TERMS IT IN. IN FALLS
CLOSURE. WE START MEETING WITH
OUR PARA AND THE PRESIDENTS WE-
AS SOON AS WE ARE DOWN AND-
THAT WITH OUR LABOR GROUP SO.
MANY IS FRANK OFTEN. BECAUSE
THE RULES CHANGE THE POLICIES
HAVE CHANGED SO FREQUENTLY AND
OFTEN. THAT THEY NEED TO BE
REGULAR. AND SO EVEN NOW WE
HAVE. 70% OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
IN PERSON. LEARNING WE'VE HAD
TO QUARANTINE. PROBABLY HUNDRED
STUDENTS TO DATE. BASED ON
CONTACT TRACING AND PRECAUTION.
AND SAID TO MARY JANE'S POINT
WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY SCHOOL TO
SCHOOL PRESS SPREAD. AND WE'VE
BEEN OPEN SINCE APRIL. AND SO
SAID SCHOOL SAFETY FOR US IS
ABOUT ABOUT A PRACTICE JUST
LIKE OUR FIRE DRILLS AND
EARTHQUAKE DRILLS. AS LONG AS
EVERYONE KNOWS THE ROUTINE
PROCEDURES AND FOLLOWING THEM.
AND WE CAN ELIMINATE MITIGATE
RISK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO SENATOR
ELENA GONZALEZ AND WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO SENATOR HANNAH BETH
JACKSON AND THEN SENATOR PAN
CENTER GONZALEZ THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THAT THIS QUESTION
MAY BE FOR SUPERINTENDENT MEET
EURO- AND A FEW OTHERS AS WELL
I'M JUST INTERESTED IN. THE
HYBRID MODEL THAT YOU'RE IN
CURRENTLY AS IT PERTAINS TO
DIGITAL ACCESS AND ATTENDED
ENTIRELY CROSS REFERENCING
THOSE TO ENSURE THAT IF THERE
ARE KIDS THAT DO NOT- THAT ARE
HAVING TROUBLE LOGGING ON TO
THEIR WIFI OR LOGGING ON TO
THEIR- THEIR- THE- THE DEVICE.
BY THE ACTUALLY IF FULLY
INTENDING. THE SCHOOL AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW THAT DATA IS
BEING CROSS REFERENCED- YET
ACTUALLY THAT THAT THAT PLAYS
INTO A POINT THAT I OPPOSE
SOMETHING WE DISCUSS ANYWAYS IN
TERMS OF ATTENDANCE AND
ENGAGEMENT TRACKING RIGHT. THE
WAY THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING
IT NOW IS STRESSING OUT
TEACHERS AND FAMILIES AND IS
MEASURING THE WRONG THINGS IN
TERMS OF WORK COMPLETION. BUT
ENGAGEMENT AND CONNECTIVITY AND
STUDENT. BASICALLY CONNECTION
TO THEIR CLASSMATES AND A
TEACHER ARE IMPORTANT
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. AND SO.
IN OUR FIRST ROUND OF DISTANCE
LEARNING WHEN IT WAS THE ONLY
OPTION. BASICALLY FROM MARCH
THROUGH JUNE- WE LOST ABOUT
3240% OF OUR KIDS. WILL BE
FOUND MOSTLY WAS BECAUSE THEIR
PARENTS DIDN'T HAVE THE STABLE
STRUCTURE AT HOME. TO GET THEM
ONLINE TO PROVIDE THAT SAFE
SPACE FOR THEM. THEY BECAME THE
BABYSITTERS THEY BECAME A
SYSTEMS THAT WORK. AND SO A LOT
OF THAT THAT REASONS ARE KIDS
COULDN'T GET ON HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE TECHNOLOGY OR THE
CURRICULUM OR THE TEACHING. IT
WAS JUST THE FAMILY DIDN'T HAVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO PROVIDE A
SAFE SPACE FOR LEARNING. NOW
THAT WE'VE OPENED OPTIONS WE
HAVE OPTIONS FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING FULLY FOR PARENTS THAT
WANT THAT. WE HAVE OPTIONS FOR
IN PERSON LEARNING AND THEN WE
HAVE A HOME SCHOOL OPTION WHICH
TAKES THE ONUS OF. THE TEACHING
LEARNING OFF THAT SCREEN TIME
BUT MORE THE INDEPENDENT STUDY
WORK COMPLETION. AND THAT'S
BEEN HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE
NOW PARENTS THAT. THEY'RE
CHOOSING TO KEEP THEIR KIDS AT
HOME FOR DISTANCE LEARNING AND
ARE PROVIDING A SPACE I THE
KIDS ARE GETTING THEIR THEIR
NEEDS MET. AND THERE'S STILL A
HANDFUL OF KIDS THAT WERE STILL
ONE ON ONE WITH TWO HOME VISITS
AND FAMILY LIAISONS. TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BEST ENGAGE
THEM BUT WHEN FAMILIES HAVE A
CHOICE AND THEY HAVE A
STRUCTURED. THEN ENGAGEMENT CAN
RISE AND WHAT WE SHOULD BE
MEASURING IS NOT WORK
COMPLETION AND SCREEN TIME. BUT
RATHER HOPING ENGAGEMENT USING
TOOLS LIKE GALLUP THE GALAXY
ENGAGEMENT CALL CALIPARI
JUDGEMENTAL. AND DIAGNOSTICS TO
SHOW THEIR KIDS ARE MAKING
PROGRESS NOT THAT THEY'RE
TURNING IN A WORK PACKAGE THANK
YOU IT DOESN'T SHOW ANYTHING WE
NEED TO HAVE DIE. AND TOOLS
WITH THESE COMPUTER ADAPTIVE.
TECHNOLOGIES THAT SHOW PROMISE.
IN LEARNING AND READING
LANGUAGE ARTS AND MATH. THANK
YOU FOR MUCH AND I HAVE A
COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS HE SAID
VERY MUCH SUPER. THAT WAS A
GREAT ANSWER AND THEN. THE NEXT
QUESTION IS FOR SUPERINTENDENT
BASS AND ALI AND DIRECTOR BROWN
I BELIEVE. CAN YOU JUST CLARIFY
YOU'VE BEEN DOING SOME REALLY
GREAT WORK IN THE POINTS THAT
YOU PUT TOGETHER WERE VERY
ORGANIZED AND REALLY GREAT TO
HEAR ABOUT- AND HOW WE CAN
EXPAND THOSE BEST PRACTICES
STATEWIDE. CAN YOU CLARIFY HE
WORK BEING DONE TO MAKE
STUDENTS FEEL MORE CONNECTED WE
OFTEN HEAR OF COURSE THEY'RE
DISCONNECTED THEIR THEIR VIDEOS
ARE OFF. THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT NUANCES I HEARD ABOUT
THE LUNCH BUNCH THAT I BELIEVE-
MS AS SURELY AS- DISCUSSED BUT
HOW HOW HOW SUCCESSFUL HAVE
THOSE SUPPLEMENTAL.
OPPORTUNITIES BEEN. YES I'D
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT. AND WE
HAVE DEVELOPED MULTIPLE
APPROACHES TO ENGAGING STUDENTS
IN THE CLASSROOM AND SO. WE ARE
GRABBING ATTENDANCE DATA AND-
DALY AND LOOKING OUT
PARTICIPATION NOT WAY AND WE
ALSO HAVE TEACHERS REFERRING.
REGARDING ENGAGEMENT CONCERNS
WITH STUDENTS WHETHER THEY'RE
NOT FULLY PARTICIPATING AND THE
DIGITAL CLASSROOM OR THEY
HAVEN'T SEEN THEN AND- WE
HAVEN'T SEEN OR HEARD FROM THEM
IN A WHILE AND SO WE HAVE TIME.
REPURPOSED A LOT OF OUR STAFF
ONE THING THAT- IS VERY EVIDENT
IS THAT NONE OF US HAVE THE
SAME ROLES THAT WE USED TO
HAVE. PRE COATED. AND SO WE
UTILIZED A VARIETY OF SUPPORT
STAFF TO ON DISABILITY OUTREACH
TO SEE IF IT'S AN ISSUE I HAVE-
DEVICE CONNECTIVITY. OR FAMILY
INFRASTRUCTURE OR IF IT'S
RELATED TO SOMETHING LEARNING
IN THE CLASSROOM AND SO AND- WE
HAVE WE HAVE TEAMS THAT INCLUDE
CLASSIFIED STAFF AS WELL AS
CERTIFICATED STAFF AND WE'VE
BEEN USING CULTURAL BROKERS TO
HELP AS OUR REACH TO FAMILIES.
WITH WHO AND MIGHT HAVE.
LANGUAGE ACCESS ISSUES. GREAT
THANK YOU AND THAT'S A MATTER
FINANCING PLEASE IN THE YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT IN THE NEXT
QUESTION ACTUALLY IS A GREAT
SEGUE AS YOU MENTIONED LANGUAGE
ACCESS ON THIS ONE THIS
QUESTION IS FOR MR LEE. ON
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES I HAVE A
LOT OF IT I KNOW THAT I'M
PREACHING TO THE CHOIR HERE BUT
I HAVE A LOT OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT. ASK ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND LANGUAGE
ACCESS OPPORTUNITIES FAR BEYOND
MAYBE WHAT IS EVEN AVAILABLE SO
HOW DO WE- BEST PARTNER I THINK
THERE WAS SALAS THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP BUT- WHAT CAN WE DO
TO SUPPORT THESE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THAT SPEAK. SPANISH
COME BY VARIOUS LANGUAGE THAT-
NEED THESE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES HOW ARE WE OUT
REACHING TO THESE COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION SO
WE SIMILAR TO- I DON'T REMEMBER
WHICH DISTRICT MENTIONED
CAROUSEL IS THAT WE DO PARTNER
WITH CAROUSEL IS ALSO AND CARE
SOLIS I BELIEVE HAS. A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
THAT THEY- HAVE TRANSLATIONS
FOR THE STUDENTS AND SO. IF WE
KNOW THE LANGUAGE AND WE-
EXPLAIN THAT TO OUR- TO THE
CARE SOLIS CONCIERGE THE NAME
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
APPROPRIATE PEOPLE ARE REACHING
OUT TO THE FAMILIES- AND THEN
WE- IN OUR DISTRICT WE HAVE A-
WE HAVE EIGHTY SIX SCHOOL
COUNSELORS WHICH IS. SOUNDS
LIKE A LOT BUT WE HAVE FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS SO IT'S
REALLY NOT THAT MANY- AND WE
AND WE HAVE MANY CONCERTS WHO
SPEAK. DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AND
SO ALTHOUGH THEY MIGHT BE A
HIGH SCHOOL COUNSELOR OR AN
ELEMENTARY COUNSELOR WHEN WE
HAVE STUDENTS WHO NEED.
MANDARIN OR VIETNAMESE OR THAI
COLLEAGUE OR SPANISH WE HAVE
COUNSELORS WHO CAN HELP WITH
THOSE SERVICES ALSO. TO BE ABLE
TO SPEAK TO THE FAMILY TO-
EITHER PROVIDE SERVICES OR LINK
THEM TO SERVICES IN THEIR IN
THEIR NATIVE LANGUAGE IN THEIR
HOME LANGUAGE SO- I AGREE THAT
THE LANGUAGE IS A BARRIER BUT
WE ARE DOING THE VERY. BEST
THAT WE CAN TO HELP OUR
FAMILIES. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE OUT OF SENATOR JACKSON
CENTER JACKSON PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
DOING THIS- I DON'T MEAN FOR
YOU THIS IS CERTAINLY ONE OF
THE MORE CHALLENGING PARTS OF
THIS- COLEMAN. NINETEEN
CERTAINLY THE NON MEDICAL SIDE
OF IT IS SO HOW WE DOING WITH
OUR OUR KITCHEN AND- HOW ARE
TEACHERS AND HOW THE WHOLE
PROCESS IS WORKING SO I JUST
WANNA GIVE YOU ALL. THE SHOW TO
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE
DOING- I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS-
ONE THE FIRST ONE RELEASE HOW
DO WE KNOW HOW OUR KIDS ARE
DOING- YOU KNOW USUALLY- SO
MUCH OF. IDENTIFYING HOW
THEY'RE SUCCEEDING IN THEIR
DEVELOPMENT IN THE SUCCESS OF
THEIR EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE IN
THEIR DEVELOPMENTIN GENERAL IS
BECAUSE- IN TEACHERS HAVE THOSE
IN. HIGH THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS IN PERSON-
GIVE A HUG OR WATCH CHILDREN
INTERACTING WITH EACH OTHER
WHAT'S THE NORM WHAT ISN'T
WHAT'S OUT THERE THAT IS
HELPING. I YOU AS OUR
PROFESSIONALS IDENTIFY AND
DETERMINE WHAT'S WORKING AND
WHAT ISN'T WORKING WHEN IT
COMES TO THESE- BOTH THE
ACADEMICS OF IT AND THEN THE
SOCIALIZATION AND MENTAL HEALTH
ASPECTS OF THAT EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE. I START SENATOR
JACKSON PLEASE PROCEED AGAIN
WHAT I LOVE TO BE THE SOLUTION
FOR POST CODE IS WIND I
DIAGNOSTICS AND PROGRESS
MONITORING WAS COME TO COMPUTER
ADAPTIVE TOOLS. THAT BLEED INTO
NOT JUST LANGUAGE ARTS AND MATH
BUT OTHER CONTENT AREAS TO
BASED ON THE TYPES OF SOFTWARE.
AND IN CONTRACTS THE DISTRICT
HAS YOU CAN SEE REAL TIME DATA
ON A DASHBOARD THAT WE CAN
EASILY SUBMIT TO THE STATE FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY TO SHOW EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING ACADEMICALLY
WITH THEIR KIDS. THE GALLUP
STUDENT ENGAGEMENT PAUL THE
GALLUP PARENT GAZED UPON GALLUP
EMPLOYEE ENGAGEMENT POLL DO
REPORT ON THOSE THINGS HOLD.
AYE ENGAGEMENT SOCIAL MOTION A
WELLBEING AND WELLNESS AND SO
IF WE WANT THOSE THINGS THEN WE
MEASURE THOSE THINGS BECAUSE
WHAT GETS MEASURED GETS DONE.
BUT THOSE TOOLS AND ADDITION TO
REGULAR MEETINGS WITH OUR
PARENTS OUR WHOLE STYLE AS WELL
AS SMALL GROUPS AND
CONVERSATIONS- ONE OF ONE ON
ONE THE STUDENTS ONE OF ONE OF
THE FAMILIES IS HOW WE GET THAT
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THEY'RE
REALLY DOING. THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE HAVE WITH OUR PARENTS
AND FAMILIES ARE CRITICAL AND
WE'VE INCREASED SALES BY. 1000%
IN THE LAST EIGHT MONTHS. WELL
THAT'S GREAT THE PRO AGAIN IS
AS MUCH AS A AYE IS HELPFUL AT
ALL THERE'S JUST NOTHING LIKE
THAT DIRECT CONTACT AND YOU
MENTIONED WORKING WITH FAMILIES
BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF FAMILIES
WHERE THEY'RE NOT ENGLISH
SPEAKERS- WHERE THEY'RE
WORKING. YOU KNOW TWELVE HOURS
THEY ARE ACTUALLY MAY NOT EVEN
KNOW HOW THEIR KIDS ARE DOING
BECAUSE- THEY'RE NOT AT HOME-
ARE THERE ARE ARE THERE ANY
SYSTEMS ARE IDEAS IN.
DISCUSSION OR IN PLACE RIGHT
NOW TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES.
PARTICULARLY SINCE WE'RE NOT
WITH OR IF WE ARE BACK 27080%
OF CLASSROOM TIME BUT- YOU KNOW
JUST ALL THE READING IS THAT
THIS WEEK THERE'S ANOTHER WAVE
COMING IN. AND THERE'S A REAL
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHAT THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS ARE GOING TO LOOK
LIKE- FOR. OUR KIDS IN SCHOOL
AND WHAT HAVE YOU OTHER ANY
OTHER- OPTIONS OR PROGRAMS OR
IDEAS THAT ARE FOMENTING OR
THAT THAT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED.
CENTER JACKSON- AMERICAN. MAYBE
WHAT I CAN AS FAR AS- WHAT WE
JUST HEARD. WHAT ARE TEACHERS
ARE IS NOTHING. TEACHERS
COUNSELORS. STAFF HELLO MIRACLE
MAKING UP THE NUMBERS .COM THAT
ARE BEING HAD THAT ARE INDEED
GET WITHIN CHILDREN AND THEIR-
NOT SCHOOL HOURS BUT BEFORE
SCHOOL AFTER SCHOOL ON THE- AND
SHE MIGHT GUESS THERE'S NOT
MORE. THAN BACK ABS INTERACTION
BETWEEN THE STUDENT AND THE
TEACHER AS WELL AS A PARENT AND
SO ONE OF THE I THINK MORE
SIGNIFICANT THINGS THAT THAT IS
HAPPENING. IN REAL TIME RIGHT
NOW ARE THE NUMBER OF CONTRACTS
THAT STUDENTS ARE GETTING
INDIVIDUALLY AND BACK ON IN AND
OF ITSELF CAN MAKE SUCH A
DIFFERENCE I TO ENSURE THAT
BEST YOU UNDER WE'D MISS. MORE
THAN THEY NEXT ASTON WE CAN'T
WAIT RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
MORE TYPICAL INTERACTION BUT
WHAT OUR EDUCATORS ARE DOING-
IS ACTUALLY UNPRECEDENTED- IN
MY YEARS IN THIS FIELD. BUT I
WANT TO QUICKLY JUMP IN ON ON.
THAT COMMENT I THINK THAT. WE
SHOULD TRY PERFECT WHICH IS
PROVIDE YES WE ARE IN UNDER
TERRITORY BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
IS PEOPLE CAME INTO THIS
PROFESSION BECAUSE THEY CARE
ABOUT KIDS. THEY WANT TO HELP
THEM LEARN AND GROW
ACADEMICALLY THEY WANT TO SEE
THEM THRIVE AND SURVIVE. SO I
THINK THAT WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE LISTENING TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN DIRECT SERVICE TO
STUDENTS DURING THIS TIME.
ABOUT AS MELISSA PERSONALLY
MENTIONED EARLIER I THINK WE
HAVE TO REACH DOUBLE DOWN ON
pHAVE TEAMS FIGURING OUT HOW TO
SUPPORT KIDS- BUT THERE IS
NOTHING THAT IS GOING TO
REPLACE. THE INTERACTIONS OF
HUMAN BEINGS WE KNEW THAT WHEN
WE WERE IN PERSON AND IT'S JUST
NOW BEEN AMPLIFIED. SO I HEAR
THAT WE WANT TO SOLUTION ABOUT
HOW TO DO THIS. I WE ARE YOU
KNOW WE'RE MAKING EVERYTHING UP
AS WE GO ALONG BASED ON WHAT
WE- KNOW WORKS WHEN WE'RE
SERVING PEOPLE IN PERSON. AND
IT IS ABOUT CONNECTING WITH
HUMAN BEINGS IN WHATEVER
FORMATS THAT WE CAN MAKE
HAPPEN. TO MAKE SURE THAT KIDS
KNOW THAT THEY ARE SEEN HEARD
AND VALUED AND THAT WERE THERE
AND CARE ABOUT THEM. I WOULD
LIKE TO ADD SOMETHING ALSO REAL
QUICK- WANTED PIECES THAT WE
ARE WORKING ON ACTUALLY
CURRENTLY IS. THIS IDEA AROUND
THAT THE MENTAL HEALTH OF OUR
STUDENTS IS NOT A SCHOOL
PROBLEM IT'S A COMMUNITY
PROBLEM AND SO HOW CAN WE-
ENGAGE THEM IN OUR COMMUNITY TO
HELP WITH- GETTING RESOURCES
OUT TO FAMILIES IF THEY'RE NOT
CHECKING OUR- FACEBOOK OR
INSTAGRAM OR GET LISTENING TO.
THOSE VOICEMAILS I GO HOME
EVERY SINGLE NIGHT EVERY SINGLE
WEEK HOW ELSE CANWE ENGAGE
WITH OUR FAMILIES AND SO WE
HAVE AN INTERFAITH- MEETINGS
AND OUR COMMUNITY AND GETTING
INTO THOSE MEETINGS HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
INTERFAITH- SO THAT. NGUYEN
MESSAGING GOES OUT IT'S ALSO
BEING MESSAGE THROUGH OUR
CHURCHES THROUGH OUR SYNAGOGUES
THROUGH OUR MOSQUES. THAT IT'S
NOT JUST A SCHOOL IT'S-
SITUATION BUT IT'S REALLY A
COMMUNITY IT'S REALLY. WHAT I
LIKE TO SAY AND WERE ROUTE WE
NEED TO WRAP AROUND OUR
STUDENTS IT'S NOT ONLY A
SCHOOL- SITUATION RIGHT NOW AND
SO THAT IS ONE OF THE OTHER
AREAS THAT WERE REALLY LOOKING
AT IS THAT. HOW CAN WE LEVERAGE
OTHER ASPECTS OF OUR COMMUNITY
TO HELP US WITH. OUR FAMILIES
AND OUR STUDENTS. SO AND THANK
CONSTRUCT THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE
HELPS RIGHT IT'S JUST ABOUT
THIS CENTRO WATERS I DON'T
THINK WE WERE NECESSARILY
PREPARED. FOR THIS SO LET LET
ME ASK THIS QUESTION- LESSONS
LEARNED. BY GOING FORWARD. I
HAS IS THERE ANY KIND OF- A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT STATEWIDE
FOR EXAMPLE. IN ONE OF MY
COUNTIES IN VENTURA COUNTY IT'S
ARE THEY DISCOVERED. THAT SOME
OF THESE KIDS- AT THE HOME
SITUATION IS JUST NOT CONDUCIVE
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS TO
DOING THIS KIND OF ZOOM IN.
DISTANCE LEARNING SO THEY'RE.
HELPING CREATE. IN IDEAS. THE
BACKDROPS FOR STUDENTS SO IT
APPEARS THAT THEY'RE IN A
DIFFERENT WORLD THEN PERHAPS
THEY ARE- IS A SAY FEEL
COMFORTABLE AT ALL I MEAN THIS
IS KIND OF AN INTERESTING IDEA
I SUSPECT EVERY SCHOOL AND
EVERY CHILD IN EVERY DISTRICT
HAS SOME OF THESE. ISSUES AND
DIFFERENT ISSUES AND
INNOVATIONS THAT THEY'RE
APPLYING IS THERE IS THERE ANY
KIND OF COLLECTIVE DISCUSSION
ABOUT THIS AND I ANY SHARING OF
LESSONS LEARNED ANYTHING THAT
THAT WE IS POLICYMAKERS CAN DO.
TO HELP IN THIS REGARD BECAUSE
I YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE'VE BEEN
OUT SINCE MARCH IN MANY
INSTANCES A LOT OF KIDS HAVEN'T
BEEN DOING ANYTHING
EDUCATIONALLY FOR MANY MONTHS
SO THEY'RE WAY WAY WAY BEHIND
WHAT'S BEING DONE ON THAT SCORE
ARE YOU ALL TALKING TO EACH
OTHER. WHAT WHAT ARE THE NEXT
STEPS AND HOW DO WE AVOID THIS
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE. SENATE
JACKSON ON BEHALF OF THAT FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
DEFINITELY THIS IS A
CONVERSATION WE HAVE EVERY WEEK
OR EVERY OTHER WEEK WHO'S DOING
WHAT WHAT'S WORKING WHAT HAVE
YOU LEARNED WHAT SHOULD WE
MODIFY. BUT THIS IS DEFINITELY
A STATEWIDE STATEWIDE
CONVERSATION AND YOU KNOW I DO
AGREE WITH YOU THAT THE MORE WE
INTERACT AND LEARN FROM EACH
OTHER AND THERE'S A LOT THAT'S
GOING ON I THINK ACROSS THE
STATE. SO THAT WE CAN- NOT
COOKIE CUTTER HE CAN'T MAKE A
COOKIE CUTTER APPROACH FROM ONE
COUNTY TO ANOTHER ISSUE WELL NO
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT
YOU CAN WANDER AND THINK ABOUT.
WHAT ARE THE LESSONS AND YOU'VE
HEARD A FEW OF THEM RIGHT
LISTEN CAREFULLY LISTEN
CAREFULLY CHECK EVERYBODY
COMMUNICATE WITH TRANSPARENCY
AND COMMUNICATE OFTEN. BE SURE
THAT AS YOU'RE MOVING AS YOU'RE
MOVING FORWARD YOU ARE PUTTING
SAFETY NUMBER ONE. AND ENSURE
THAT. EVERYONE HAS. A VOICE
WHETHER IT BE A STUDENT A
PARENT A TEACHER A CUSTODY AND-
YOU KNOW WHOEVER IT YES NEEDS
TO BE PART OF THIS AND THAT'S
WHY WHEN YOU LOOK AT OUR
SCHOOLS AND THE OPPORTUNITIES
TO RE OPEN. IN PERSON THAT
EVERYBODY HAS TO BE PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT.
IT LOOKS LIKE TO BE SAFE. I
WOULD I WOULD ADAM. I THINK ONE
THE MOST OF THING. IS
EVERYTHING KEEPS CHANGING STILL
AND HOW WE GET BETTER IN
EDUCATION AND IN A CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT CYCLE IS BY
REFLECTING ON WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING MAKING ADJUSTMENTS AND
SEEING WHAT THE IMPACT WAS AND
ONE OF THE MOST DIFFICULT TIMES
ABOUT IMPROVING ANYTHING THAT
WE'RE DOING THIS TIME IS THAT
WE KEEP HAVING TO SHIFT BASED
ON OUR INVOLVING REALITY OF
TRYING TO DO WHATEVER SCHOOL
IS. TODAY SO I THINK THAT- YOU
KNOW A YEAR FROM NOW WE'RE
GOING TO KNOW A LOT MORE
HOPEFULLY THINGS WILL BE VERY
DIFFERENT IN A YEAR FROM NOW.
BUT I WILL JUST OFFERED THAT
THAT IS ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT- ASPECTS OF THIS WORK
RIGHT NOW IS THAT WE ARE
CONSTANTLY HAVING TO PLAN FOR
THE NEXT THING AND IT'S GIVING
US VERY LITTLE TIME TO REFLECT
ON WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW.
SCREECH I THINK I THINK IT'S
SAFE TO SAY THAT THE MY
COLLEAGUES PROBABLY SHARE THAT
THERE WOULD YOU YOU ARE- HAVING
TO DEAL WITH SO MANY THINGS
IT'S HARD TO REALLY TAKE A AND
HAVE THE TIME TO REFLECT SO I
WOULD JUST- THAT THE THANK YOU
THANK YOU WALL PASSED THE MIKE
BACK IN- BUT JUST URGE YOU TO
STAY IN TOUCH YOU KNOW SO MUCH
OF THIS CLEARLY I SEE DOLLAR
SIGNS- WHEN I HEAR DR ME CHERYL
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THEY THEY'VE GOT ALL OF THE
STUFF- COMPUTERS AND THE
TECHNOLOGY IS THERE AND THAT
THERE IS. BROADBAND YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE THAT A LOT OF PLACES
IN THE STATE CLEARLY A LOT OF
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TAKES MONEY-
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO BUT
I THINK IT'S REALLY VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THERE CONTINUE
TO BE THIS DIALOGUE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE SO WE KNOW WHAT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO EDUCATE
OUR CHILDREN DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME BECAUSE FRANKLY
I'M WORRIED THAT SO MANY OF OUR
KIDS HAVE FALLEN BEHIND- AND-
THAT WE NEED TO IDENTIFY WHO
THEY ARE THEY FALLING BEHIND
ACADEMICALLY EMOTIONALLY- YOU
MENTION SAFETY CRITICAL
PROBLEMS- THAT. YOU KNOW THAT
THEIR SUCH ISOLATION THAT IT'S
KIND OF HARD TO TELL SO I JUST
WANT TO END UP BY THANKING YOU
ALL IN AND ASKING. THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO KEEP. US IN IN FOR
IS TO YOUR NAY ARE AND HOW WELL
YOU'RE DOING AND WHAT MORE YOU
NEED IN ORDER TO DO A BETTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK SENATOR JACKSON CENTER
PAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PRESENTERS AND PARTICULARLY
RECOGNIZE- BOTH THE- RUSSIAN
AND BROWN AND MELISSA BEST
KNOWN WHO ARE IN MY DISTRICT AT
SAN JUAN UNIFIED- DO I ASK SOME
QUESTIONS ARE BUILDING ON THE
QUESTIONS THAT THAT CENTER
GONZALEZ AND CENTER HANNAH BETH
JACKSON. ALSO ASKED. SO AND I
KNOW WHAT THE SUPERINTENDENT
CARE SURE YOU MENTIONED THAT IN
THE SPRING IN YOUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT YOU SAID ABOUT 3240%
OF THE KIDS KIND OF DROPPED OFF
IN THE SPRING. AND YOU
MENTIONED OF COURSE
INFRASTRUCTURE. ISSUES NOT
NECESSARY BROADBAND BUT OTHER
TYPES HOME ISSUES. THAT I GUESS
THE QUESTION I HAVE AND MORE
BROADLY NOT JUST FOR YOU-
SUPERDIMENSION AERO IS THAT.
WITH THIS NEW SCHOOL YEAR THIS
FALL AND WHEN THE THINGS THAT I
JUST WANT PERHAPS. THINK ABOUT
IS THAT YOU KNOW IN OUR ROLES.
IN IN THE STATE SENATE AND I'M
SURE MANY OTHER PEOPLE WE END
UP SPENDING A LOT OF TIME ON
WHETHER ZOOMS ARE CONFERENCE
CALLS AND SO FORTH AND FRANKLY
FROM MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
AND I THINK YOU MAY PEOPLE HAVE
ALSO EXPRESSED THIS IT'S-
FAIRLY FATIGUING. TO DO THAT TO
AFFECT PEOPLE'S BEEN WRITTEN
ABOUT. HOW MUCH MORE FATIGUING
IT IS TO DO REPEATED ZOOMS AND-
CONFERENCE CALLS VERSUS
ACTUALLY MEETING IN PERSON-
AND- SO. I GUESS. THE TERM SO I
GUESS THE QUESTION I HAVE IS I
SO YOU MENTIONED THIRTY FORTY
PERCENT- AND I'VE HEARD THIS
NUMBER FROM OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BEFORE. WHAT IS THE
PERCENTAGE OF HAVING THE FALL
AND ALSO IS THAT PERCENTAGE
INCREASING OR IS IT CHANGING.
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR THIS FALL TO THIS
POINT TITLES ARE WE DEVELOPING.
THIS ARE CHRONIC FATIGUE. AMONG
STUDENTS AND ALSO PERHAPS ALSO
AMONG TEACHERS AS WELL HAVING
TO BE ON A SENSUALLY OF VISION
YOU KNOW THIS VIRTUAL. MEDIUM
FOR HOURS EVERY SINGLE DAY SO
THIS IS. IS THIS AN ISSUE THAT
YEAR- EXPERIENCING- SEEING
AMONGST BOTH THE STUDENTS. AND
PERHAPS EVEN THE STAFF THE
TEACHERS. AND PERHAPS AND ALSO
IF YOU HAVE ANY DATA IN TERMS
OF NUMBERS OF WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF STUDENTS RIGHT NOW AT THIS
STAGE. ARE ACTUALLY OF YOUR
EXPECTED ROMAN WHO YOUR CONCERN
MAY BE DISENGAGED BECAUSE OF
WHATEVER REASON. AT THIS POINT
SO SINCE 3040% WAS MENTIONED
FOR THE SPRING WAS IT NOW. IT'S
AN- LOS DIGIT NOW AND SHAUNA
BROWN'S. EARLIER ABOUT THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT I HAVING
EVERY PERSON SEEN AND HEARD. I
THINK WAS OUR SUCCESS WE MET
WEEKLY WITH PARENT GROUPS. HOW
WE MET WEEKLY WITH OUR
CLASSIFIED PLAYGROUPS. WE'VE
HAD WEEKLY WITH OUR TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND TEACHER ASKED
REACHED FOR. AND THE QUESTION
IS WHERE WHERE HOW ARE YOU
DOING OUT WHAT ARE YOUR HOPES
WANTS AND NEEDS- SOCIALLY
EMOTIONALLY AND PROFESSIONALLY.
AS IN CONVERSATION WITH
FAMILIES WHAT ARE YOUR HOPES
AND NEEDS AND WANTS BOTH
SOCIALLY EMOTIONALLY. AND
ACADEMICALLY FOR THE CHILDREN.
AND THE FIRST THOSE
CONVERSATION JUST GAVE US THE
ANSWERS TO THE PROBLEMS YOU'RE
HAVING. ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE
CONCERN AS WELL AS OUR EMPLOYEE
CHILD CARE. OUR TEACHERS NEEDED
TO COME TO WORK BUT THEY'RE
ALSO YOU KNOW. PARENTS AND SO
HOW DO WE NEED BOTH IT'S HARD
TO USES LEARNING JUST BY
YOURSELF BUT WHEN YOU'RE TRYING
TO MANAGE YOUR OWN DISTANCE
LEARNING YOUR KIDS. IT'S AN
ISSUE. OF FREE CHILDCARE FOR
ALL EMPLOYEES IS SOMETHING WE
IMPLEMENTED RIGHT AWAY.
SOMETHING THAT WILL PROBABLY
GIVE US A CALL BACK IF WE CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW TO FINANCE IT.
JUST TAKES THE STRESS OF WORK-
AWAY IN TERMS OF GIVING YOUR
FULL ATTENTION TO THE JOB. AND
THEN THE SAME CONCERNS. FROM
OUR FAMILIES WORK. I NEED TO
WORK THAT NOT IN THIS WORKING
MY WIFE I BOTH NEED WORK IN THE
DON'T HAVE ANY SOLUTION CHILD
CARE. THAT'S WHY WE OPEN UP
SCHOOLS IN A- TO PROVIDE THE
POP CHARTER SO THAT ARE TOWNS
NO WORK IN UNDER THOSE. CAN GET
THIS IS LEARNING STEP. THE LAST
THING THAT WE LEARNED WAS THAT.
WE HAD A THANK YOU CAN PROGRAM
WITH ARE BLACKWOOD SYSTEM WOULD
CALL. AND THEM. FOR A COMMUNITY.
WE REALIZE THAT 40% THE PARENTS.
OUT OF THIS NEW. SO IT FANS
WERE RECEIVING. FROM US AFTER
ALL THE MECHANISMS AND WE HAD
TO RECONSTITUTE. NEEDS ARE OUR
SYSTEM. AROUND A NEW PHONE. I
TAX AND EMAIL SYSTEM TO
RECONNECT WITH OUR FAMILIES.
AND THEN ONE HOME VISIT AT A
TIME WE'RE ABLE TO RECONNECT.
IT'S JUST THAT A COUPLE KIDS-
THAT. PARENTS ARE NOT PUTTING
THEIR EDUCATION. AT THE HEART
OF. WHAT THEY'RE DOING RIGHT.
NOW THAT. ARE THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE. OKAY THANK YOU. L.
OF A- MESS BROWN ONE TO SINCE
YOU'RE THE EXACT. OF THE
TEACHERS. ONE HAD SOME
OBSERVATIONS. I DE FIFTEEN
ISRAEL I MEAN I THINK EVERYONE
ON THIS- CALL CAN ATTEST TO
THAT. IT'S I WOULDN'T SAY IT'S
NOT JUST THE INNER
INTERACTIONS- THAT ARE
OCCURRING VIRTUALLY BUT I DO
THINK THAT IMPACTS SO AS MUCH
AS WE NEED TO ENGAGE WITH EACH
OTHER- IT'S NOT THE SAME AS YOU
HEARD OTHER PEOPLE SAYING SO-
YOU KNOW A LOT OF WHAT FILLS UP
EDUCATORS IS THE INTERACTION
WITH STUDENTS. AND THAT'S
MISSING RIGHT NOW SO THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY IMPACTING PEOPLE- I
THINK THE OTHER THING IS. D.
EDUCATORS ARE HAVING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO TAKE. CONTENT THAT
THEY KNOW WELL AND THEY'RE VERY
WELL VERSED IN DELIVERING AN IN
PERSON FORMAT RIGHT SO AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THERE'S THE
DIRECT INSTRUCTION AND THEN I
LET MY STUDENTS GO TO
INDEPENDENT STUDY WHO KNOW THE
WORK AND THEN I CAN PULL EITHER
IN. STUDENT OR SMALL GROUPS ON
THE BACK OF THE ROOM IN REAL
TIME TO MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS- THAT
TAKE EXTRA WORK IN A VIRTUAL
WORLD BECAUSE YOU CAN'T MAKE
THOSE ADJUSTMENTS ON THE FLY-
PUTTING THE RESOURCES ONLINE.
MAKING THEM ACCESSIBLE AND
UNDERSTANDABLE FOR STAFF AND
STUDENTS ARE SKEWS ME FOR IT
STUDENTS AND PARENTS AND EVERY
AGE LEVEL- WE'RE HEARING ON A
REGULAR BASIS FROM TEACHERS
THAT THEY ARE SPENDING BETWEEN
TEN AND TWELVE HOURS A DAY-
THAT INCLUDES THE TIME THEY'RE
SPENDING WITH STUDENTS AND
SYNCHRONOUS BUT IT ALSO IS ALL
OF THE GRADING OF ALL OF THE
ONLINE THE COMMUNICATION
FOLLOWING UP WITH FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS. AS WELL AS HAVING TO
REFORMAT EVERYTHING TO FIT IN A
VIRTUAL WORLD SO THE FIFTEENTH
ISRAEL- AND- WERE ABSOLUTELY
HEARING ABOUT IT. THANK YOU.
BOB I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO TRACK- SO
OBVIOUSLY LEARNING IS A- BILL
TO A STREET RIGHT WE HAVE STOOD
THE LEARNER AND THAT AND THE
TEACHER AND SO. HOW BOTH ARE
DOING A VERY IMPORTANT AND ONLY
GET TO ACCESS THE INTERNET I
MEAN SUCH AS THOSE OF. BOTH
WAYS. THE OTHER QUESTION I HAD-
FOLLOWING UP ON THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH AND-
CERTAINLY THAT'S THE- MAJOR
ISSUE. TWENTY SO I LIKE TO
SHARE NO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
AND BUT JUST LIKE ANY HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. SO WHAT
DEGREE ARE HIS COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH WORKING WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO TRY TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. FOR STUDENTS. SO I
KNOW THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
TRYING VERY HARD ON THEIR OWN
WITH THEIR OWN RESOURCES AND I
APPRECIATE OUT REACH SOME THE
COMMUTER ORGANIZATIONS BUT WHAT
IS COUNTY BOARD COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS DOING WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE HAD THEY
BEEN. ABSENCE AND EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE BETTER ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH. PARTICULARLY VIRTUALLY
FOR STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING CHALLENGES.
SO I COULD TAKE MAYBE PART OF
THAT SO IN MARIN COUNTY
DEFINITELY STRONG RELATIONSHIP
WITH COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH. ARE
THEY REACHED OUT- AND I THINK
IT WAS IN THE SPRING I STARTED
DOING A TRAINING ONLINE WEEKLY
FOR DIFFERENT. PARENTS AND
STUDENTS DIFFERENT EACH. I'M IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGE. BUT IT
AVAILABLE IN HAVE. IN ADDITION
ARE PART OF OUR OVERALL
WELLNESS GROUP AND THEY ARE
BRING YOU TO LEVERAGE OUR
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT SO
THEY'RE DEFINITELY A STRONG
PLAYER IN OUR COMMUNITY. OKAY I
WOULD SAY WE RECEIVED
TREMENDOUS SUPPORT FROM THE
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAN
DIEGO AND ESPECIALLY THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE DOWN
HERE. WHO'S SEEN A RISE AND IN
CRIME ABUSE AND- TEEN SUICIDE
ATTEMPTS- CHILDREN COMING INTO
RADY CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL WITH
SCARS AND BRUISES AND THINGS
THAT WE WOULD THINK ARGUES THAT
ARE NOT IDENTIFIED BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT IN OUR BUILDINGS.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT ARE
OUR LOCAL EPIDEMIOLOGIST
PEDIATRICIANS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAVE SAID. ARE THE
REASONS THAT THEY SEE SCHOOLS
NEED TO BE VERY OPEN TO GET
THAT SAME PLACE BACK FOR KIDS.
IS ALSO REFLECTED IN OUR PARENT
TEACHER TALK IN TERMS OF WHAT
YOU'RE ACTUALLY SAYING. WHEN
YOU HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
FAMILIES. DEFINITELY THREE
OTHERS ON THE- DEGREE THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO BE PARTNERS I THINK
THE WE CONTINUE TO FACE
CHALLENGES AND NOT GOING BACK
TO THE SCREEN TIME AND VIDEO
THAT THE ON THE VIRTUAL FORMAT
AS THE FORMAT FOR SERVICE
DELIVERY AND SO THAT CAN AT
TIMES BE THE CHALLENGE IN TERMS
OF OUTRAGE BUT THEY ARE VERY
MUCH SO PARTNER. WITH US. I WAS
JUST GONNA SAY OUR AN- COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT IN THAT MAYBE WEREN'T
WE DON'T HAVE AS MUCH OF A
PARTNERSHIP- IN OUR COUNTY AND
SO- WHAT WE DO OFFER IS THROUGH
OUTREACH SERVICES THAT I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO. SEEK ON MY OWN I
AM NOT FROM THEM C. KEEN- APPS
CELL. THAT'S KIND AN OFF END.
ACTOR OKAY NO THANK YOU I AT
THE RELY THAT YOU CAN DIFFER
BUT ALSO WE CAN HAVE A BROADER
EFFORTS AND TO DRIVE THEIR ACTS
AND THEN FINALLY- IT'S GOT
WORSE SOMEONE MENTIONED ABOUT
SOCIAL MEDIA- I GUESS ARE THERE
EVER CONCERNS ABOUT YOUR SOCIAL
MEDIA CERTAINLY CAN BE USEFUL
TOOL BUT ARE THERE ARE CONCERNS
ABOUT PRIVACY- YOU KNOW IT'S SO
WE'RE NOW NOW DOING STUFF
VIRTUALLY AND I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
USING SOCIAL MEDIA NECESSARY TO
DIRECTLY TO DO TEACHING BUT-
IT. IS YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
USING SUCH AS THE SOCIAL MEDIA
IS THERE AS A MEDIUM FOR
ENGAGING STUDENTS ARE FAMILIES
AND ESPECIALLY AROUND SENSITIVE
ISSUES LIKE LET'S SAY MENTAL
HEALTH BEHAVIOR BETTER. PRIVACY
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT. I BELIEVE
I WAS THE ONE THAT MENTIONED
IT- IN MY- WHEN I WAS SPEAKING
AND SO WHEN I SPEAK TERMINAL
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH IN OUR-
SOCIAL MEDIA IT'S- OURS
COUNSELORS HAVE CREATED- CAL
FACEBOOK ACCOUNTS INSTAGRAM
ACCOUNTS WHERE IT'S JUST
PUSHING MESSAGING OUT TO
FAMILIES. WITHOUT THAT RESPONSE
BACK SO WE'RE NOT RECEIVING
RESPONSES BACK FROM FAMILIES WE
ARE ONLY PUSHING MESSAGING OUT.
IF THEY WANT TO REACH AS THAN
THEY NEEDED SEEK. THROUGH MEANS
OF A PHONE CALL OR AN EMAIL
THAT WE ARE NOT- GETTING
INFORMATION THROUGH OUR SOCIAL
MEDIA FROM THE FAMILIES. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MR MUCH
MANAGER THANK YOU SENATOR PAN A
SING NO MORE MICROPHONES RAISED
IN THE CHAMBER AND NO MORE
HANDS RAISED ON THE COMPUTER I
HAVE ONE FINAL QUESTION AND
THAT'S FOR IS SURELY. AND THIS
IS A HARD QUESTION TO ASK WE'VE
HEARD ANECDOTALLY THAT SUICIDE
RATES AMONG STUDENTS ARE UP.
SINCE YOU ARE THE HEAD OF
COUNSELING THAT IS ON THIS
PANEL I'M GOING TO ASK DIRECTLY
IF YOU DO YOU KNOW IF SUICIDE
RATES ARE UP IN YOUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR- IF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS HAD ANY SUICIDE
SINCE COVERED. OUR RATES ARE UP
AND YES WE HAVE- BUT WHAT WE'RE
FINDING IS THAT. IN THE PAST-
WE WOULD KNOW IMMEDIATELY
BECAUSE THE KIDS WERE CONNECTED
THEY WERE SHOWING UP AT SCHOOL
OR NOT SHOWING UP AT SCHOOL
UNTIL. IT'S BEEN ACTUALLY
REALLY DIFFICULT CHALLENGES ON
OUR IN DEPTH FIND OUT WHAT'S
GOING ON WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE- THAT FAMILIES ARE NOT
REACHING OUT TO THE SCHOOL SITE
TO SAY THE STUDENT IS NOT GOING
TO BE ATTENDING SCHOOL TOMORROW
BECAUSE OF THIS OR THAT AND SO.
AND BUT OUR NUMBERS ARE UP AND
YES WE HAVE HAD SUICIDES THIS
YEAR. THANK YOU I'M SORRY TO
HEAR THAT BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HONEST ANSWER. OKAY AT
THIS TIME I WOULD LIKE TO TURN
THE GAVEL OVER TO CHEER
GONZALEZ WHO'S GOING TO PRESIDE
OVER OUR SECOND PANEL. THANK
YOU TO ALL OF OUR FIRST
PANELIST.
THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. LEYVA FOR YOUR- AMAZING
WORK ENOUGH ON THE FIRST PANEL
AND I JUST WANNA THINK AS WELL-
ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS. AND
EDUCATORS WHO SPOKE TO US AND
GIVE US THEIR INCREDIBLE
INSIGHT- YOUR WORK IS
DEFINITELY APPRECIATED. I'M I
JUST WANT TO REMIND THE PUBLIC
BEFORE WE BEGIN ON THE SECOND
PANEL WHO WOULD LIKE TO CALL IN
TO DO SO NOW AGAIN THE NUMBERS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. ACCESS CODE
FOUR FIVE SEVEN. SEVEN FIVE
FIVE NINE. OUR SECOND PANEL IS
GOING TO TALK WITH US ABOUT
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET. THAT IS
NEEDED FOR DISTANCE LEARNING
MANY OF THESE ARE STAKEHOLDERS
WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY DID
DILIGENTLY ON THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. IN FINDING WAYS FOR US
TO BE MORE INCLUSIVE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ARE
VERY FIRST PANELIST ME THANK
HIM SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND
IS PATIENTS AS WELL. WE'LL BE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND
WELCOME MR SUPERINTENDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR- GONZALEZ
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR LEYVA. UP FOR TODAY'S
HEARING INTO ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE JOINT COMMITTEE- IT HAS
BEEN HELPFUL TO YOU HERE- THE
HEARING PROCEEDINGS. I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS WHO WERE
PARTICIPATING TODAY- FOR.
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION FUND
THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED TO OUR
SCHOOLS- BETWEEN YOU AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THIS MEANS
FIVE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS- THAT CAN BE USED. TO
SUPPORT- DEVICES INTERNET AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE. FOR OUR
STUDENTS- AGAIN I WANT TO START
BY ALSO SPEAKING TO SOME OF THE
THEMES THAT MANY OF YOU HAVE
SPOKEN TO. AS YOU STARTED OUT
TODAY ETHNOLOGY OUR STUDENTS.
ARE EDUCATORS AND THEIR
FAMILIES FOR THEIR RESILIENCE-
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
TIME PROBABLY THE MOST
DIFFICULT THAT WE WILL SEE. OUR
LIFETIME AS I HEAR FROM
EDUCATORS AND STUDENTS. ALL
OVER THE STATE EVERYONE IS
LEANING IN AS HARD AS THEY CAN.
TO MAKE THIS WORK I THINK MANY
OF YOU KNOW THAT OUR SCHOOLS
OPEN THIS FALL WITH NINETY
SEVEN PERCENT. OF OUR SCHOOLS
OPENING IN DISTANCE LEARNING-
IF YOU LOOK AT THE TOP TWENTY
FIVE LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN THE STATE MOST OF THEM
CONTINUE. TO BE IN DISTANCE
LEARNING I THINK MAYBE TWO AS I
LOOK AT THE LIST IN FRONT OF
ME- MAYBE TO- HAVE ACTUALLY UP
PROVIDE HAVE OPENED WHILE MANY
OF THOSE AT. LARGER DISTRICTS
ARE IN DISTANCE LEARNING SOME
OF THEM HAVE SMALL COHORTS AS
HAS BEEN ALLOWED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ALSO BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT. OF PUBLIC HEALTH WE
KNOW THAT WE NOW HAVE OF
METRICS FOR HELPING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MAKE DECISIONS WHEN
IT MAY BE SAFER TO OPEN. AND
WHEN IT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT SAFE
TO OPEN UP MORE THAN 40% OF OUR
DISTRICTS CONTINUE TO BE- IN
PURPLE- ZONES WHICH MAY KNOW UP
MEANS THAT THEY CANNOT OPEN. AT
THIS TIME- I WANT. TO THANK US
LATER MCGUIRE NOW OTHERS WHO
SERVED IN SENATOR LEYVA UP FOR
YOUR SERVICE ON THE TASK. AND I
BE NAY AND THE DEAL DIVIDE I
YOU CENTER AGAIN. FOR YOUR
LEGISLATION TO WHICH THE DIVIDE
IN THE GOING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU- AS YOU SAY IN THIS
INTEREST THAT YOU HAVE. WELL
FOR GOING FORWARD. AT THIS TIME
WE IT'LL ARE STILL OPERATING
OFF OF THE ASSUMPTION THAT
MAYBE A MILLION STUDENTS MAYBE
A MILLION AND A HALF STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA. ARE WITHOUT
COMPUTING DEVICES OR INTERNET
OR BOTH THIS IS AN
EMBARRASSMENT. TO ME FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR OUR
NATION THAT WE HAVE ALLOWED
THIS DIGITAL DIVIDE TO EXIST WE
KNOW THAT STUDENTS TO RULE
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO BE.
WITHOUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE THEY
NEED TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET AND IT IS MY BELIEF
THAT THE INTERNET IS SO SLOW
LIKE. ELECTRICITY AND WE WANT
TO WORK WITH YOU AND OTHERS TO
MAKE. APRIL AND REALLY SINCE
MARCH WE WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN THE FIRST
PARTNER AND FOUNDATIONS MANY OF
YOU WHO HELPED TO SECURE
DONATIONS IN THE EARLY DAYS. WE
RECEIVED A HUNDRED THOUSAND
COMPUTING DEVICES ANOTHER
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOT SPOTS- BUT
THAT JUST WASN'T ENOUGH- THE
NATION HAS BEEN EXPERIENCING A
SHORTAGE OF COMPUTING DEVICES
IN HOT SPOTS. IT'S SO MANY OF
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
A WAITING LIST WAITING TO GET
THE LATEST ROUND OF DEVICES TO
BE A BILL TO THEM. WHEN I THINK
MY STAFF AND OTHERS LIKE MERRY
NICELY WORK LITERALLY WITH
MANUFACTURERS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO MAKE ANOTHER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DEVICES
AVAILABLE TO OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FOR PURCHASE WITH
THEIR LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION
FUNDS. AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE PARTNERSHIP
WITH APPLE IN T. MOBILE THAT
HAS MADE ANOTHER MILLION AND A
HALF THE PRICE IS AVAILABLE TO
OUR STUDENTS THESE ARE DEVICES
THAT. ARE INTERNET ENABLED
THEY'RE SOLD AT A REDUCED COST
AND IF THEY ARE AVAILABLE TO
OUR STUDENTS AT A TIME WHEN
THERE'S A SHORTAGE ON AVAILABLE
DEVICES I LIKE TO ALSO- THANK
THE INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
IN OUR STATE. AND AGAIN CENTER
LEYVA CENTER INQUIRE WHO WORK
WITH US- TO SAY TO THEM LOOK
YOU'VE GOT TO PROVIDE FREE
INTERNET AND IN MANY IT IN MANY
CASES. AND CERTAINLY LOW COST
INTERNET FOR THOSE WHO QUALIFY
I'M IN THERE DOING THAT AT
ABOUT TEN DOLLARS A MONTH FOR
MANY OF OUR FAMILIES. WE'VE
ASKED THEM TO DO THAT WITHOUT
PROVIDING. ANY HOOPS TO JUMP
THROUGH NOT ASKING FAMILIES TO
YOU KNOW PROVIDE THEIR CREDIT
HISTORY NOT ASKING FOR SOCIAL-SECURITY NUMBER- AND THEY'VE
DONE THAT THEY PROVIDED
LIAISONS THAT FAMILIES CAN
CALL. TO GET HELP GETTING
ACCESS TO THESE PROGRAMS BUT
YET WE STILL SEE CHALLENGES
THAT EXIST FOR MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES AND WE INTEND TO USE
THE TASK FORCE AND WORKING
CLOSELY WITH YOU. TO ADDRESS
MANY OF THOSE EVEN IN THE TASK
FORCE WE FOUND UP IN SOME CASES
STATE GOVERNMENT HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO THE DELAY TO
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THAT WILL ALLOW. FOR
BROADBAND IN SO WE'VE USED TASK
FORCE TO ESTABLISH A BETTER
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH
CALTRANS THEY HAVE A WAY TO-
HUNT. FOR PROJECTS THAT NEED TO
BE EXPEDITED AND IF THEY'RE PER.
ISSUES WORK THROUGH. SO THAT WE
CAN NEXT. THOSE PROJECTS I WANT
TO THANK EVERY AGENCY THAT HAS
HELPED- TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS CRAIG COMING FROM- THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
THE CALIFORNIA TELEKINETIC- IF
FOLKS THAT ALLOWED FOR EIGHTY
SIX THOUSAND HOT SPOTS TO GO TO
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY. RULE AND
SMALL- DISTRICTS FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS COMING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND. THAT PROVIDED DEVICES IN
HOT SPOTS AT FOURTEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AGAIN OUR INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE STEPPED
UP TO PROVIDE TO REDUCE COST.
INTERNET TO OUR K. TWELVE.
FAMILIES AND ALSO TO HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENTS MANY OF WHOM
ARE FINANCIALLY INSECURE FOOD
INSECURE BUT THEY'RE ALSO. IN
DISTANCE LEARNING THEIR STILL
MANY MANY CHALLENGES. WE DON'T
HAVE INTERNET IN OUR RULE
COMMUNITIES THIS IS A
CHALLENGE. WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE INTERNET TAXES FAMILIES ARE
TRYING HARD. TO ADDRESS THE
INTERNET MULTIPLE PEOPLE IN ONE
HOME AND SOMETIMES THEY JUST
GET KNOCKED OFF A RESUME. IN SO
WE KNOW THAT OUR INTERNET
COMPANIES ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
HELP US TO ADDRESS THESE GAPS.
WHEN I THINK DR GARY MICHELSON
ENGINE AND TECH WHO'VE COME
FORWARD TO HELP US IN CREATING
WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE ANNOUNCING
A NEW. INNOVATION COMPETITION-
SENATOR LEYVA NINE TO. FORCE
MEMBER WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
THIS. THIS A WAY FOR US TO GET
THOSE TO DO RESEARCH TO THOSE
WHO ARE ENTREPRENEURS THOSE WHO
ARE INNOVATORS. TO COME UP WITH
A NEW TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY OR
WASTE TO HELP US ADDRESS- THE
LACK OF INTERNET IN OUR STATE
COME UP WITH NEW SOLUTIONS AND
CUTTING EDGE. SOLUTIONS TO DO
THAT WILL BE OFFERED A CASH
CRISIS HELP MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
PROVIDE SOME INCENTIVES TO
COMPANIES AND RESEARCHERS AND
INNOVATORS TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
FOR OUR STUDENTS AND SO- WE'RE
DIGGING IT ON ALL THE THINGS
THAT YOU ALL ARE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY. TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS HAVE THE TOOLS TO
LEARN AND ALSO THE TOOLS TO BE
CONNECTED WITH CANCERS BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW MORE
THAN EVER. OUR STUDENTS NEED
ACCESS TO SOCIAL. LEARNING IS
SOMETIMES THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN
GET ACCESS. TO A COUNSELOR IS
TO TELL THE HEALTH WE'VE
CREATED A COUNSELING. THIS OF
THAT SPEAKS TO OF OUR- NAY
WHERE THEY CAN. CALL THE NUMBER
ANY IS. YOU GET CONNECT. TO A
SHORTER RESOURCE THE FIELD WILL
BE WORKING WITH US THIS TO DO
WHAT YOU HEARD EARLIER TODAY
FROM THE COME HOME VALLEY
DISTRICT. A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT. IF OUR
FAMILIES DON'T HAVE COMPUTERS
WE CAN EXPECT THEM TO RESPOND
TO THE INTERNET. AND SO WE WANT
TO WORK WITH OUR DISTRICTS TO
ADDRESS ISSUES AROUND FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT. WE DON'T WANT
IGNORE THE PANDEMIC OF RACISM
THE MANMADE PANDEMIC WHERE%
YOUNG PEOPLE SEE POLICE
BRUTALITY IN RACIST ACTS
OCCURRING. ON THEIR TELEVISION
SCREEN EVERY SINGLE DAY. OUR
OFFICE PROVIDED MORE THAN A
HUNDRED WEAPON ARE SINCE THE
PANDEMIC. I STARTED TO EXAMINE
EVERY WAY TO DELIVER EDUCATION
TO DISTANCE LEARNING TO EVEN
PROVIDING SUPPORT. TO OUR
STUDENTS THAT TO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT ANTI
RACISM. WILL BE MAKING AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THIS WEEK OF. A
NEARLY A DOZEN NEW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE PROVIDING. MANY
GRANT TO DO A MORE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AROUND ADDRESSING-
OUR- OUR NEEDS AS IT RELATES TO
ANTI RACISM WORKING ANTI BIAS
WORK. I THANK ALL OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT EMPLOYEES FOR THEIR
WORK- AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC MORE THAN FIVE
THOUSAND SITES PROVIDING MEALS
WE KNOW THAT OUR FAMILIES.
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF OUR COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICERS AND- OTHERS WHO COME
TOGETHER WITH OUR COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS. TO TALK NEW
IDEAS AROUND MORE TESTING- TO
TALK THROUGH HOW WE KEEP OUR
FAMILY SAFE- WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS UNTIL
WE- ADDRESS THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
ONCE AND FOR ALL. IN OUR
LIFETIME I THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THESE TWO COMMITTEES FOR YOU
COMING TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS AT
ANY TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SUPERINTENDENT AND I KNOW
YOU HAVE BEEN LEANING INTO THIS
ISSUE LIKE NO OTHER AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT AND AT THE
INCREDIBLE WORK OF THE DIGITAL.
DIVIDE TASK FORCE INCLUSIVE OF
SENATOR LEYVA AND SENATOR
MCGUIRE I THINK THEM FOR THEIR
WORK AS WELL. WE APPRECIATE
THAT PRESENTATION- NEXT WE HAVE.
A MARTHA WHO'S MON I SERVICE
COMMISSIONER AT CAL PUBLIC.
COMMISSION COMMISSION WE THANK
HER FOR BEING HERE WELCOME
COMMISSIONER ASSET GOODMAN A
SERVICE. THANK YOU CHAIRWOMAN
GONZALEZ SENT THANK YOU
CHAIRWOMAN LEYVA AND ALL OF THE
SENATORS AS YOU KNOW AND AS AS
SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND JUST
MENTIONED THAT YOU SEE HAS BEEN
VERY INVOLVED IN WORKING WITH-
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION ON SOME OF
THE FUNDS THAT HE'D MENTIONED.
BUT FIRST I DO WANT TO STOP IN
A KNOWLEDGE ALL THE
SUPERINTENDENTS FOR THEIR
AMAZING WORK WE'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF TRYING TO
COOPERATE WITH SOME OF THEM.
THEY ARE REALLY- BEING AS
INNOVATIVE AS THEY CAN BE
EVERYWHERE FROM FRESNO MODERATE
MADERA SACRAMENTO YOU NAME IT
WE'VE BEEN. TRYING TO DO A
LITTLE BIT OF HELP BUT I I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL TO BE HERE
TODAY TO SHARE SOME OF MY
RECOMMENDATIONS BECAUSE THEY'RE
CARRYING A BURDEN THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T BE AND WE REALLY NEED
SOME LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO HELP
NOT JUST OUR CHILDREN BUT ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET. ONE
THING IN SEAKING TO MANY OF
THESE- SUPERINTENDENTS THAT WE
ALL AGREE ON. IS THAT HOT SPOTS
ARE A SHORT TERM SOLUTION. AS
SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND
MENTIONED ALTHOUGH WE WERE ABLE
TO PARTNER WITH SEAT WITH THE
TAX CALIFORNIA TELL CONNECT
FUND. TO EXPAND OUR SOME OF THE
FUNDING FOR PARTICULAR SMALL
MEDIUM SCHOOLS IT'S JUST A
BANDAID- THIS IS WHAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT SUPERINTEND ALREADY
MENTIONED. THEY DON'T ALWAYS
WORK EVERYWHERE THE HOT SPOTS
AS THE NUMBER ONE PROBLEM FOR.
SOME OF THE KIDS THAT WERE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT ARE STILL
BEING LEFT BEHIND. IN ADDITION
THE SHARING OF THE DEVICES
LEADS TO BANNED WITH ISSUES AND
OF COURSE THE DATA CAPS IS JUST
NOT A LONG TERM SOLUTION. THE
REAL SOLUTION THAT I REALLY
WANT TO ENGAGE ALL OF YOU TODAY
IN THIS NEXT LEGISLATIVE YEAR.
IS THAT WE NEED TO GOVERN THE
INTERNET AS THE ESSENTIAL
SERVICE THAT IT IS. IT IS A
UTILITY THIS IS CENTRAL SERVICE
NEEDS TO BE REGULATED LIKE ONE
AND LEGISLATOR LIKE ONE.
IRONICALLY WE HAVE LONG
STANDING STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
THAT REQUIRES OUR TELEPHONE
VOICE CARRIERS FOR THE VOICE
SERVICE. TO HAVE TO REALLY
CRITICAL MANDATES ONE IS THAT
THEY HAVE TO SERVE ALL
CUSTOMERS IN A DESIGNATED AREA.
WE REFER TO THIS TERM AS THE
CARRIER OF LAST RESORT WE DO
NOT HAVE THAT MANDATE FOR THE
INTERNET AND WE DESPERATELY.
NEEDED THE WE NEED. PERSONALLY
I THE MOST EXPEDITIOUS AND%
COMPREHENSIVE WAY TO GOVERN IN
THIS APPROACH WOULD BE TO
REQUIRE THAT CABLE COMPANIES TO
BE THE CARRIERS OF LAST RESORT
IN THEIR DESIGNATED AREAS. SO
THAT ALL CUSTOMERS HAVE THE
INTERNET SERVICE VAILABLE TO
THEM AND TO HAVE IT AT AN
AFFORDABLE RATE. AS I MENTIONED
ALSO HISTORICALLY AND NOW
TELEPHONE VOICE CARRIERS HAVE
THE MANDATE OF CARRIER OF LAST
RESORT. BUT THEY'RE ALSO
MANDATED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
CALIFORNIA LIFELINE PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDES AFFORDABLE PLANS
FOR VOICE. NO SUCH MANDATE
EXISTS FOR INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS. THESE PROTECTIONS TO
OBLIGATE TO SERVE AND TO HAVE
AFFORDABLE PLANS FOR LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS. DON'T EXIST IN THE
INTERNET SPACE BECAUSE WE HAVE
USED ALLOWS A FAIR APPROACH FOR
THE LAST COUPLE DECADES THAT
THE FREE MARKET FREE OF THESE
TYPES OF OBLIGATION WAS GONNA
SOMEHOW ADDRESS THESE- ON THESE
DISPARITIES THAT EXISTED. IN
FACT THEY'VE CAUSED A GREATER
DISPARITY. AS AN EXAMPLE JUST
WANNA SHARE RECENT-
INTERACTIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
WITH EIGHTEEN T. ON THEIR
FUTURE TO INVESTING COMMUNITIES
AND THEY'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR
THAT THEY PLAN TO RETIRE THEIR
DSL SERVICE AND THAT THEY HAVE
NO REAL UPGRADES TO AGREE THAT
DSL TO FIBER ESPECIALLY NOT IN
THE AREAS WHERE DOESN'T ALREADY
EXIST. IN SOME AREAS WHAT
THEY'RE PROPOSING IS TO PROVIDE
NON FIXED INTERNET SERVICE AND
THIS IS A WIRELESS BROADBAND
SERVICE WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S A SUBSTITUTE FOR
WIRELINE INTERNET SERVICE FOR
MUCH OF THE SAME REASONS THAT I
MENTION WITH THE HOT SPOTS.
SOME AREAS OF CALIFORNIA WILL
BE LEFT WITH NOTHING NO ALL DSL
NO FIBER UPGRADES NO CABLE AND
NO MOBILE WIRELESS WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE SAME WE DESPERATELY
NEED THE LEGISLATURE TO ACT.
STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS FOUND
THAT COMPANIES LIKE AT&T AND
COMCAST ARE RED LINING
COMMUNITIES BOTH RURAL AND
URBAN BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
OBLIGATION TO SERVE THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY. A RECENT REPORT FROM
THE NATIONAL DIGITAL INCLUSION
ASSOCIATION FOUND THIS PROBLEM
TO BE NATION WIDE FOR A. T. AND
T. THE MEDIAN INCOME FOR
HOUSEHOLDS WITH ACCESS TO FIBER
WAS 34% HIGHER. AND THEN IN THE
AREAS WITH DSL ONLY. AN IN
CALIFORNIA AT AND T. IS ONLY
DEPLOYING FIBER 210% OR LESS
HOUSEHOLDS IN RURAL COUNTIES
SUCH AS KINGS TO WARY AND
MADERA. ANOTHER STUDY BY THE
ANNENBERG RESEARCH NETWORK ON
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNICATIONS
WERE USC RESEARCHER AND NONE. I
GOT BUILDING. THIS LAST YEAR
DID A STUDY ON WHO GETS ACCESS
TO FAST BROADBAND IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. THE FINDING
INDICATED THAT FIBER SERVICES
ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE OFFERED
IN LOW INCOME AREAS WITH
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WITH THE
MOST SEVERE DEFICITS IN AREAS
THAT HAVE BLACK RESIDENTS
LIVING IN POVERTY. IN JUNE OF
THIS YEAR ANOTHER STUDY BY
GREEN LIGHTING THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE THEY SHARED THEIR
FINDINGS OF COMMUNITIES IN AND
NEAR OAKLAND LACKING HIGH SPEED
INTERNET ACCESS AND IT CLOSELY
RESEMBLED A MAP OF THE
REDLINING THAT OCCURRED IN
HOUSING FROM THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES. HERE AT THE DO YOU
SEE AS I MENTIONED WE HEAR FROM
INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITIES ALL THE
TIME IN THESE LAST TWO WEEKS
ALONE I PERSONALLY HAVE MET
WITH COMMUNITIES IN CINEMA
COUNTY. MENDOCINO COUNTY
MONTEREY COUNTY FRESNO COUNTY
AND COMMUNITIES ALL IN BETWEEN
AND THE ISSUES RUN THE GAMUT
MOST OF THE TIME THERE'S FIBER
GOING THROUGH THE COMMUNITY AND
THEY HAVE NO ACCESS OR THE
FIBER GOES WITH ANY CABLE
SERVICE HALF OF THE COMMUNITIES
LIKE HIM BY ALLAH. AND THE
OTHER HALF DOESN'T HAVE IT. OR
LIKE THE COMMUNITY AND SIGNED
HER ARE THE MONTEREY WAS
SHOWING SERVICE BUT THE
COMMUNITY DOESN'T HAVE IT. ALL
OF THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE
CHILDREN CHILDREN ARE FALLING
BEHIND AND THE SUPERINTENDENTS
ARE TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO GET IT. RESOLVED
BUT THEY CANNOT DO IT ALONE.
THIS IS A YOU KNOW WE COME TO A
POINT HERE WHERE WE HAVE. THE
TRIED AN APPROACH OF OFFERING
INCENTIVES AND USING THE MARKET
FORCES TO TRY TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE BUT WE'RE PAST
THAT POINT WE NEED TO REQUIRE
THESE COMMUNITIES TO BE SERVED
AND THAT THEY BE SERVED THE
SAME QUALITY AT AN AFFORDABLE
RATE. IT'S TOO LATE IT'S TOO IS
JUST INSUFFICIENT NOW TO. ON A
ALONE IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
THE DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
VIDEO COMPETITION ACT KNOWN AS
DIFFICULT. THE CHANGE IT CHANGE
THE CABLE FRANCHISE LICENSING
TO BE ISSUED BY US THE CPUC
INSTEAD OF LOCAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES. DIFFICULT TO THE
AUTHORITY FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITHOUT PROVIDING
THE P. YOU SEE ANY AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE AGAINST THIS CRITICAL
TYPE OF REGULATING WE CANNOT
INSURE THAT. IN EACH COMMUNITY
EVERYONE GETS SERVED OR EVEN I
EACH COUNTY LEVEL THAT THERE'S
NO REDLINING. THIS IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM AND I REALLY CALL ON
THE LEGISLATURE TO TAKE THIS
ON. THANK YOU SIR. OKAY. THANK
YOU COMMISSIONER I I'LL LET YOU
GO AHEAD AND FINISH WE HAVE
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES FOR EACH
PERSON WE GAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME TO GO RIGHT OKAY
THANK YOU CHIRLA AND I'M SORRY
TO BE SO ANIMATED SUS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE BY SAYING WE CANNOT
LEAVE THIS TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WE NEED TO PROVIDE
MORE FUNDING AND I KNOW YOU ARE%
A LEADER IN EXTENDING THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND WE NEED TO FIND THAT
SAFETY NET AND WE ALSO NEED TO
MANDATE THESE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE INCUMBENTS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
COMMISSIONER AND I APPRECIATE
THE SOLUTIONS THAT YOU PROVIDED
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE ALSO TO
VERY VERY COMMITTED I'VE TALKED
WITH THE MULTIPLE TIMES AND I
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
INSIGHT HERE. AND WHAT MORE WE
CAN DO TO IMPROVE- THE
SITUATION FOR ALL OF OUR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M NEXT PANELIST IS
CAROLYN MCINTYRE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
IS MCINTYRE THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- CAROLYN
MCINTYRE. I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY- MEMBERS OF OUR
ASSOCIATION FAST INVEST HEAVILY
IN CALIFORNIA'S. BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE HAVING INVESTED
MORE THAN FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
IN CALIFORNIA. SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY SIX. ARE THE MEMBERS OF
THE ASSOCIATION WHICH I WILL
POINT OUT. DO NOT INCLUDE AT&T
GIVEN THE EXAMPLE CITED BY THE
COMMISSIONER. OF THE MEMBERS OF
OUR ASSOCIATION HOWEVER DO
SERVE. ABOUT EIGHT LONG AND
INTERNET SERVICE CUSTOMERS IN
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I'M IN
ADDITION TO DELIVERING FASTER
RELIABLE INTERNET SERVICE TO
BUSINESSES AND RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS. CCJ MEMBER COMPANIES
TO VOLUNTARILY OFFER PLANS. TO
EXTEND INTERNET SERVICE FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IN FAMILIES.
WITH STUDENTS THAT ARE NOW
LEARNING FROM HUB. AT THE CABLE
INDUSTRY HAS ACTUALLY BEEN
OFFERING IS LOW INCOME INTERNET
PROGRAMS. LONG BEFORE THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC AND I WILL NOW
WITHOUT. ANY GOVERNMENT
SUBSIDIES. UNDER THESE PLAY
THAT ARE SEARCH PROVIDER I'M
SERVICE AT A COST THAT RANGES
BETWEEN NINE NINETY FIVE IN
SEVENTEEN NINETY FIVE PER
MONTH. FOR FAMILIES WITH THE
STUDENT IN GRADES K. THROUGH
TWELVE WHO QUALIFIED FOR THE
FEDERAL FREE LUNCH OR REDUCED
LUNCH PROGRAM OR AND NOW THEIR
SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAM I LIKE
HOW FRESH IT JUST DEPENDS ON
THE COMPANY. I'M IN ADDITION TO
OUR ON GOING LOW INCOME
INTERNET ACCESS PLANS IN
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC SOME
OF THE COMPANIES HAVE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED ADDITIONAL SPECIAL
OFFERINGS FOR NEW CUSTOMERS
THAT PROVIDE FOR TWO FREE
MONTHS OF SERVICE FOR.
CUSTOMERS THAT QUALIFY FOR THE
FREE REDUCED LUNCH PROGRAM. END
FOR NEW CUSTOMER COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND IN SOME CASES
EDUCATORS. SO I'D ALSO LIKE TO
MENTION ANOTHER STRATEGY THAT
WAS ACTUALLY UNDERTAKEN AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL FOR THE
INDUSTRY- THE CABLE INDUSTRY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE EDUCATION
SUPERHIGHWAY- BASICALLY IS
ESTABLISH THE FRAMEWORK FOR A
PROGRAM CALLED K. THROUGH
TWELVE. BRIDGE TO BRIBERY AND
THAT BASICALLY ESTABLISHES A
FRAMEWORK FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THE CABLE
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
WORK TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY
POPULATIONS- STUDENT
POPULATIONS THAT STILL DO NOT
HAVE INTERNET CONNECTIVITY.
UNDER THE STRUCTURE OF THE
PROGRAM ULTIMATELY THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT WOULD ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDER TO. PROVIDE
PROVIDE FOR WHAT WE REFER TO
EIGHT IS A SPONSORED SERVICE
AGREEMENT AND I WILL NOTE THAT
A SPONSORED SERVICE AGREEMENT
CAN BE ENTERED INTO YOUR BY.
ANY ORGANIZATION OR ANY
INDIVIDUAL EVEN THAT WHAT LIGHT.
TO TAKE IT UPON THEM SOUTH TO
NEGOTIATE CON. AND TO PAY FOR A
SERVICE ON TWO INCH. BROADBAND
CONNECTED TO CERTAIN POPPED
UNDER THE STRUCTURE OF THIS
PROGRAM AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE COULD
ACTUALLY ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS- TO PROVIDE SERVICE
TO WHATEVER POPULATION THEY
IDENTIFIED- AND PRACTICALLY
HAVE THESE POPULATIONS
CONNECTED OVERNIGHT. SO THERE
ARE OPTIONS OUT THERE-
AVAILABLE- AND ONLY THAT AND
WHILE WE DO NOT AGREED WITH THE
COMMISSIONER OF THAT PRODUCT
AND SERVICE NEEDS TO BE
REGULATED AS A UTILITY WE DO IT
KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS MUCH
WORK TO BE DONE IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR IMPROVING BROADBAND
AVAILABILITY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- IT STARTED WITH PROGRAMS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY UNDER WAY AT
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND AND AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THE REGIONAL DIGITAL
OPPORTUNITY FIND BOTH OF FOR
EACH WELL DEPLOYED PROVIDE
FUNDING TO DEPLOY. BROADBAND
SERVICE TOO MANY AT THE
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE STATE THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN ME. BUT THE
ULTIMATELY THE SOLUTION HERE IS
IN FACT I'M GOING TO BE
ADDITIONAL PRIVATE INVESTMENT
BY MEMBERS THAT OUR ASSOCIATION
AS WELL AS MANY OTHER
COMPETITORS IN THE INDUSTRY- AS
WELL AS THE PUBLIC SUBSIDIES
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
THOSE AREAS ARE TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES. WHERE IT'S HARD TO
DEPLOY OR FOR MANY CHALLENGES
THAT CURRENTLY EXIST THERE AND
IS NOT CURRENTLY SERVICE BEING
PROVIDED AT THE TWENTY FIVE IN
THREE LEVELS- I WILL ALSO NOTE
HOWEVER THAT I ASKED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN CONSIDERING
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT. LOOK TO
ELIMINATE BARRIERS TO
PERMITTING- INCLUDING BY
REQUIRING STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES TO EXPEDITE AND
STREAMLINE. PERMITTING ACCESS
THAT HAVE OFTEN DOWN BROUGHT
PROJECT PROHIBIT LOW GOVERNMENT
FROM EXCESSIVE. AND REQUIRE
SPECIFIC TIME. FOR AT INVESTOR
ON YOUR OR OTHER OWNERS BROWN
ACTS TO THE POLLS FOR BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT PURPOSES. LAST LATE
I'LL SAY WELL THERE'S MUCH TO
BE DONE AND I DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE TO MENTION THAT WE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ADDITIONAL
WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE IN THE
BROADBAND ADOPTION AND DIGITAL
LITERACY SPACE. THAT IS ONE OF
THE PRIMARY REASONS WHY OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES DO IN FACT
PROVIDE BROADBAND SERVICES FOR
CERTAIN POPULATIONS AT A LOWER
COST. BUT THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF
WORK TO BE DONE IN THE SPACE OF
RECOGNIZING HOW TO USE THE
TECHNOLOGY AND EDUCATING SON
FAMILIES ON THE FACT THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY IS IN FACT A PART OF
OUR EVERYDAY LIVES. AND WE NEED
TO UNDERTAKE DIGITAL LITERACY
EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY GETS THE BENEFIT OF
THE TECHNOLOGY SO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
AND I. LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS MCINTYRE PRIEST YOUR-
INSIGHT AS WELL I KNOW YOU'VE
WORKED VERY HARD WITH MANY OF
US IN THE LEGISLATURE TO FIND
SOLUTIONS. AND SPECIFICALLY THE
POINT OF DIGITAL LITERACY IS A
HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR AND I KNOW
PEOPLE HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THAT. NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
DANE JASPER THE C. E. O. OF
SONIC A TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANY AN INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDER BASED IN SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA- MISTER JASPER YOU
CAN GO RIGHT AHEAD THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY SONIC IS A-
COMPETITIVE INTERNET ACCESS
PROVIDER FOCUSED ON FIVE THE
HOME SERVICES. EIGHT MILLION
SEVEN SISCO BAY AREA TODAY. AND
WE SERVE ABOUT A QUARTER OF A
MILLION CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
TODAY. AND WE ARE SIMILAR TO-
COMPANIES LIKE GOOGLE FIBER AND
TAKING INTERNET AND METRO IN
THAT IN THAT WE'RE A NEW MARKET
ENTRANTS- BUILDING TODAY
EXCLUSIVELY FIBER THE HOME
NETWORKS. WE WITH THE BEGINNING
A PANDEMIC- WE LAUNCHED A
COVERT NINETEEN PROGRAM AND-
AND THAT PROGRAM OFFERS A
COMPLETELY FREE ACCESS TO OUR
GIGABIT FIBER SERVICE SO THAT'S
A ONE THOUSAND MEGABIT SERVICE-
TO T. K. THROUGH TWELVE
STUDENTS COLLEGE STUDENTS. US
SENIORS ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
WORKERS AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS
AND DELIVERY AND GROCERY. OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT THAT
PROGRAM IS JUST A FEW MONTHS
LONG IT ONLY PROVIDES A FEW
MONTHS HAVE COMPLETELY FREE
ACCESS. LONG TERM IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR US TO SUBSIDIZE
THOSE SORTS OF PROGRAMS. I WANT
TO TALK A LITTLE ABOUT
PERFORMANCE BECAUSE I MENTIONED
FIBER TO THE HOME THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE PERFORMANCE
OF FIBER. HAS REALLY BEEN SHOWN
BY THIS PANDEMIC. AND WE SAW AT
THE START OF SHELTER IN PLACE A
THIRTY. A PERCENT INCREASE
ALMOST OVERNIGHT IN THE
CONSUMPTION OF INBOUND USAGE-
AND BETWEEN FORTY AND 50%
INCREASE IN OUTBOUND. AND SO
YOU THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW SORT
OF BASELINE PERFORMANCE OF A
TWENTY FIVE DOWN THREE UP
PRODUCT. AND A SINGLE ZOOM
GROUP CALL REQUIRES BETWEEN ONE
AND A HALF IN TWO AND A HALF
MEGABITS. AND I HAVE THREE
YOUNG CHILDREN MY WIFE AND I
ARE ALSO LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE TO WORK FROM HOME GIVEN
THE INDUSTRIES THAT WERE IN.
AND THERE ARE TIMES WHEN ALL
FIVE OF US- ON ZOOM TEAMS HANG
OUT MEET AT CETERA AND- AND SO
A LOT MORE UPSTREAM BANDWIDTH
IS NEEDED. AS AN IMPORTANT
RECOGNITION YOU KNOW AS THESE
TECHNOLOGIES HAVE EVOLVED I
THINK THE FUTURE OF WORK IN THE
FUTURE OF LEARNING. YOU KNOW
I'M TRYING TO TAKE THE MOST
OPTIMISTIC VIEW ABOUT THE
CHANGES THAT THIS PANDEMIC HAS
BROUGHT. AND ONE OF THOSE IS
THAT YOU KNOW WE MAY BE ABLE
TO. WORK FROM HOME MORE AND
HAVE MORE FLEXIBLE WORKING
ENVIRONMENTS- AND WE MIDDLE
SUPPORT STUDENTS WHO HAVE A
VARIETY OF NEEDS. BY SUPPORTING
THEM AT A DISTANCE SO I ONE
TOLD ABOUT KIND OF THE TWO
BROAD CATEGORIES THAT WE THINK
ABOUT- IN REGARDS TO CONNECTING
HOUSEHOLDS AND CONNECTING
STUDENTS THE FIRST IS. I THINK
THE ONE THAT GETS THE MOST
ATTENTION THAT IS DEPLOYMENT.
THE RURAL PROBLEM- THE SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF HOUSEHOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE NO INTERNET
ACCESS AVAILABLE OR FOR WHOM
THE INTERNET ACCESS IS JUST.
INSUFFICIENTLY SLOW AND SO THAT
MIGHT BE A VERY OLD DSL SYSTEM.
FOR NOTHING EVER. AND TESE
AREAS YOU KNOW THESE ARE A
CHALLENGE PRIMARILY OF SUBSIDY
IT IS A FINANCIAL CHALLENGE HOW
DO YOU CONVINCE CARES TO GO
BUILD. A TO FAR FLUNG LOCATIONS
WHERE IS THERE IS NO CLEAR
RETURN ON INVESTMENT. AND I'VE
SEEN REFORMS IN THE CASF
PROGRAMMING CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE
THE STATE TO CONTINUE TO COMMIT
TO. A PROGRAMS LIKE CASF AND
OTHER GRANT PROGRAMS. THAT
WOULD REACH THOSE RURAL MARKETS.
IN THOSE THERE CONTINUE TO BE
PROBLEMS THOUGH BEARS AND
DEPLOYMENT YOU KNOW ISSUES
AROUND LOCAL PERMITTING-
UTILITY STANDARDS LIKE
DIRECTIONAL BORING IN MICRO
TRENCHING ARE ESSENTIAL POLL
SAFETY AND ONE TOUCH MAKE READY
ACCESS TO UTILITY POLES ARE
ESSENTIAL TABLE STAKES BEFORE
YOU INVEST IN THOSE SORTS OF
PROGRAMS. SONIC THOUGH IS
FOCUSED ON THE URBAN AND
SUBURBAN DEPLOYMENT TODAY WE-
DO NOT- HAVE NOT BUILT ANY
RURAL MARKETS AND WE HAVEN'T
PURCHASED IT IN ANY OF THE
SUBSIDY PROGRAMS WOULD REALLY
STRUGGLE TO FIND A BUSINESS
MODEL AROUND THOSE THAT WOULD
ALLOW US AS A PRIVATE ENTITY.
THE BILL NETWORK INTO THOSE FAR
FLUNG IN VERY CHALLENGING
ENVIRONMENTS I REALLY APPLAUD
THE CARES THAT HAVE SUCCEEDED
NOT. AS WE THINK ABOUT URBAN
AND SUBURBAN ENVIRONMENTS.
GENERALLY THERE IS SOME FORM
ACCESS IT MIGHT BE A PRE
EXISTING DSL OR A FIBRE TO THE
NODE PRODUCTS OR IT MIGHT BE A
HYBRID FIBRE COAXIAL CABLE
SYSTEM OTHER MENU MEDIA A FIBER
IN SOME LOCATIONS. IN THOSE
LOCATIONS OF URBAN LOCATIONS WE
ACTUALLY HAVE MORE UNCONNECTED
HOUSEHOLDS AND MORE UNCONNECTED
STUDENTS THAN WE DO IN THE
RURAL MARKETS WHERE THEY HAVE
NO CHOICE TO CONNECT. ADOPTION
IS A CRITICAL ISSUE THAT
IS A MORE COMPLEX PROBLEM
DEPLOYMENT PROBLEM IS- YOU KNOW
IT IS A CHALLENGING ONE IT'S AN
EXPENSIVE ONE THAT'S WHY IT'S
CHALLENGING. BUT THE ADOPTION
ISSUE IS MORE COMPLEX IN OTHER
WORDS WHEN THEY'RE TWO OR THREE
CARRIERS OFFERING A SERVICE TO
A HOME AND URBAN MARKET. WHY DO
WE CAN TO HAVE ROUGHLY 20% OF
HOMES IN URBAN MARKETS NOT
CONNECTED. AND COST IS REALLY A
KEY FACTOR THERE- SO THERE ARE
TWO PRIMARY FACTORSCOST. AND
EDUCATION ACCESS TO DEVICES
ACOSTA- IT ENCOMPASSES DEVICES
AND EQUIPMENT- THE
AFFORDABILITY THE CONNECTION
ITSELF WHERE EDUCATION HOW WHY
DO I WANT THIS HOW WILL I USE
IT. AND THE- YOU KNOW
SUPPORTING THE PARENTS AND
STUDENTS AS TO- THE KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT THEM THE USE OF THE
CONNECTIONS. AND AS A AS A
COMPETITIVE CARRIER. WHAT WE
OBSERVE IS THAT THE MORE
COMPETITION YOU HAVE IN THE
MARKETPLACE. THE HIGHER THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE SERVICES.
AND THE LOWER THE COST OF THOSE
SERVICES AND CRITICALLY EASY
THINK ABOUT AN ENVIRONMENT WITH
DISTANCE LEARNING AND WORK FROM
HOME. HAVING HIGHER THAN TWENTY
FIVE DOWN AND THREE MEGABITS UP
IS IMPORTANT. AND WHERE YOU
HAVE SLOW LEGACY TECHNOLOGIES
DEPLOYED YOU'D REALLY LIKE TO
SEE FAST FIBRE DEPLOYED. AS A
COMPETITIVE CARRIER FOCUSED ON
URBAN AND SUBURBAN FIBER
DEPLOYMENT WE EXPERIENCE MANY
BEARS TO THAT APPOINTMENT OF
PAUL SAFETY AND ONE TOUCH MAKE
READY PROCESSES AROUND POLL
REINFORCEMENT AND REPLACEMENT
TO ALLOW FOR DEPLOYMENT ARE
CHALLENGING AND TODAY RESULTING
GAPS IN OUR DEPLOYMENT. LOCAL
PERMITTING ALSO PRESENTS
CHALLENGES AND- WE HAVE CITIES
THAT WERE READ WITH TODAY. WHO
DON'T WANT US TO SET TEMPORARY
POLLS. DESPITE THE EXISTING
COAL BEING OVERLOADED AND
UNSAFE AND THE TEMPORARY POLL
WOULDN'T RESOLVE THIS SAFETY
ISSUE WHILE ALLOWING US TO
DEPLOY. WHAT IT MEANS TO PAUL
SITTING SIDE BY SIDE MAY FIND
THAT UNSIGHTLY DESPITE IT BEING
A TEMPORARY CONDITION UNTIL THE
ELECTRIC UTILITY POLE HONOR
RESOLVES THE EXISTING SAFETY
ISSUE. THANK A THIRD TRAILER IS.
STANDARDS AROUND MODERN
CONSTRUCTION METHODOLOGIES IN
UNDERGROUND CONSTRUCTION. AND
TODAY THE TWO PRIMARY
UNDERGROUND CONSTRUCTION
METHODS USED ARE TRENCHLESS
METHODS DIRECTIONAL BORING AND
MICRO TRENCHING- BUT DESPITE
THAT MANY CITIES HAVE NOT
ADOPTED STANDARDS ALLOW FOR
NARROW SLOT OR MICRO TRENCHING-
TO BE PERFORMED. BUT THAT IS AN
ESSENTIAL TECHNOLOGY FOR NEW
DEPLOYMENT OF FIBER OPTIC
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU MISTER
JACKSON IS GOING TO HAVE TO ASK
YOU TO JUST REFERENCE YOUR ARM
AS- THE OTHER ISSUE THAT WE
THINK IS ACCESS TO MULTI TENANT
ENVIRONMENTS. APARTMENT
BUILDING OWNERS. DO NOT
NECESSARILY WANT TO SEE THEIR
TENANTS WELL CONNECTED AND THIS
REALLY SURPRISED ME AND- I LIVE
IN THE NORTH BAY. ACTION
SENATOR MIKE MCGUIRE'S- REGION
AND- SO YOU KNOW I GREW UP IN
NORTH BAY AREA AND OUR FIRST
MAJOR FIBER DEPLOYMENTS IN THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO. AND
WE'RE STRUGGLING TO GET INTO A
NUMBER OF- BUILDINGS IN WESTERN
SAN FRANCISCO WE SPOKE WITH A
BUILDING MANAGER ABOUT HOW
GREAT THIS NEW FIBRE CONNECTION
BEING HOW MUCH THEIR TENANTS
WOULD ENJOY A GIGABIT RELIABLE
FIBER SERVICE. IN THIS BUILDING
MANAGER SAID THIS BUILDINGS
RENT CONTROL THE SENATE LIKE
THEIR INTERNET THEY CAN MOVE
AND THAT'S BETTER FOR US. AND
THAT'S THAT SORT OF ATTITUDE IS
REALLY CORROSIVE SAM'S HAS
TAKEN SOME STEPS TO COMPEL ST
JASPER CAN WE DO THAT BILL HAVE
YOU. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN
HEAR ME OKAY A NUMBER OF
BUILDINGS WHERE WE STRUGGLE
WITH ACCESS. SO FROM A STATE
ONE POLICY PERSPECTIVE POLICIES
AROUND I DON'T THINK MODERNIZE
TRENCHING METHODS. ACCESS TO
APARTMENT BUILDINGS POLICIES
LIKE THE- SORRY MR JASPER WE'VE
DONE WELL OVER THE FIVE MINUTES
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE
BEING FAIR WITH EACH OF OUR
PANELISTS SO- I KNOW WILL HAVE
A LOT OF QUESTIONS RESPECTED TO
WHAT YOU JUST MENTIONED WE JUST
REALLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INSIGHT THERE SO I'M GONNA GO
HEAD TO OUR FINAL PANELIST AND
THEN WE'LL OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS I'M SURE YOU WILL
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS- OUR FINAL
WITNESS ON THIS PANEL IS JORI
WOLF THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
DIGITAL INNOVATIONS THAT
MAGELLAN ADVISORS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER WILL FOR JOINING US.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON-
COMMITTEE CHAIRS GONZALEZ AND
LEYVA- AND ALSO- SENATORS I
WOULD. LIKE TO LET YOU KNOW-
MAGELLAN ADVISORS WORKS WITH
GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY
THROUGHOUT THE NATION- BUT WE
FOCUS WORK- AND HELPING
GOVERNMENTS OF. AND DESIGN AND
BUILD OUR FIBER AND WIRELESS
NETWORKS TO HELP WITH
ELIMINATING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
WORK OUR CLIENTS SEE VERY
RATTLING. DODD IT'S EXPENSIVE
FOR THE SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
BUILD WITHIN- THE RURAL AREAS
AND EVEN IN SOME METRO AREAS
WHERE THE PARCELS ARE LARGE AND
THE DENSITIES ARE NOT ON OUR
SMALL. WE LOOK TO OPPORTUNITIES
TO UTILIZE PUBLIC ASSETS
WHENEVER POSSIBLE YEAH OUR
FOCUS IS TO ASSIST GOVERNMENTS
IN FILLING OF THIS GAP THE GAP
BETWEEN THE CONSUMER AND THE
SERVICE PROVIDER SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE PLEASE ARE ARE
HAVE A PROFIT MOTIVE AND THAT'S
REALLY WELL UNDERSTOOD- AND OF
COURSE IT'S RESPECTED THEY HAVE
SHAREHOLDERS THAT THEY NEED TO
ACCOUNT TO. THE GOVERNMENTS ARE
LOOKING AT BROADBAND IS A NEW
UTILITY AND OF COURSE- IT WAS
ALL AROUND IT I CANNOT MAKE
DEVELOPMENT IN WHICH BROADBAND
BECAME KEY AND ARE FOUND DEAD
ELEMENT OF JUNIOR BUILDING. WE
SIT WE SAW THIS STARTING IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES SOUND IT'S
CONTINUING NOW INTO THE TWO
THOUSANDS. BEING SECOND ELEMENT
GOAL AN OBJECT. HAVE NOW BE
SUPERSEDED BY CO. AND CHARLIE
AND LEARNING HAS EMERGED AS THE
PRIMARY THING. WE'RE SEEING
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
GOVERNMENTS ARE NOW STARTING TO
PAIR UP AND WORK TOGETHER
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE GOVERNMENTS
MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENTS AND
COUNTY GOVERNMENTS DO HAVE
ASSETS AND THEY CAN WORK WITH
UTILITY PROVIDERS. WITH OTHER
STATE AGENCIES- AND ALSO
WHERE'S COMMITTEE ANCHOR
INSTITUTIONS IN WHICH TO- BUILD
FIBER OPTIC NETWORKS TO PROVIDE
FOR THE GAPS THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST FOURS ARE USED AND THE
STUDENTS- THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THEMSELVES ARE WELL SERVED BY
STATE PROGRAMS- SCENIC IS DONE
VERY WELL. ALONG THE LINES OF
E. RATE FUNDING- BUT OF COURSE
THAT IS CONNECTING SCHOOL
FACILITIES BUT IS NOT
CONNECTING WITH THE CONSUMER-
WE SEE TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
WHERE ARE USING THEIR BACKBONE
AND ALSO ASSISTING- CITY. I'M
SORRY WHAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
IN WHICH TO- IMPLEMENTED
CARRIER SOLUTIONS WIRELESS
SOLUTIONS FOR THE LAST MILE TO
CONNECT TO USED TO THESE. ODD
JOBS TO THE INTERNET- AND ALSO
THE G. SERVICES- INCLUDING
THEIR FAMILIES FOR TELEWORK. WE
HAVE. GONE FROM CITIES. UP AND
FUNDING MASTER PLANS FOR OF
SHORTFALL CAN. AND NETWORK TO
CITY'S PARTNER AND LOOKING FOR
PRIVATE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH NEW ENTRANTS
TO OPERATE THESE NETWORKS BASED
UPON THE PUBLIC ASSETS IN THE
INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
AND TRAFFIC SIGNAL CONTROL
SYSTEMS- AND MANY OTHER SYSTEMS
FOR UTILITY SCALE-
APPLICATIONS. AND MANY MANY
OTHERS THOSE ARE NOW- SPILLING
OVER INTO YOUR FILLING THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING AFRICAN ACTING
FAMILIES- WHERE THERE. ISN'T
ENOUGH DOWN WEST. WITH THESE
CAN WE'RE SEEING AT. IN KEY
THROUGHOUT. IN THE NORTHERN
PORTION OF THE COUNTY AND EVEN
IN THE SOUTHERN PORTION OF THE
COUNTY WHERE COUNTIES ARE
BRINGING THEIR CITIES TOGETHER-
AND WITH MANY COUNTIES COMING
TOGETHER AND CONSOLIDATING INTO
CONSORTIUMS IN WHICH TO APPLY
FOR GRANT FUNDING FROM THE
STRUTS- INDIAN USING OTHER
STATE MONIES FOR BEING ABLE TO
USE THOSE LOCAL MATCH. THE BIG
CHALLENGE THAT OUR CLIENTS HAVE
RIGHT NOW IS FINDING THE LOCAL
MATCH THE LOCAL MATCHES THE
MOST DIFFICULT. PART IN BEING
ABLE TO FIND THE LAST MILE- BUT
ALSO FUNDING MIDDLE MILE
BACKBONE NETWORKS FOR REGIONAL
COLLABORATION AMONG CITIES
WITHIN COUNTIES AND COUNTIES.
WITH ONE ANOTHER WHICH IN
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS. WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE IMPLEMENTATION OF A DICK
ONCE THROUGHOUT ALL OF THESE
COMMUNITIES WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE PUBLIC WORKS ASSOCIATIONS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
ADOPT A ONCE. AND IS IT INSTEAD
TO ADOPT STANDARDS FOR-
DIRECTIONAL BORING- BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR MICRO TRENCHING
TECHNOLOGIES. IT'S REALLY KEY
THAT WE LOOK AT THIS ALTERNATE
SOLUTION NOT JUST FROM THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO CAN'T
AFFORD TO BUILD WHERE IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE BUT TO ASSIST TO THE
GOVERNMENTS TO BUILD. WHERE
THEY FEEL THAT IT'S KEY FOR THE
COMMUNITY BUILDING FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND FOR QUALITY OF
LIFE. AND FOR RESPONSE TO
KROGER. WE'D LIKE TO SEE- THE
EXPANSION OF OPPORTUNITIES TO
GO AFTER FEDERAL MONEY AGAIN
THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH LOCAL
MATCH IN WHICH TO DO THAT BUT
IF THE STATE WERE ABLE TO
ASSIST. OUR CLIENTS- AND CITIES
AND COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- IN ACQUIRING FEDERAL
GRANTS USING STATE MONIES- OF
THESE NETWORKS WILL END UP
GENERATING REVENUE AND THOSE
REVENUES. WILL ACTUALLY REPAY
THE CAP EX INVESTMENTS- FOR
THESE BROADBAND MUNICIPAL
NETWORKS THAT BETTER SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS AND WHERE IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE TO BUILD. WE ALSO SEE
THAT OUT THERE ARE-
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CITIES TO
COME TOGETHER BECAUSE WORKING
INDEPENDENTLY WORKS OR ON THEIR
OWN- IS IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE-
IT'S TOO DIFFICULT TO BE ABLE
TO WRITE GRANT APPLICATIONS ONE
AFTER THE NEXT AND- IF THEY
COME TOGETHER IN A REGIONAL
COURT A COOPERATIVE CONCERN. AT
A COUNTY LEVEL WE SEE THAT
THERE'S MUCH MORE OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF CITY TO
CITY CAPITAL PROJECTS THAT CAN
BE USED TO LOWER THE COST OF
CONSTRUCTION TO BRING IN YOU
JODY IS SUCH AS WATER YOU JUST
NEED WATER DISTRICTS ELECTRIC
COOPS AND OTHERS THAT CAN
ASSIST. YOU PROVIDING ASSETS
INCLUDING AERIAL DEPLOYMENT AS
WELL AS C. R. P. PROJECTS
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS
UNDERGROUND THAT WILL HOUSE THE
COST OF THE CONSTRUCTION OF
FIBER NETWORKS WITHIN THESE
COMMUNITIES. SO OVERALL SEE
THAT THERE'S BEEN A LACK OF
ATTENTION TO MUNICIPALITIES AND
TWO COUNTIES AND GOVERNMENT'S
TRYING TO ACHIEVE SOMETHING
THAT IS NOT BEING DONE BY THE
PRIVATE SECTOR- BUT THEY
OBVIOUSLY UNDERSTAND NEEDS TO
BE DONE. AND WE NEED WAS SYSTEM
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- VICE PRESIDENT
WILL FULLY APPRECIATE THAT
INSIGHT AS WELL- WE THINK EACH
OF THE PANELISTS FOR BEING HERE
AND ALL OF YOUR INSIGHT AS
MENTIONED- WE WILL NOW TAKE IT
BACK TO MEMBERS QUESTIONS OF
THE VERY FIRST NUMBER I HAVE IS
A SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF NINE CHAIRMAN SHOOTER
I'M BITES COMMENTS IT'S ALRIGHT
WITH YOU INSURE LATELINE FIRST
AND FOREMOST I WANT TO SAY
THANKS FOR ABOUT EXCELLENT
PANEL HERE TO GAIN BEGINS. YOUR
PERSONAL REPRESENTED AT THE
CHALLENGES THAT CALIFORNIA
FACES IN. JERRY I WANT TO SEE
IF YOU CAN YOU AND YOUR LEYVA
PEER LEADERS ON THESE. ISSUES
ESPECIALLY REGION IN GENERAL
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IN A BIG
SHOUT OUT TO SUPERINTENDENT
TONY THURMOND OF COURSE. THE
MINISTRATION OGBU TONY THURMOND
HAS BEEN A PERSON HAD BEEN.
WALKING HIS TALK ON ALL ISSUES
TO BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
ONCE THAT FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION AS ALLOCATED A GETTING
THAT MONEY INTO THE HANDS OF
DISTRICTS. I AND I ALSO WANT TO
SEE THANK YOU TO RISE TO
PRETEND BERMAN FOR INSURING.
THE DOCKET RESPONSE IN STAFFERS
HAD OF TRYING TO BE ABLE TO
BRING DOWN THOSE WAITING LISTS
THERE ARE BARELY AT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DEVICES THAT WERE
WAITING FOR WEATHER CHAPLAINS.
ARE IN OR OUT LAPTOPS ARE HOT
SPOTS IN THE SUPERINTENDENT IN
HIS TEAM HAS BEEN ALL OVER.
BRINGING DOWN THOSE WAITING
THIS AS ONE STATE THANK YOU. I
JUST A FEW COMMENTS. ON WORLD.
AND WORLD CUP FOR HAS HAD A
DIGITAL THE BY. SINCE BEARS
AROUND. I'M DESPITE ALL DIGITAL
THE- NAY BE NEW FOR SOME AREAS
THE STATE BUT- WE TAKE A LOOK.
AT WHAT IS HIGH. I HIGHLIGHTS
THE DISK. THAT WE'VE HAD CAL.
FOR YOU WHEN IT COMES TO
CONNECT TO THE ONCE UP.
NEEDIEST KIDS. IF WE LOOK AT
RURAL CALIFORNIA PER CAPITA.
REAL CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
RATES OF HOMELESSNESS AND STATE
FACTS. HUMBOLDT COUNTY HAS. THE
HIGHEST. HOMELESS RATE PER
CAPITA IN THE STATE AND THE
THIRD HIGHEST IN AMERICA
MENDOCINO COUNTY HAS THE
SEVENTH. HIGHEST ALMOST RATE.
IN AMERICA AND IT'S A COMMUNITY
OF SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND VOTES.
DATE THESE RURAL COUNTIES HAVE
THE HIGHEST RATES OF ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES BOTH
PHYSICAL AND SEXUAL ABUSE OUR
HIGHEST RATES OF KIDS IN
POVERTY PER CAPITA. IN WE KNOW
THAT WHEN CONNECT. HAPPENS IN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES OUR
ECONOMY PROSPERS AND I THINK
THAT'S BEEN A FRUSTRATION. THAT
WE'VE HAD FOR DECADES IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA. ALL RIGHT SO I JUST
WANT TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
POLITICS OF IT. BECAUSE WE CAN
TALK TO WEAR BLUE IN THE FACE
THAT WE NEED AN ACTIVITY LET'S
JUST BE REALLY OPEN AND BLUNT.
IT'S THE POLITICS THAT EXIST IN
THE LEGISLATURE ON WHY WE'RE
NOT SEEING CONNECTED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE CAL TALE- ALMOST
EVERY YEAR. CHU I'M SPECIAL
INTERESTS LIKE TELECOM AND
CABLE SO THAT WE DON'T PROVIDE.
EASIER ACCESS TO OPERATE
MUNICIPAL OPTIONS ARE HAPPENING
MUNICIPAL. MUNICIPALITIES BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH REGIONAL
CARRIERS LIKE SONIC TO BE ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT. THEIR OWN
SOLUTIONS BETTER BRIDGE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE THIS HAS
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH POLITICS
AND NOT SOUND POLICY IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE I WHY WE
CONTINUE TO SEE THIS DIGITAL
BY. INCREDIBLY. FRUSTRATING I
WILL SAY THE AT. WHEN THERE ARE
NO WINNERS BEEN MUNICIPAL
UNVEILED. IN YOUR INCITING OF
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES FOR MONEY
OUT WE IT'S NOT COME OUT T. A
BOY. AND TO BE OUT OF SIGHT
NEEDS. MUNIS OPTION IN THESE
GRANTS TO BE TO SLOW. TO CAN
FOR A LOCAL GUY OR SMALL
REGIONAL CARRIER MEDIUM RANGE
CARRIER GET PROVIDE. FIBER
BECAUSE WHEN IT'S THE SUPER
SLOPE. THERE ARE AREAS WHERE
COM AND AT&T AND VERIZON ONE
NEVER GOT NAY WILL NEVER GO BUT
WHAT I'VE SEEN IN MY NECK OF
THE WOODS IS THAT NAY WILL SITE
THEY WILL FIGHT TOOTH AND NAIL
TO BE ABLE TO STOP. AT SMALL
PROJECTS ARE MEDIUM SIZED
PROJECTS ARE BEING DUMPED OUT.
AND I AGREE WITH THE CHAIR OR
THE CHAIR AND STAND UNITED NOT
SOME OF THE NEWS THE
COMMISSIONER REPUBLICAN CHILES
COMMISSION ON THE. STATUS AND
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR HER
WORK. I WERE WE ARE HAVE
CHALLENGE. IS WHERE FIBER
EXISTS MOST LARGE COMPANIES
WON'T ALLOW ACCESS EVEN YES
THERE ARE COUNTIES IN THE STATE
IS WILLING TO PAY AND THAT'S
THE BOTTOM LINE TO THE LEASE ON
THE NORTH COAST WHERE LIFE'S
FIBER EXIST IT'S DARK IN THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THIS FIBER
GOES THROUGH OUT YET THEY WON'T
FIGHT IN NOT ALLOW WORKING
ACTIVITY. IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
I SAY ALL THAT IS I AGREE WITH
MS MCINTYRE NEWS MCINTYRE'S
ALWAYS PUT HERSELF AT THE TABLE
AND I DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THIS BACKING TRACK
REPRESENTS PEOPLE OUGHT TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE COLLABORATIVE
CONVERSATIONS AND I AGREE WITH
THAT. I GREE WITH MR ASK FOR
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO EASE
PERMITTING WE DO NEED TO EASE
PERMITTING ACROSS THE STATE
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO. CONNECT
OUR COMMUNITIES BUT IN RETURN I
DO BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES
OR URBAN COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY
URBAN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BE
ABLE TO LAUNCH THEIR OWN
PROGRAM THEIR OWN PROGRAM THEY
LOOK LIKE A WIDE FIRE BROADBAND
DISTRICTS VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
WE HAVE WITH SEWER AND WATER
ELECTRIC- AND- ALLOW THOSE
COMMUNITIES WE ARE WORK WITH
THE REGIONAL CARRIER LIKE A
SONIC. I TO BE ABLE TO LAUNCH
THE- BROADBAND OR WIFI WITHIN
WAR INCORPORATED COMMUNITY- TO
BE ABLE TO CONNECT YOUR KIDS
AND BE A CONNECTOR FAMILIES.
LASTING ALL SAVES THIS. THERE
ARE AREA ON THE NORTH COAST.
THAT HOT SPOT WILL WORK THERE
IS NO SO. TOWERS IN THE ALL WAY
BE ABLE TO GET CAN. WITH
CONNECTED INTERNAL IS SATELLITE.
AND SATELLITE IS INCREDIBLY.
WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
THE GOVERNMENT EDUCATION TO BE
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE A RATE VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT COMCAST IS DONE
AND I WANT TO SAY. WE NEED TO
POINT OUT WHEN THEY DO GOOD AND
COMCAST IS DONE GOOD WITH OUR
COMCAST ESSENTIAL PROGRAM
PROVIDING. LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND KIDS ACCESS. TO THE
INTERNET IN EXPLAINING THAT
PROGRAM BY THE WAY I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THEM.
THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC. BUT
WE ALSO ARE FOCUSED ON A NON
REGULATED UTILITY THAT WE HAVE.
BECAUSE IT'S REGULATED AT THE
SEC AND ADDS SATELLITE IN
MAKING SURE THAT FOR THOSE KIDS
WHO HAVE NO OTHER ALTERNATIVE
BUT TO GET RETURNED A
SATELLITE. THAT WE ARE GOING TO
BAT IN THIS WHILE YOU CAN
DOLLARS IN FEDERALLY REGULATED
UTILITIES. I DON I DID TOO LONG
AND I'M SORRY A LITTLE BIT OF A
SOAPBOX I'M HAPPY TO HEAR FROM
ANY OF OUR PANELISTS MANAGER
BUT- I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
THERE IS- AN INCREDIBLE.
FRUSTRATION IN FACT DOWNRIGHT
ANGER AT TIMES. THAT WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT THIS WE KNOW WHAT
THE SOLUTIONS ARE BUT LIKE.
THIS ONE INSTEAD- WE LET THE
POLITICS GET IN THE WAY OF THE
GOOD. AND I THINK YOU SO MUCH
ADVENTURE THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE- I TO. ALSO FEEL A LOT
OF YOUR FRUSTRATION AND WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT SOLUTIONS AND
THAT'S CERTAINLY WHY WE'RE
HERE- BUT WILL OPEN THAT UP TO
THE PANELISTS OF ANYONE WOULD
LIKE. TO RESPOND TO THAT WE
WOULD LOVE TO. HERE YOU. WELL
MADAM CHAIR NO ONE ELSE WISHES
TO SPEAK ON IT I'M HAPPY TO
STATE HERE THAT WOULD RESHAPE
IT SENATORS CANDOR- THAT THIS
IS BEEN A MATTER OF BOTH
POLITICS AND ABOUT A LACK OF
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES IT IS HEART
BREAKING THAT THERE ARE
COMPANIES THAT SIMPLY WILL NOT
INVEST IN RULE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THEY DON'T THINK THAT
THE POPULATION IS BROAD ENOUGH
FOR THEM TO IT WOULD BE
PROFITABLE AND SO THAT MEANS
WE'VE ALLOWED CALIFORNIANS TO
GO ABOUT SOMETHING THEY NEED
NOT JUST FOR THE PANDEMIC WE
WANT OUR STUDENTS TO BE READY
FOR THE JOBS OF TOMORROW WE
WANT THEM TO BE THE COMPUTER
SCIENTISTS AND ENGINEERS. AND
THAT BE HEALTH EXPERTS AND HAVE
ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED INTERNET
CHAT NOT JUST AT HOME BUT AT
SCHOOL- LOWER OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC IN THERE IN IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND SO WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WHAT THE SENATORS
TALK ABOUT LOOKING INTO ALL
KINDS OF OPTIONS INCLUDING
INCLUDING SATELLITE WE THINK
THAT THERE ARE SOME POTENTIAL
OPPORTUNITIES THERE IT IS VERY
VERY EXPENSIVE- BUT WE THINK
THAT THERE ARE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES AND AGAIN WE WANT
TO PURSUE THEM FULL SPEED AHEAD
AND HAPPY TO WORK WITH- CENTER
AND WITH YOURSELF MADAM CHAIR
AND- SENATOR. LEYVA OUR
TECHNOLOGY PARTNERS IN. THE
ENTIRE LEGISLATURE AS WE MOVE
FOR. I'M THIS IS YOUR WHAT CAN.
I BUT I BELIEVE THAT THAT.THERE ARE MANY. AND TO. USE
EXISTING PUBLIC INVESTMENTS
ESPECIALLY IN. SUBURBAN AND
RURAL AREAS- WE SEE RAIL
ALIGNMENT SPECIES MARC
CORRIDORS WE SEE- OLD ABANDONED
TELECOM ASSETS. WE SEE AGAIN
ABANDONED. GAS PIPELINES SO
LARGE AND EXTENSIVE WATER.
NETWORKS AND VARIOUS OTHER.
UTILITIES THAT WOULD ENABLE
GOVERNMENTS TO SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE THE COST OF
CONSTRUCTION. AND IN THE IN THE
COURSE OF DOING THAT TO ENABLE.
FACILITATE PRIVATE INVESTMENT
TO DO THE LAST MILE
CONNECTIVITY WITHIN THESE RURAL
AREAS TO FILL. IN THE FOR
BROADBAND. WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
A TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER WILSON THANK YOU MISTER
SUPERINTENDENT FOR THOSE
ANSWERS AND SENATOR MCGUIRE FOR
YOUR QUESTION WILL MOVE ON TO
SENATOR TO BOOT ASAL AND THEN
TO CENTER LEYVA. THANK YOU- IN
SCHOOL IT'S WONDERFUL TO CA
MIGHT MY COLLEAGUES HERE AND
I'M GLAD I CAME UP. AFTER
SENATOR MCGUIRE- BECAUSE OF
WHAT HE SAID WHICH IS REALLY
POWERFUL AND CLEAR. THANK YOU
SIR LEYVA THANK YOU CENTER. BUT
IF WE DON'T HAVE THAT OF COME.
THEN FORGET IT WE'RE NOT WE'RE
NOT DOING OUR KIDS ANY JUSTICE
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT DEFENDING
THEM WE'RE NOT PROTECTING THEM
AND I JUST WANNA SAY FROM FROM
MY DISTRICT IS MORE OF A QUICK
COMMENT. THEN IT IS A QUESTION
BUT- MY DISTRICT ALL THE ALL
THE KIDS- I REPRESENT ARE IN
THE SECOND LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE COUNTRY IS SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS 80%
ARE LOW INCOME. THE NEW- L. A.
U. S. T. REPORT SAYS 60% OF THE
STUDENTS LOG ON TO THE
DISTRICTS VIRTUAL CLASSROOM
SOFTWARE ON A DAILY BASIS- ONE
IN FOUR FAMILIES IN L. A.
COUNTY WAS SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY RESOURCES.
THAT MEANS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND COUNTY HOUSEHOLDS
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES. SO AND
MOST OF THOSE BEING IN IN MY
DISTRICT AND WHAT ABOUT THE
PARENTS WHO DON'T HAVE THE- THE
ABILITY TO DO THIS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT HOME OR- THAT CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS DON'T KNOW HOW
TO DO THIS. I THINK IT'S
pWEALTHIEST CALIFORNIA IS
POINTING TO THESE ISSUES THOSE
KIDS WILL NEVER HAVE THE CHANCE
TO BE A TO FILL THE CAREERS AND
THE WORK FORCE NEEDS THAT THE
STATE HAS- AS LONG AS WE
CONTINUE TO DEFEND- WHATEVER
PRACTICES LEAD. TO WHAT'S GOING
ON RIGHT NOW- SO- EVERYONE S.
SENATE MCGUIRE I WANT TO BE A
PARTNER WITH YOU TO TAKE THIS
OUT PUBLICLY WHAT CENTER THEN
SALAS AND CENTER LEYVA AND
ANYBODY ELSE. I THINK IT'S JUST
OUTRAGEOUS I. ONE COMMENT THAT
WAS MADE EARLIER. THAT I AGREED
IS NOT A AGING. PROBLEM THIS A
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE'VE GOT A FIX
AND- I SURE HOPE THAT THE P.
YOU SEE IN THOSE OF US IN THE
LEGISLATURE COME UP WITH THE-
WITH THE RIGHT ANSWER BECAUSE-
IT SHOULDN'T BE UP TO OUR
SUPERINTENDENTS TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO THIS THAT'S NOT THEIR
JOB THEIR JOB IS TO TEACH- AND
IT'S NOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S KIND OF
CONNECTIVITY OR DEVICES SO.
THANK YOU ALL I JUST WANT TO
MAKE THAT COMMENT AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
THE PANELS PUT IN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR
DROUGHT SO WE APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
SENATOR LEYVA THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ ON I JUST WANNA SAY
AMEN TO WHAT SENATOR ALSO SAID
AN AMEN TO WHAT SENATOR-
ACQUIRE OR SAID. THAT THE IT'S
REALLY INCREDIBLE THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY WE ARE STILL
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND IT ISN'T
JUST FOR SCHOOL CHILDREN HOW DO
PEOPLE DO THEIR WORK FROM HOME
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR OUR CAROL
MCINTYRE. MS MCINTYRE CAN
EXPLAIN HOW THE CAPE THE WELVE
BRIDGE TO BROADBAND. INITIATIVE
WORKS. IN REGARDS TO THE
VERIFICATION OF A STUDENT OR
FAMILIES ELIGIBILITY. IS IT
COMPLETELY UP TO THE SCHOOL TO
DETERMINE WHO IS ELIGIBLE SUCH
AS STUDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR FREE OR REDUCED PRICE MEALS
TO SERVICE PROVIDERS CONTACT
FAMILIES TO DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY AND IF SO WHAT
INFORMATION IS SOUGHT CREDIT
HISTORY CURRENT INCOME. IF YOU
COULD ENLIGHTEN US A LITTLE BIT
THAT BE REALLY HELPFUL. M.
SENATOR LEYVA I THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION- I HAD A LITTLE
BIT BACK FEET BUT I BELIEVE I.
AM UNDERSTOOD WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING WHICH IS HOW THE
FAMILIES ARE IDENTIFIED AND HOW
THEIR QUALIFYING- I'M FORTY BE
LOW INCOME PROGRAM OFFERINGS
YEAH. THE CTA MEMBER COMPANIES
THEY WORK WITH THE ATTEMPT TO
WORK WITH THE SCHOOLS AND- IN
MANY CASES WITH COMMUNITY
PARTNERS. TO IDENTIFY
POPULATIONS THAT MAY ACTUALLY
QUALIFY FOR THE PROGRAM. AND
THEN ONCE THOSE POPULATIONS ARE
A QUALIFYING AND THEN THE
FAMILY NEED APPLY AND VARIOUS
FORMS OF IDENTIFICATION FOR
THEM TO CONFIRM WHO AND THE AT
THE CUSTOMER ACTUALLY IS. ARE
ACCEPTABLE AND MANY CASES NO
CREDIT REPORT IS REQUIRED I
THEY SIMPLY NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THE NEEDS BE CRITERIA FOR THE
PROGRAM. WHICH IS ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE FREE OR REDUCED LUNCH
PROGRAM OR AND NOW THEIR SOCIAL
SERVICE PROGRAMS DEPENDING ON
THE COMPANY I'M AND THEN AND
GET PROPERLY IDENTIFIED SO THAT
THE COMPANY MAY PROVIDE. THEM
WITH SERVICE. THE YOU SO WHEN
POPER AT. THAT THE THEIR
VARIOUS. THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THE CUSTOMER DEPENDING ON WHAT
THEY WANT TO OPERATE THEY CAN
SIMPLY OFFER A DRIVER'S LICENSE
OR- AN AUTHOR ACCENTUAL
SECURITY I THINK IF IN FACT
THAT'S WHAT THEY CHOOSE TO
VARIOUS COMPANIES. I WILL
NARROW IT IS SIMPLY TO CONFIRM
THE IDENTIFICATION OF THE
POTENTIAL CUSTOMER IN THEN THE
INFORMATION IT'S NOT RETAIN
THEIR AFTER THANK YOU I KNOW
THAT THIS IS SECURITY NUMBERS
WAS AN ISSUE THAT WE HAD WHEN
WE FIRST STARTED THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE TASK FORCE AND WE'D ASK
PROVIDERS TO NOT ASK FOR THAT
SO IT SOUNDS LIKE WHAT I'M
HEARING YOU SAY IS THAT. YOUR
PROVIDERS DO NOT ASK FOR IT BUT
IT'S AN OPTION THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE IT THE OPTION IS UP TO
THE CONSUMER BUT FORM AND
IDENTIFICATION THEY LIKE TO
PROVIDE AND THEN FOR CREDIT
HISTORY YOU SAID IN MANY CASES
IT IS NOT NEEDED. WHY WOULD IT
BE EVER NEEDED. WELL FIRST
SEVEN NEW CUSTOMERS THE
COMPANY'S WERE IN FACT RAINY I
CREDIT REPORTS. THAT PRACTICE
IS NO LONGER IN PLACE INSIDE
CULVERT- HAS BEEN- AND HAS
BECOME A PROBLEM. THANK YOU-
ONE OTHER QUESTION I KNOW WHEN
THE COMMISSIONER TALKED ABOUT-
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNMENT
REGULATING. INTERNET SERVICE
YOU SAID THAT YOU DID NOT AGREE
WITH THAT I'M JUST CURIOUS WHY.
AS THE COMPANIES ARE
COMPETITIVE INDUSTRY COMPANIES
THAT HAVE ME PRIVATE
INVESTMENTS INTO THE NETWORKS
TO BUILD AND DEPLOY BROADBAND
IN MOST OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT ANY RATE OF
RETURN WHICH IS GENERALLY THE
MODEL THAT IS APPLIED TO RATE
REGULATED COMPANIES AS WELL-
THE ELECTRIC AND GAS UTILITIES
THAT CURRENTLY OPERATE THE
STATE. PLUS AND THE ENVIRONMENT
IS MUCH MORE COMPETITIVE WHERE
YOU GENERALLY HAVE AT LEAST TWO
PROVIDERS USUALLY MORE I
PROVIDING ASK SERVICE IN THE
END OF THE YEAR IN ATHERTON
COMMUNITY. WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY AND WE KNOW WE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH SERVICE IN
MOST OF THE STATE AND WITH THE
COMPETITIVE NATURE OF THE CABLE
INDUSTRY AN INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDER PROVIDERS- FRANKLY IT
HASN'T GOTTEN DONE. SO HAVING
GOVERNMENT STEP IN HAVING THE
LEGISLATURE STEP IN. ISN'T THAT
A WAY FOR US TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS. LET ME BE
CLEAR WE SUPPORT THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO DEPLOY BROADBAND
21100% 98% WHATEVER THE STATE'S
GOAL IS. OUR WHAT WE DON'T
SUPPORT IS GOVERNMENT
SUBSIDIZED COMPETITION WE
BELIEVE THAT IT IS APPROPRIATE
TO SET A STANDARD FOR THE
MINIMUM SPEEDS AND THE TYPES OF
SERVICES THAT BE- CONSUMERS IT
SHOULD HANDLE. IT TO THE EXTENT
THAT THAT SERVICE IS NOT
AVAILABLE IN THERE'S NO PRIVATE
INVESTMENT TO ALTERNATELY BRING
THIS THE SERVICE ACT TO THAT
LEVEL. AND THEN WE SUPPORT THE
USE OF GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT BROADBAND
IS AVAILABLE. AS THE AND TWO
WITNESSES POINTED OUT EARLIER
IN THE GALLEY IN THE END
SUNDAY. REPRESENTATIVES THERE
ARE SOME CASES WHERE IT'S JUST
NOT ECONOMIC FOR A COMPETITIVE
COMPANY TO BE WILLING TO GO AND
MAKE A PRIVATE INVESTMENT SO WE
ARE FULLY SUPPORTIVE. AND
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIES BE AT THE
SURCHARGE SPENDING THAT HAS
BEEN AVAILABLE WERE AFTER
FINDING AND BECOMING AVAILABLE
TO SUPPORT IN THE AREAS. GREAT
THANK YOU THOSE ANSWERS WERE
VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU MA'AM
CHEROKEE CENTER LEAVE AND I
THINK COMMISSIONER SERVICE HAS
HER HAND UP AS WELL TO ADD. TO
THIS CONVERSATION COMMISSIONER.
IT THANK YOU CHAIR AND CHERYL
LEYVA. I JUST WANNA COUNTER THE
STOCK POINTED FACTS AND- WHICH
IS THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
COMPETITION WE CERTAINLY DON'T
HAVE COMPETITION WITH CABLE
PROVIDERS. VIRTUALLY EVERY
TERRITORY IS ONLY SERVED BY ONE.
CABLE COMPANY THERE ARE SOME
LIMITED AREAS WHERE THERE IS
ACTUAL COMPETITION WITHIN CABLE
AND THAT'S- WHAT YOU THINK IT
IS THE RICHER AREAS IN AS EVERY
STUDY I MENTIONED ALREADY FOUND
IT'S THE RICHER WHITER AREAS SO
THE COMPETITION THE MARKET IS
NOBODY IS COMPETING FOR POOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR THAT'S THE
PROBLEM IF WE'RE GONNA ALLOW
THESE CABLE COMPANIES TO PROFIT
FORTY AND 50% R. O. Y. ON THESE
RICHER WHITER COMMUNITIES. THEN
THEY SHOULD HAVE THE OBLIGATION
TO SERVE THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY
THIS IS WHERE THE OBLIGATION
COMES IN THERE'S NO COMPETITION
IN ALL OF THESE. AND BY THE WAY
I WANT TO ADD I AGREE WITH
SOMETHING THAT DANG SAID
EARLIER FROM SONIC. THE PROBLEM
WAS ADOPTION AND URBAN AREAS HE
IS OUR BIGGEST PROBLEM IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT'S WHERE
MILLIONS OF OUR CHILDREN ARE
BEING LEFT ALONE IT'S IN LA
IT'S IN THE BIG CITIES IN
OAKLAND IT'S AN FRESNO IT'S AN
BAKER STILL IT'S IN SACRAMENTO
IT'S IN THE CITIES. AND THESE
CABLE COMPANIES HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF SERVING THE WEALTHY
WITH NO OBLIGATION TO SERVE THE
POOR THE OTHER FRONTIER
EIGHTEEN ANTI SAME THING THEY
THEY DON'T HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO SERVE. THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE
A GOOD YOU KNOW HIGH FIBER
EVERYWHERE SO ANYWAY. I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT. THIS IS NOT
GONNA TO THE MARKET HAVE WE
WILL A LONG TIME AND IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT FINDING THE
ALTERNATIVE THAT'S GONNA TAKE A
LONG TIME WE- THESE COMPANIES.
SHOULD HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
SERVE THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
IT'S THE WE HAVE NO REPORTING
ON HOW THERE'S NO TRANSPARENCY
ON THESE LOW INCOME PLANS THAT
THEY'RE OFFERING. YES IT'S
GREAT THAT THEY'RE DOING THAT
BUT THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO DO
IT ALL THE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE WE DON'T KNOW HOW ONE
PERSON'S IMPLEMENTING IT OVER
ANOTHER. THERE'S NO UNIFORMITY
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT THERE'S
NO REPORTING WE ACTUALLY DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE
SIGNED UP FOR THESE PROGRAMS TO
EVEN GIVE THEMCREDIT. THAT
THIS IS HAPPENING THEY SHOULD
BE PUBLICLY REPORTED SO WE KNOW
WHERE THE POCKETS OF THEY'RE
STILL MISSING OUT AND CONTINUE
TO WORK ON PROGRESS THAT ARE.
IMMEDIATE LOW HANGING FRUITS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER AND I HAVE TO ADD
ON TO THAT I KNOW THAT THE IDEA
OF OPEN ACCESS OR OF WHICH IS
A- SYSTEM WHERE THE SAME
PHYSICAL NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE
IS USED AND SHARED BY MULTIPLE
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS-
IT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP IN. IN
PAST DISCUSSIONS- THESE COULD
BE COMMUNITY BASED OPEN ACCESS
NETWORKS COULD THAT COULD BE
NEUTRAL OPEN MARKET PLATFORMS
WERE SERVICE PROVIDERS ALL HAVE
EQUAL ACCESS TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SO I JUST WANTED
TO ASK ABOUT THAT AND PERHAPS-
EITHER- MISTER JASPER MISTER
WOLF CAN ALSO. DISCUSS THIS
BECAUSE THEY WOULD BE. AN OPEN
ACCESS NETWORK WOULD WOULD KIND
OF BE OPEN TO ALL- PROVIDERS
LARGE AND SMALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO IF WE CAN TOUCH
ON THAT AND WHY THAT WOULD BE
SO IMPORTANT. SB AS A PERTAINS
TO COMPETITION. I CAN START
THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR I THINK
IT'S KEY THAT GOVERNMENT'S
ASSISTANCE TO THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND YOU COMING INTO
AREAS WHERE THERE'S BEEN A LACK
OF INVESTMENT BECAUSE OF THESE
OBSTACLES- EITHER THE LACK OF
DENSITY OR THE- THE ISSUES OF-
OF COMPETITIVE CONTESTS ADAM
AND THE MARKET- WE HAVE SEEN
THAT IN THE COUNTY OF VENTURA
AND THAT NOW IN THE COUNTIES OF
SONOMA NAPA. MARIN MENDOCINO-
THAT ZZ WHEN THESE COUNTIES THE
CITIES COME TOGETHER- AND IN
THE SOUTH BAY IN CALIFORNIA
THIRTEEN CITIES CAME TOGETHER
THEY WERE ABLE TO REMOVE THESE
OBSTACLES BY PROVIDING AN OPEN
ACCESS MIDDLE MILE NETWORK THAT
ENABLED NEW ENTRANTS TO COME IN
AND INVEST IN JAIL AND THE LAST
MILE. AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING- WHAT'S KEY AND ALL
THIS IS THERE NEED TO BE
DROPPED STONES THERE NEEDS TO
BE. VISIBILITIES ABOUT. AND
IT'S SIX. TO BUILD ALL THAT- SO
EXCITES BUILDING THE MIDDLE
MILE BACKBONE THE CITIES AND
THESE COUNTIES ARE PROVIDING
THEIR CIP PROJECTS WHICH WERE
WERE WERE LOWERED THE COST OF
THE CONSTRUCTION. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THEY'RE PROVIDING KEY
PHYSICAL FACILITIES AND ASSETS
IN WHICH TO- PROVIDE FOR MEET
ME ROOMS- DROP ROOMS-
INTERCONNECTION POINTS FOR
PROVIDERS TO DO BUSINESS WITH
OTHER RESEARCH. AND OTHER
PROVIDERS- AND THAT'S REALLY
CHEESY. POSTURING THE BUILD OF
FIBER AND NETWORK WHERE THERE
ISN'T THERE ISN'T ONE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
MISTER WOLF A PRE SHEE YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS THERE- AND THEN A
MISSED SENATOR PENN HAS A
QUESTION I'LL GO TO HIM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION-
FIRST OF ALL IT PARDON MY
IGNORANCE WHAT IS WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT LOW INCOME AREAS AND WE I
HEARD SOMETHING ABOUT. WHAT WE
ONLY WANT TO SUBSIDIZE THE
MINIMUM. SO WE DON'T SUBSIDIZE
COMPETITION WHAT WHAT IS THAT
STANDARD. OF INTERNET ARE
BROADBAND THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT. WE'RE EXPECTING LOW
INCOME AREAS TO HAVE. I FELT
OUT OF MISS MCINTYRE WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE THEY THINK
YOU MADE REFERENCE TO THAT WHAT
WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT SPEED
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THAT IT'S
OKAY TO SUBSIDIZE BUT NOT.
ABOVE SENATE PANELS CAROLYN
MCINTYRE WITH CGA. WE SUPPORT
THE FCC'S STANDARD OF TWENTY
FIVE AND THREE. I TWENTY FIVE
MEGABITS PER SECOND DOWN AND
THREE ASK OKAY. SO I THANK YOU
SO I GUESS MY NEXT QUESTIONS
ACTUALLY TO OUR SUPERINTENDENT.
PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION TONY
THURMOND AND A I WANNA THANK SO
MUCH FOR LEADERS. LEAVE ME A LA
OF QUESTIONS ASK IN REGARD TO
SCHOOL OPEN. AND STAYING OPEN
THAT'S NOT THE SUBJECT OF THIS
HEARING BUT WHAT DID WANT TO
ASK YOU IS THAT. IS SUPERINTEND
PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION. HAS OF THE
PART OF EDUCATION LOOKED AT.
WHAT'S OF INTERNET DOES A
TYPICAL FAMILY NEED IN ORDER
FOR THEIR KIDS TO PEOPLE TO
ENGAGE IN THE DISTANCE LEARNING
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT THE FIRST
HALF OF THE HEARING. YOU KNOW
IF YOU HAVE TWO KIDS. THREE
KIDS EIGHTY MORE BUT EVEN WITH
JUST TWO OR THREE. WHAT KIND OF
SPEED INTERNET THE PEOPLE NEED
TO HAVE IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
HAVE RELIABLE CONNECTION. PETER
PAN- THERE'S BEEN MUCH DEBATE
ON THE SUBJECT. PUT IT. IN A
VERY FRANK WAGER THANK AT SOME
COMPANIES ARE NOT. PROVIDING
HIGH SPEED INTERNET. AND THEN
WHEN YOU COMBINE THAT WITH DATA
CAPS AND OTHER ISSUES YOU GET
COMPLAINTS SAID FAMILIES WHO
SAY- WE GET KICKED OFF- WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO GET. YOU KNOW
SUSTAINABLE INTERNET
CONNECTION- MULTIPLE FAMILIES
CANNOT BE ON AT THE SAME TIME.
AND SO THERE ARE THESE HUGE
CHALLENGES THAT. CONTINUE TO BE
A CHALLENGE IN THAT- PO CENTER
LAVINE I'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
NEXT- SET OF MEETINGS FOR THE-
CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE TASK
FORCE TO FOCUS ON THINGS LIKE.
THESE DATA CAPS AND SPEEDS YOU
KNOW A FEW WEEKS AGO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DATE THROUGH-
TO- TO AN EXECUTIVE BOARD TO
TALK ABOUT STANDARD SPEEDS THAT
PEOPLE SHOULD BE. WORKING
TOWARDS AND- YOU KNOW I I'M
SURE- THIS IS MY ME MUCH MORE
SPEAK TO THAT- THROUGH OUR
LANDS AT THE PC BUT THE REALITY
IS THAT. NOT ALL FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH
SPEED INTERNET AND IN
PARTICULAR OUR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES- FIND MORE TIMES THAN
NOT THAT THEY DO. NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED INTERNET.
IS THOMAS WITH COVERED IN. EVEN
RECOGNIZE THAT. ONCE WE
ACTUALLY CAN LET KIDS GET BACK
TO SCHOOL THEY'RE EITHER GONNA
DO HYBRID FOR AWHILE OR WE MAY
EVEN BE LOOKING AT. OTHER FORMS
OF USING THE INTERNET IS THIS
THIRD AS DIFFERENT. DIFFERENT.
AT THE TOP OF EDUCATE OR
SOMETHING ABOUT IS. FOR AT
LEAST FROM AN EDGE ONE. WHICH
BE. THE MINIMUM AT YOU KNO
WHAT WHAT TO THE TYPICAL FOR OR
HOW. WHAT'S THE MINIMUM LEVEL
OF ACCESS THEY SHOULD HAVE TO
BROADBAND IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
ENGAGE FULLY AND EDUCATION
WHICH IS A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
ACTUALLY HERE IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA. WE PARTNERED WITH
WITH THE PC WITH THE CPUC AND
THEIR JOB AND- IN THE
TECHNOLOGY DEPARTMENT REALLY
THEY REALLY TAKING THE LEAD ON
ESTABLISHING WHAT THOSE- SPEEDS
IN METRIC SHOULD BE WE AGREE.
THAT THERE SHOULD BE A- LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD- SO THAT EVERYONE
HAS ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET AND SO WHEN WE REACHED
OUT TO COMPANIES THAT HAVE SAID
WE'RE GOING TO DONATE- YOU KNOW
REDUCE COSTS. OF TECHNOLOGY IN
HOT SPOTS WE'VE ASKED THEM TO
MAKE THAT HIGH SPEED INTERNET
AND SO- I CAN TELL THAT THIS
WAS MY SERVICES IS TRYING TO
GET TO ANSWER THIS QUESTION
BECAUSE I'M IN HER LANE. AND
BUT WE AGREE WITH WHERE THE P.
C. P. C. IN OTHER PLACES ARE
MEETING TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
HIGH SPEED INTERNET OKAY AND I
DO WANT TO GET TO ACTUALLY A
COMMISSIONER GUZMAN ASSET BUT
JUST NEEDED ONE LAST QUESTION-
SUPER DENT THURMOND. AND ALSO
ASKED THE SAME QUESTION OF- THE
COMMISSIONER- WE HEARD THAT THE
FCC STANDARDS IS. THIRTY YEARS
TWENTY FIVE DOWN THIRTY UP THAT
IT'S PRIVATE CORRECTLY IS THAT
SUFFICIENT AS AS THE
PARTICIPATION LOOKED AT IT FOR
A FAMILY. TO BE ABLE ENGAGE IN
EDUCATION. I REALIZE PERHAPS A
QUESTIONS A LOT MORE COMPLEX
THAN SIMPLY ASKING THAT BUDGET
IS BUT THERE'S A BASELINE IS
THAT ENOUGH. AND WITH TO I CAN
CLARIFY AS WELL THE FEDERAL
STANDARD IS AS MENTIONED BY- MS
MCINTYRE IS TWENTY FIVE-
DOWNLOAD THREE UPLOAD RATE AND
I KNOW I'M COMMISSIONER SERVICE
CAN ELABORATE ON THIS- I THINK
THE FEDERAL- STANDARD FOR WHAT
WE'VE SEEN BIRTH. YOU KNOW
MULTIPLE KIDS IN THE HOUSEHOLD
I THINK HAS TO BE ABOVE TWENTY
FIVE I THINK WE'VE SEEN GOALS
OF A HUNDRED MEGABYTES UPS
UPLOAD AND A HUNDRED MEGABYTES
DOWNLOAD TO BE ABLE TO. SUSTAIN
IN THIS ARGUMENT VARMINT. AND
ALL KICK IT OFF TO IN THANK YOU
MISTER SUPERINTENDENT AS WELL
BUT I'LL KICK IT OFF TO
COMMISSIONER US OF ITS WHO
CONDUCTED THE TYPICALLY ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA STANDARDS. AS IT
PERTAINS TO OUR SUBSIDIZE WORK-
FOR SUBSIDIZED PLAN IN THE
CALIFORNIA SERVICES FUND. NO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER PAN I THINK THE- THE
QUESTION IS THAT. THE FCC
STANDARD TWENTY FIVE DOWN THREE
UP WAS PRE COATED. RIGHT NOW.
THE UPLOAD SPEED TO UP TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE STEP OF
RITUAL MEETING REQUIRES MORE
THAN THREE UP. AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT- A SITUATION WHERE
AT MINIMUM WE SHOULD BE HAVING
OUR CHILDREN AND ALL OF US
REALLY TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE IN
ALL INTERACTIONS. AT A HUNDRED
DOWN AND A HUNDRED UP. THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN MENTION
THE GOVERNOR SAID THE GOAL OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS A
HUNDRED DOWN HE LOOKED KIND OF
LEFT IT OPEN FOR THIS THE UP
SPEED. BUT WE CAN TELL YOU FOR
A FACT THAT. YOU KNOW THREE UP
IS INSUFFICIENT WE WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO DO THIS CONVERSATION
AND SO I KNOW DAY AND YOU HAD A
REALLY GOOD POINT EARLIER
ACTUALLY ON WHAT YOU SEE THE
NEED AS THE NEED IS FIBER. WE
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE SPEEDS
IT'S ALMOST LIKE ANOTHER TRICK
IT'S BEEN USED AS KIND OF LIKE
IS THIS THE INNER IS INTERNET A
COMMUNICATION SERVICE OR AN
INFORMATION SERVICE IT'S
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE TRICKS WE
TALK ABOUT SPEED. WHAT WE NEED
IS THE BEST INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
ALL CITIZENS FOR ALL PEOPLE IN
STATE CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
FIBER AND SO HUNDRED
SYMMETRICAL IS A MINIMUM. FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE FOR US TO HAVE
YOU KNOW ONE OR TWO KIDS
PARTICIPATING IN THE CLASSROOM
BEING ABLE TO SEE THEIR TEACHER
HAVE ALL THAT. ALL THOSE THINGS
ARE TIED TO MENTAL HEALTH SO
YOUR PANELISTS SPOKE OF EARLIER
HE NEEDS. TO BE AT LEAST A
HUNDRED SYMMETRICAL. JUST TO
CLEAR WHAT MOTHER SAYING IS
THAT. IT IS SOME TO KNOW THAT
COPPER CANNOT PROVIDE THAT KIND
OF UPLOAD SPEED SIGNIFICAN
UPLOAD SPEEDS- BEYOND- YOU KNOW
THE SIX MEGABITS PER SECOND- WE
ALSO KNOW THAT IT'S- NOT
CAPABLE OF DELIVERING A HUNDRED
MEGABITS DOWN- IN ANY CASE. IN
ANY ANY ANY ANY REAL COMMERCIAL
BASIS. SO IT REALLY DEFINES-
THESE SPEEDS THESE DEFINITIONS
OF SPEEDS REALLY DEFINE- THE
MEDIA. AND THAT IS STEP TO
FUTURE IS FIBER. THANK YOU I
GUESS MY DOT COM AND DEFERRED
WRAP UP IS JUST THAT AND THAT
THAT SORT OF GOT TO MY QUESTION
I ASKED THE SUPERINTENDENT TO
IS TO ME. OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT ALSO
NEED TO BE FIGURED OUT BUT WE
HAVE A- RIGHT TO AN EDUCATION
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN OUR CONSTITUTION. AND RIGHT
NOW LEISTER EDUCATIONS. VERY
DEPENDENT ON ACCESS TO
BROADBAND. EIGHT SO AND OF AT
LEAST A CERTAIN MINIMUM
CAPACITY. WHATEVER THAT IS AND-
DEBTS AND SO I HOPE THAT OUR
DEPARTED EDUCATION. SO OUR
SUPERINTENDENT IN OUR GOVERNOR
CAN WORK TOGETHER AND DEFINE
WHAT THAT IS. BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S A SEPARATE STANDARD AND
JUST THE FTC STANDARD. BECAUSE
WE DO HAVE. DON'T STUDENT
CHILDREN HAVE A RIGHT TO AN
EDUCATION HERE AND CITY
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE DO NEED TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE MEET THAT
STANDARD. AND WHAT KIND OF
REQUIREMENTS AND DEMANDS WE
NEED TO PUT ON- BUT IT'S OUR-
SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE FOLKS OR OTHER
TYPES OF INVESTMENTS WE NEED TO
MAKE COMES OF SUBSIDIES OR
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS AS THE
STATE GOVERNMENT AND ALSO WHAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MAY NEED TO
DO. IN ORDER TO TRIED IT IS
SURE WE MEET AT CONSTITUTIONAL
STANDARD OF THAT RIGHT OF
EDUCATION THANK YOU. AND I KNOW
YOU SAID YOU WANTED TO ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT OPENING AND
THINGS THAT NEED TO WORK WITH
YOU OFFLINE. OUR OFFICE WOULD
ALSO BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
ON THIS VERY ISSUE THAT YOU
RAISE I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR-
WE CAN WORK WITH THE CPUC AND
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION. WE
CAN PUT OUT A RECOMMENDATION
BUT WITHOUT LEGISLATION OR
REGULATION THEY WILL NOT HAVE
ANY IMPACT. AND SO YOU KNOW.
AGAIN WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE ON A VERY SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS. IN CALIFORNIA
WE'D BE HAPPY TO DO THAT. THANK
YOU SUPERMAN THURMOND I LOOK
FOR TO ARE. OFF LINE FOR THE
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT
THAT AND APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN.
AM AND JUST TO BE CLEAR AS
WELL- I HAVE TO MENTION THAT
YOU KNOW THE ALIFORNIA
SERVICES FUND RIGHT NOW AS IT
STANDS IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
BELOW THE FEDERAL STANDARD. SIX
DOWNLOAD SPEED ONE UPLOAD SPEED
IS OUR CURRENT STANDARDS WERE
WELL BELOW THE FEDERAL
STANDARD- FOR MEANING FOR THOSE
WHO COULD BE. DEFINED AS SERVED
UNDER THAT PLAN- WITH THAT I
JUST WENT LIVE. VEGAS MANAGER
CAN I JUST MAKE IT CLEAR FIND
TREATMENT HERE TO CAROLYN
MCINTYRE. I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT AS THE CTA MEMBERS
OFFERS SERVICE. AT
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER SPEEDS
THAN TWENTY FIVE THREE- I
SIMPLY WANTED TO RESPOND TO THE
QUESTION EARLIER ABOUT WHAT WE
CONSIDERED. INSUFFICIENT
SERVICE AND THAT'S LESS THAN
TWENTY FIVE THREE. BUT ALL OF
THE CTA'S MEMBERS OFFER GIGABIT
SERVICE. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
BEG TO DIFFER WITH THE FACT
THAT FIBER IS THE ONLY WAY TO
GET THERE. MANY OF THESE
NETWORKS ARE ON HIGH BRED. AND
FIND BERMAN CALLING. AND SO I
WOULD ON LIKE TO IT'S IN IN THE-
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO ACTUALLY
RECEIVE A PRESENTATION. ON
NETWORK FUNCTIONALITY WHAT'S
ACTUALLY NEEDED AND REAL DATA
TO SUPPORT HOW THE NETWORK IS
ACTUALLY BEING USED DURING HELP
AT. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
PUBLIC POLICY DECISIONS ARE
GOING TO BE BASED ON WHAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY SEEING IN THE MARKET
AND WHAT IS ACTUALLY AVAILABLE
FROM A TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
STANDPOINT. THANK YOU MISS
MCINTYRE WE APPRECIATE THAT-
AND JUST A VERY LAST QUESTION
THAT I HAVE IN THE WE'RE GONNA
TURN IT BACK OVER TO SENATOR
LEYVA- TO TAKE ON A PUBLIC
COMMENT- WAS JUST DIGITAL
LITERACY I KNOW WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT THE HARDWARE AND WE
TALKED VERY. IN DEPTH ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT HOW DO WE
HELP PARENTS AND STUDENTS- IN A
SIGNIFICANT WAY WITH DIGITAL
LITERACY PROGRAMS AND- FOR THAT
I WILL KICK THAT OFF TO A
SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND IF YOU
CAN ANSWER THAT AND HOW WE CAN
JUST HELP YOU. MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
APPRECIATE YOU ASKING THAT WE
THINK THAT THIS CONVERSATION
HAS TO BE MORE THAN JUST.
PROVIDING A STUDENT WITH A
COMPUTING DEVICE. OR A HOT
SPOT. WE THINK THAT THERE ARE
ONE WE HAD BEEN SUSTAINED- THE
PROVISION OF EQUIPMENT OVER
TIME- MANY OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY ARE USING
EVEN THOSE THAT ARE IN A ONE TO
ONE RELATIONSHIP. STUDENTS ARE
USING DEVICES THAT OFTEN DON'T
WORK WHEN THEY GO TO TAKE
STANDARDIZED TESTS YOU KNOW
THEY FIND THEMSELVES OPENING
DEVICES FOR THE FIRST TIME BUT
ALSO AREN'T WORKING. AREN'T
FUNCTIONAL AND SO WE NEED A
VERY BROAD A ROBUST PLANNED ON
CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
THAT IT LOOKS AT EQUIPMENT THAT
LOOKS AT TRAINING FOR STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES ARE ASKING FOR
TRAINING. IN SUPPORT AND YOU
KNOW MANY OF OUR EDUCATORS ARE
ASKING FOR TRAINING ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES THAT WE
HEARD. WHEN THIS IS LEARNING
BEGAN IN MARCH IS THAT THERE
WERE JUST SOME EDUCATORS AND
STAFF WHO JUST WEREN'T
COMFORTABLE- YOU KNOW. USING
THE COMPUTERS IN THE WAYS THAT
THEY HAD NOT USED THEM BEFORE
IS SO WE DO NEED DIGITAL.
LITERACY AND TRAINING FOR EVERY
ASPECT OF THE EDUCATIONAL
FAMILY OF THOSE RESOURCES DON'T
EXIST RIGHT NOW FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- SOME DISTRICTS DO
BETTER THAN OTHERS. BUT THOSE
RESOURCES DON'T EXIST THIS IS
EGGS DEFINITELY OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR YOU THE NEW LEGISLATION OR
FOR WORK IN THE BUDGET AND WE
WOULD AGREE WITH YOU MADAM
CHAIR THAT IS WE HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD. IT
ABSOLUTELY HAS TO FOCUS ON THE
RECEIPT TRAINING AND SUPPORT.
FOR THE STUDENTS THEIR FAMILIES
AND EDUCATORS WILL BE USING
THIS EQUIPMENT AND HOW TO
SUSTAIN IT. A LOT OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE THIS KIND OF
PATCHWORK QUILT OF DIFFERENT
OPERATING SYSTEMS AND THINGS
THAT THEY'RE USING. YOU KNOW WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THINGS BE
MORE EFFECTIVE IN STREAMLINED
AND WILL RESOURCE IN A WELL
MAINTAINED- AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR INTEREST. IN THE DIGITAL
LITERACY WE HAVE TO WORK WITH
YOU AND OTHERS ON THAT SUBJECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
SUPERINTENDENT AND I DO HAVE A
QUESTION A. REYES TEN BY
SENATOR DODD. YES PLANCHEREL
TAKE YOU MUCH UP FOR VERY AND
IN FOR ALL THE SPEAK FOR THIS
VERY INFORMED CONVERSATION WHAT
IT'S REALLY DRILL DOWN TO ME IS
THAT THAT. THERE ARE SO MANY
MORE QUESTIONS THAN THERE ARE
ANSWERS- IN THIS PANEL THEY
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE THE
SIGNIFICANT. DIGITAL DIVIDE
LONG BEFORE- CODE NINETEEN AND
WE SEE IN THE- DESPERATE-
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE
PARTICULARLY IN. LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND IT JUST HOW
UNSETTLING THAT IS AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LEGISLATION
PERHAPS COMING OUT THIS YEAR.
YEAH I AM VERY VERY VERY
CONCERNED THAT THIS IS YEAH
HUGELY COMPLICATED ISSUE THAT
SOMETIMES WITH YEAH WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO THE TELL
COMMUNITY CATIONS INDUSTRY IS
MADE TO LOOK LIKE THIS BLACK
BOX THAT- YELLOW. I DO YOU KNOW
WHERE I'M GOING WITH THIS I
REALLY THINK THAT WE NEED. YEAH
A TASK FORCE THAT YOU KNOW I
KNOW THE OVER HOUSTON PEOPLE
SAY OH GEEZ THAT'S- YEAH I'M
GONNA TAKE TOO MUCH TIME BUT
THE REALITY IS HERE WE ARE. IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
STATE OF INNOVATION. AND WHAT I
JUST WHAT I DID HEARING YES
AGAIN MORE QUESTIONS THAN WE
HAVE ANSWERS TO WE NEED BETTER
OUT. OF SPEED DOWNLOAD SPEED
THAT IS YOU KNOW CLEAR TO BE
BUT- IS FAR AS AFFORDABILITY IN
GETTING OUR STUDENTS TO WHERE
THEY'RE EVEN CLOSE TO WHERE
THEY NEED TO BE. I DON'T KNOW
HOW WE GET THERE I KNOW I
APPRECIATE- SUPERINTENDED-
SERMONS IS UP OUT SHE DIDN'T.
IN WORK ETHIC ON THIS WE ALL
NEED TO GET ON BOARD BUT I
THINK WE GOT TO FIND OUT. SOME
MORE CRITICAL- YOUR ASSAM
REALLY DEEP QUESTIONS IN IT IT
REALLY GET DOWN TO THE POINT
WHERE WE KNOW WHERE WE'RE GOING
INSTEAD OF. YOU KNOW MAKING
THIS ON THE FLY YOU KNOW MAYBE
SOME OF THESE OTHER COMPANIES
HAVE THAT ALREADY AND WE
HAVEN'T HEARD THAT THAT MAY BE
A TOPIC. FOR ANOTHER BE MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN AND I'D BE DELIGHTED
TO HEAR THAT I WOULD LIKE TO.
TAKE A- THIS MCINTYRE
INTERPRETATION. TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THIS TOPIC CAN TAKE ME
THROUGH. AND MAYBE OTHERS
THROUGH WHAT. OF WHAT SHE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THEIR TO GET MORE
INFORMATION I'D SOUGHT I DO
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S TIME AND
EFFORT- THIS ON THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC THANK YOU
SENATOR DARDEN I HAVE
SUPERINTENDED ME ASSURE WHO HAS
TO STAND UP. THANK YOU I WASN'T
SURE IF IT WAS APPROPRIATE
TREES MAN ON THIS PANEL THAT
TONY AND- AND SENATORS I WOULD
LOVE TO HELP WITH THIS
INITIATIVE. WE'VE BEEN VERY
STRATEGIC AND THOUGHTFUL AND
OUR TECHNOLOGY IMPLEMENTATION
DEPLOYMENT. AND IT'S ALL
INTERRELATED WITH ASSESSMENT
DATA ACCOUNTABILITY IS NOT JUST
A STANDALONE THING THAT YOU
KNOW IF THE DEVICES AND THINGS
CHANGE. BUT THAT'S- THE WAY WE
BRING OUR EDUCATORS AND THE
CONVERSATION EMPOWER THEM WITH
THE TOOLS. TO LEARN ALONGSIDE
WITH THE STUDENTS. BUT ALSO
THING POST PANDEMIC YOU KNOW
WHAT IS OUR LONG TERM
TECHNOLOGY STRATEGY. THERE'S A
TERM CALLED THE HOMEWORK GAP
THAT EXISTED BEFORE KOVIN. AND
REFERRED TO THE STUDENTS THAT
HE DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO
UBIQUITOUS AND FREE WIFI. A TO
DO THEIR HOMEWORK AND DISTRICT
LIKE OURS IT'S REQUIREMENTS OUR
KIDS HAVE TO. ACCESS HIGH
QUALITY DIGITAL TOOLS FROM
THEIR HOME. SO IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WE MADE AN EFFORT TO
CONNECT EVERY FAMILY BACK THEN
KNOWING THAT THERE IS AN
INEQUITY IF WE DIDN'T- IT'S
EXCITING TO HEAR THE
CONVERSATION HERE ABOUT. MAKING
THIS MORE TO CALIFORNIA EFFORT-
BUT WHEN YOU MANDATE THE
COMMENT THAT WE CAN'T LEAVE
THIS FOR SUPERINTENDENTS TO DO
IT ON OUR OWN. I'M NOT ALONE IN
IN LEADING A DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION. AND THERE ARE A
FEW IN CALIFORNIA THAT I THINK
ALONG WITH TONY CAN REALLY.
MAKE IT EASIER FOR OTHERS TO
START THINKING ABOUT WE JUST
PURCHASED ALL THESE TOOLS. NOW
HOW DO WE MAKE IT A UBIQUITOUS
PART OF OUR OUR SYSTEM. THANK
THE LITTLE WITH THAT THANK YOU
SUPERINTENDENT- I WILL JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING THAT- THIS TIME
CALLS FOR CREATIVE AND BOLD
SOLUTIONS WE CANNOT CALL
OURSELVES ONCE AGAIN THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY WITH LEAVING.
SO MANY KIDS BEHIND RULE A
COMMUNITY CHILDREN URBAN KIDS
AND EVERYONE IN BETWEEN
ESPECIALLY SENIORS THAT NEED
THIS FOR TELEHEALTH SERVICES AS
WE'RE SEEING AN UPTICK. SO WITH
THAT I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO THIS PANEL. I'M GONNA
KICK IT BACK TO SENATOR LEYVA.
SORRY ONE MOMENT. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE
GONZALEZ THAT WAS A GREAT PANEL
AND I AGREE I THINK SOMETIMES
THERE ARE MORE QUESTIONS THAN
ANSWERS BUT I ALSO THINK THAT
WE ARE ALL COMMITTED I THINK
YOU HEARD FROM EVERYONE THAT
WE'RE COMMITTED TO GETTING THIS
DONE SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO. GO
TO OUR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TWO ONE MINUTE EACH
PLEASE NOW LET'S BEGINWITH ANY
WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE PROCEED SIR ONE
MINUTE. GOOD AFTERNOON SHOW
EVENTUALLY SALAS AND SENATORS
OUTSOURCING STRATEGIES THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF LIGHTSPEED
SYSTEMS THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING TODAY
GREAT SEE YOU ALL- SO MANY
ISSUES WITHIN THE CONNECTIVITY
DISCUSSION ALL THOSE OBVIOUSLY
SUCH A CRITICAL PIECE EVEN WITH
COVERT ASIDE- BUT GIVEN THE
EMPHASIS ON DISTANCE LEARNING
IS THAT MUCH MORE CRITICAL THAT
WE AS A STATEMENT ACCESS
AVAILABLE FOR ALL AGAIN THE
CHARLIE WERE YOU OPENED WITH
THE DISCUSSION ON MENTAL HEALTH
IN YOUR AN EXCELLENT- A
CONVERSATION. WITH MISS SURELY
FROM CORONA NORCO UNIFIED AS A
STATE FACILITATES CONVERSATIONS
ON DISTANCE LEARNING I THINK
IT'S ACTUALLY CRITICAL WE
ALWAYS ALSO CONSIDER ONLINE
SAFETY INTO IN PRIVACY THIS IS
A KEY PART OF LIGHT SPEEDS
MISSION IN A CRUCIAL PILLAR
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR THE STATE
AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO FACTOR
IN AGAIN ESTABLISHING
CONNECTIVITY FOR ALL IS
PARAMOUNT THERE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES WITHIN THIS
BROAD DISCUSSIONS BUT SO WE
STAND READY TO ASSIST WHERE WE
CAN TO BE SUPERINTENDENT BERMAN
IS MADE- MENTAL HEALTH A
PRIORITY DURING THIS PERIOD
WHICH WE ARE GREATLY
APPRECIATIVE AND SUPPORTIVE OF
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE CD AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS I THINK A SENATOR-
JACKSON MADE THE POINT SHE- PUT
THE NAIL RIGHT ON THE HEAD AND
SAID HOW OR WHAT TOOLS ARE
AVAILABLE TO ASSESS. HOW OUR
STUDENTS LEARNING WHAT MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE
IN THIS ERA OF DISTANCE
LEARNING. THAT'S REALLY WHERE
LIGHTSPEED LIVE SAID AS A
NEIGHBORHOOD ONE HUNDRED. SO
STAND READY TO CONTINUE THIS.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S A GOOD CRITICAL
PIECE OF THE CONNECTIVITY
LOOKED TO CONTINUING THE MOVE
IN THIS ISSUE ALONG WITH YOUR
THANK YOU SO MUCH GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY THAT
WHICH IT WISHES TO SPEAK. ONE
MOMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON PLEASE
PROCEED. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON.
DID YOU HAVE SOME COMMENTS I DO
I HAVE LOTS OF COMMENTS ALRIGHT
WE HAVE ONE MINUTE AND YOU CAN
ALL RIGHT I'M USING MY MINUTE
USE IT YOUR FIFTEEN MINUTES
INTO A FIFTEEN SECONDS INTO IT.
MY HUSBAND SAT HERE FOR THREE
HOURS AND HE JUST HAD TO LEAVE
FOR HIS THIRD JOB. HE'S A
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER. YOU
WOULD HAVE BEEN WILD TO LISTEN
TO HIM. INSTEAD WE LISTENED TO
YOU. WE PAY YOUR SALARIES. THIS
IS OUR HOUSE YOU WORK FOR US
AND DON'T FORGET IT. ALL RIGHT
YOU'RE YOU'RE ONE MINUTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM HAVE A GOOD
REST OF THE DAY ANYONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY WHO WOULD YES
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
WELCOME PLEASE LEAVE- I HAVE A
LOT TO SAY SO I'M NOT EVEN SURE
IF I CAN GET HALF OF IT OUT.
BUT I'M A SINGLE FATHER. DOING
A SOLID JOB WITH TWO KIDS- AND
HAVE VERY LITTLE INCOME MYSELF.
MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS THE
MOTIONAL SUPPORT I HAVE TO. THE
METICULOUS SOMEONE I DO ON
RAISING MY TWO CHILDREN. TO
MAKE UP THE LACK OF EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT THEY GET DON'T GET.
FROM THEIR MOTHER AUNTS UNCLES
GRANDPARENTS BECAUSE THERE'S NO
ONE. THE SCHOOL WAS PART OF
THAT. AND THAT IS GONNA. AND
I'M I'M GLAD THAT YOU GUYS ARE
WITH THE SCHOOL SYSTEM AND
COMMUNICATING. I WISH THERE'D
BE MORE COMMUNICATION WITH THE
PARENTS AS WELL. AND THE
STUDENTS BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
LOT TO SAY MR- THE MENTAL
HEALTH IT'S ALMOST LIKE WE'RE
TREATING. SAFETY FOR MENTAL
HEALTH. YOUR KIDS NEED THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO LOSE IT. LOSE
OUR SOCIAL SKILLS. SERVILITY TO
READ SOCIAL CUES. I MEAN IF I
DON'T TALK TO PEOPLE FOR A
WHILE. I LOSE MY SOCIAL SKILLS
A LITTLE BIT AND I HAVE TO RE
INTRODUCE MYSELF AND I'VE DONE
THAT AND TIME TO TIME IN MY
LIFE. THANK YOU SIR YOU'RE A
MINUTE AND A HALF I WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT WHATEVER SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THAT YOU YOUR
CHILDREN ARE IN. YOU HEARD FROM
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS TODAY
REACH OUT TO THEM. AND THEY'RE
DOING THE BEST THEY CAN DURING
THIS PANDEMIC TO THE FINAL
THING I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS. A
WAY OF GETTING PARENTS TOGETHER
THAT'S VITAL AND HOME
SCHOOLING. AS FAR AS HAVING
PARENT GROUPS. FF FAMILIES CAN
GET TOGETHER AT SOME POINT.
THAT SHOULD BE PUT THE
COMMUNITY SHOULD BE PUT BACK
TOGETHER. THIS I THINK HE SAID
I AGREE I'M SO IF YOU'RE GOING
TO BE MORE ABOUT PERSONAL ON
THE THRONE THANK YOU YOU KNOW
WILL BE GREAT YOU CAN SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS IN WRITING TO US.
SO THAT WE CAN FULLY REAP THEM
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE IT DO WE
HAVE. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
NO ONE ELSE VERY GOOD WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO. ROOM ONE
TWELVE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
PARTICIPANTS THERE. SEEING NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES WHO WANT
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
THROUGH THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
A LINE NUMBER. YOU WILL BE
CALLED ON BY AIRLINE NUMBER
WHEN IT'S YOUR TURN. IF YOU'RE
USING A SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE
PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS. ONCE
AGAIN HE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
FEUD PLANET. ALL RIGHT HERE WE
GO. IN OUR FIRST PUBLIC COMMENT
COMES FROM THE LINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS
REPRESENTING TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE BUSINESS
LEADERS WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING
NONSTOP SINCE MARCH THIRTEENTH.
THANK YOU FOR TODAY'S
DISCUSSION ON A CRITICAL ISSUE
THAT WE CANNOT. ON OUR OWN I
PUBLIC EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF
OUR MILLION. WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE THE TO LET IT DID I THAT.
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERS. WITH
TELECOM. COMPANIES COOL AND
LOCAL. TO FUND AND BUILD THE
CONNECTIVITY INFRASTRUCTURE
PRIORITIZING OUR WILL AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY. WE NEED THE
STATE TO SUPPORT STATE FARM TWO
HUNDRED KNOWLEDGE IN ACCORDANCE
INCLUDING DEVICES AND HOT HOT
THAT HAVE SHORTER LIFE.
BUILDING A GREAT AS MOST OF OUR
SCHOOL FIGHT NEED TO BE
MODERNIZED IN ORDER TO TRANSMIT
RELIABLE WIFI FOR IN CLASS. IN
HOT. THANK YOU TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND I'M GOING COURT TO ENSURE
THE EVERY. EVERY AND EDUCATE
HUSBAND TECHNO SKILLS IN THE BY.
AS WE THE CALL THE NINETEEN. IN
MEETING THAT PERCENT. WE MUST
ALSO RECOGNIZE THE CONTINUED
IMPACT OUR OUTAGES WILDFIRES.
OUR STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY AND
THINK THE FAMILY MEMBER MAY FOR
OFFERING AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN AND- BOB. BUT THE MORALE
BUILDER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE YOUR CALL MONTEREY CAN WE
GO THE NEXT PLEASE. OUR NEXT
PUBLIC COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THERE AND HAPPY WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATE THE IRISH
BUDGET TRAILER BILL MADE ACCESS
TO THE DEVICE AND CONNECTIVITY
A PERMANENT PART OF THE
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS
DEFINITION IN OUR EDUCATION
CODE. CHANGES AFFECTED
IMPORTANT WAYS BUT THE WILLIAM
SETTLEMENT LEGISLATION THAT%
REQUIRES ALL STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO TEXTBOOKS AND
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS USED IN
CLASS AND AT HOME. OWNERSHIP
BUT THE FACT PUBLICLY REPORT
INCORRECT INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIAL INSUFFICIENCIES NOW
INCLUDING A LACK OF ACCESS TO
DEVICES AND CONNECTIVITY AND
REPORT ANY INSUFFICIENCY OF
MATERIAL IN ONLY ON THE SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT CARD. WE
APPRECIATE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS ABOUT CONNECTIVITY AS
A PART OF STUDENT ENGAGEMENT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE BURDEN OF
CONNECTIVITY SHOULD NOT FALL AN
EDUCATIONAL LOAN. TO SUPPORT
ELEAZAR MONITORING ONGOING
DIGITAL ACCESS WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE STATE DEVELOP A
STANDARD SET OF QUESTIONS RALLY
A FACTORED INTO THE FAMILY.
BURKE COUNTY FASCICLE DETERMINE
WHETHER EVERY STUDENT HAS
ACCESS TO A FUNCTIONAL DEVICE
IN A ONE TO ONE BASIS
CONSISTENT CONNECTIVITY WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE REGULARLY
CHECKING IN WITH STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES TO AFFECT ACCESS TO
RELIABLE INTERNET AND
ADDRESSING DEFICIENCIES.
TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS
AND PARENTS INCLUDING A
STUDENTS HOME LANGUAGE AND
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS WITH
INADEQUATE HOME LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED EFFORTS ON THIS
IMPORTANT. ISSUE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BUT FROM. COLOR IN OUR
NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MARTY A MOTO
I'M A FAMILY MEMBER PERSON WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ALSO
WITH HE CAN CALIFORNIA
DISABILITIES IN CONNECTION THAT
WERE THING WANT TO THANK BTH
SHARES IN THE COMMITTEES FOR
DOING THIS HEARING- I JUST WANT
TO EMPHASIZE WHAT THE SENATOR
TO CERTAIN ALSO COMMISSIONER
GOODMAN AND SUPERINTENDENT
THURMAN ABOUT THE- BARRIERS
RELATED TO ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET AND THAT CROSSES ALBA
SYSTEM LINES INCLUDING THOSE IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION BUT ALSO
THOSE WHO RELY ON REMOTE
SERVICES OR NEED REMOTE
SERVICES AND REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES. MEXICO I THINK
SOMEONE MENTIONED THAT AND-
ALSO JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE
WHAT SENATOR JACKSON SAID NOT
SOME OTHER SENATORS- REGARDING
OUR PEOPLE BEARING AND THAT'S
SO IMPORTANT FOR THE NEXT
HEARING IF YOU DO WANT TO HEAR
FROM ADVOCATE ON HOW FAMILIES
ARE PAIRING UP PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND INSPECTOR
EDUCATION REPAIRING- AND ALSO
THE ISSUE THAT YOU RAISE AN
ORDERLY ABOUT ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT FAMILIES ARE BEING
IMPACTED ON EMPLOYMENT HOUSING
SECURITY AND FOOD SECURITY
THANK YOU AGAIN. FOR ALL YOUR
WORK THANK YOU SIR FOR PROTESTS
WITH TODAY. MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ENTERNEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LET'S GO TO THE NEXT CALL
MODERATOR WE COME BACK. SURE
OUR EXT COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE. FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL RIGHT LET'S TRY THE
NEXT LINE. AND OUR NEXT COMIC
COME FROM LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SHARE
SLAVING GONZALEZ THIS IS DEREK
PLANNING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS. THAT
TOPICS TODAY ESPECIALLY
DISTANCE LEARNING PEOPLE MENTAL
HEALTH AND CONNECTIVITY ARE
EXACTLY THE RIGHT ISSUES TO BE
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
THEY'RE SO TOP OF MIND. FOR
SCHOOL LEADERS. WATER STREET
EDUCATIONAL POLICIES ARE OFTEN
TOP DOWN. SUPPORT ANNA BURKE
NOTED THIS IS THE CASE WITH THE
SOLUTIONS ARE OFTEN COMING FROM
THE GROUND UP AND BE HEARD
TODAY. I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
HOWEVER THAT THE DISTRICTS THAT
YOU HEARD FROM JAY ARE REALLY
REALLY MODEL CITIZENS WITH
RESPECT TO THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING. THEY'RE DOING
SUCH GOOD WORK BUT A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF OUR
STATES DISTRICTS ARE STILL
STRUGGLING TO ACHIEVE THE SAME
BREADTH OF THE STATE. STUDENT
SERVICES. ADVISOR WONDERFUL
PANELISTS. EQUALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT TO EXPECT NEXT YEAR
BOTH IN TERMS OF THE PANDEMIC
BUT ALSO THE FISCAL SUPPORT
THAT THEY CAN EXPECT FROM THE
STATE WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
HEARING ABOUT THESE TOPICS AND
INVITING THE PALETTE THAT YOU
DID THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING
MODERATOR NEXT CLUB. PERSON
PLEASE. OUR NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT
COMES FROM THE LINE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR THE MEMBERS I'M
NOT SURE THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ON THE DEVIATION CERTAINLY
DISTRICTAND TWO MILLION SCHOOL
CHILDREN INCLUDING EARLY
LEARNERS. ARE TAKING THIRD RD
CONNECTIVITY'S DR. LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT THURMOND.
MICHAEL MICHAEL IS GREATER
ALLEN CHRISTIAN FOUNDATION OF
PROVIDE A ONE YEAR SERVICE WITH
POP CULTURE THOUSAND STUDENTS
L. A. COUNTY. LAKE ALSO
SPEARHEAD EFFORTS FOR ALEX
BOARD OF. BY TWELVE FIVE NOW
DOLLARS TWENTY THOUSAND. AND
TWO THOUSAND. THE NEW THAT A.
COUNTY. ONE TROUBLE SPOT
SOMEBODY SERVICE AFTER THIRTY
TWENTY TWENTY CONSERVATION THE
CARE. COULD EVENTUALLY FUNDING
DEADLINE. EXTENSION DOESN'T
WILL BE HELPFUL OR CALL AND WE
CAN PREPAY HOP ON. HERE AND.
TWENTY ONE. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
INTERNET COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS BETH
BURKE I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
AUTISM SOCIETY OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR F
AUTISM SOCIETY IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND A PROUD PARENT AND
TWO FORMER SPECIAL ED STUDENTS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION AND
TODAY BUT I ALSO WANTED TO
BRING UP SOMETHING MARTY AND
MENTIONED WAS- THE QUESTIONS IN
THE NEEDS THAT FAMILIES ARE
HAVING. A LOT OF OUR SPECIAL
EDUCATION PARENTS DON'T HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF THE SMALL COHORT
THEY ARE STILL ONLINE DISTANCE
LEARNING AND THEY ARE IN
CRISIS- IT IS NOT WORKING FOR
MANY OF OUR FAMILIES AND THEY
ARE DROWNING AND THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR RELIEF. ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAD FOR THE
COMMITTEE IS POSSIBLY
PUBLISHING ON SOME SORT OF DATA
THAT SHOWS HOW MANY OF THE
DISTRICT ACTUALLY ARE OPENING
CO COURT OPEN TO SPECIAL ED
STUDENTS- WE ARE HOPING THAT
MORE STUDENTS WILL ADOPT THIS.
SO WE CAN SERVE SOME OF THESE
FAMILIES THAT ARE IN CRISIS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FIFTY
FIVE ZERO HERE MIKE IT'S OPEN.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
ENTERNEXT COMIC COMES FROM THE
LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK YOU-
CENTER LEYVA CENTER GONZALEZ
MEMBERS AND SPECIAL THANK YOU
TO THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT
ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION REPRESENTING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES IN
SIX COUNTIES OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS. WANT TO
SPEAK ON THE DISTANCE LEARNING
DIGITAL DIVIDE. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU APPRECIATE ALL
THAT AND DONE AND THE ISSUES
THAT WE DISCUSSED TODAY. THERE
ARE COUNTIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THAT EARLY ON
ESTABLISHED HIGH SPEED INTERNET
NETWORKS AND THEY'RE NOW BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
STUDENTS BUT THERE ARE STILL.
ISSUES RELATED TO THAT CASE
THAT CAME UP TODAY RELATED TO
SPEED AND ACCESS. AND OTHER
COUNTY VOTER FORMING STATE
LOOKING TO FORM JTA'S TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICE. ONE ISSUE
IS THAT THE STATE BROADBAND
pWHO REALLY NEEDS TO HAVE A
CONCERTED EFFORT OUTREACH AND
INCLUSION OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. DISTANCE LEARNING
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY IS NOT
GOING TO GO AWAY AS A NEED WE
NEED TO REALLY THINK ABOUT THE
SECTOR- AS A VITAL PART OF THE
STATE PLAN. IN ADDITION ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS I JUST WANTED TO
RAISE ISSUES. THAT CONNECTIVE
ITTY IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
ESPECIALLY AS- STUDENTS ARE
RECEDING AND CAN RECEIVE SOME
OF THE NEEDED SERVICES VIA
TELEHEALTH SERVICES. I REALLY
THINK THIS IS AN AREA THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS
NEED TRAINING ON ABOUT HALF OF
THE TECH THE TECHNICAL ASPECTS
THANK. YOU MA'AM YOU'RE A
MINUTE THIRTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE HEAR YOU. MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE.
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRWOMAN GONZALEZ
AND LEYVA AND MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WHICH REPRESENTS A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
CERTIFICATED AND CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE STATE WE'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR CONVENING
THIS JOINT HEARING TO ADDRESS
THIS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
ENSURING THAT EVERY STUDENT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
BOTH ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET RELIABLE TECHNOLOGY IS
CRITICAL AS WE STRIVE TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH A HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATION IN A DISTANCE
LEARNING OUR HYBRID LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT. THERE ARE TWO
ISSUES THAT I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT- IN THIS
CONVERSATION- ONE IS THE NEED
TO PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TO OUR EDUCATORS
WHO MAY BE STRUGGLING TO
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTION IN A VIRTUAL
ENVIRONMENT- SUPERINTENDENT
THURMAN MENTIONED THIS AND-
CERTAINLY WE SEE THAT AS A NEED
NUMBER TWO IS PROVIDING
EDUCATORS WITH THE TECHNICAL
SUPPORT THEY NEED SO THAT THEY
CAN- MAINTAIN THE TECHNOLOGY
THEY HAVE BEEN AND MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S WORKING EFFECTIVELY-
SO AGAIN WE'RE COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING THE HIGHEST QUALITY
INSTRUCTION POSSIBLE IN A
DISTANCE LEARNING AND-
ENVIRONMENT. AS YOU CONTINUE
YOUR DELIBERATIONS ON THIS
ISSUE WE RECOMMEND THAT YOU
INCORPORATE THESE NEEDS INTO
THOSE DISCUSSIONS AS YOU SIX
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE THE CFC IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WRONG HERE. TO
MINUTE THIRTY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ENTERNEXT COMES FROM A LINE OF
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LUIS
REPRESENTING SCENIC THE
CORPORATION FOR EDUCATION
NETWORK INITIATIVES IN
CALIFORNIA I'M IN THANK YOU FOR
THE HEARING TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AS
YOU MOVE FORWARD AN UPCOMING
SESSION AROUND AND BRINGING
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND TO ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. BY CONNECTIVITY'S
THROUGH FOUR MONTHS OF THE K.
TWELVE DISTRICT ALONG WITH
PUBLIC LIBRARY. AND OTHER
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS IN THE
STATE AND NOTE THAT THE
ADMISSION OF ADVOCATE THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WOULD BE REALLY
HELPFUL COMMISSION WE CAN GET
MORE READERS WOULDN'T YOU GREAT
PROGRAM WHICH HELPS SCHOOLS.
AND LIBRARIES HERE TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE FOR. ADDITIONAL
NEEDS AND MERIT SITE SUCH. AS
WIRELESS AND- PLAN AND OTHER OP.
THERE I'M A JUST THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MODERATOR COLORFUL.
ENTERNEXT COMMENT COME FROM A
LINE. FORTY NINE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS LAURIE
YOUR CAN HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR
THIS. LARRY OR TAKE UP FROM
FROM MONA JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT THE DIGITAL VIDE
REPRESENTS A DENIAL TO
OPPORTUNITY IN ITS MOST BASIC
FORM. OUR CHILDREN MUST HAVE
SEAMLESS ACCESS TO THE RICH
RESOURCES OF THE INTERNET. I
THINK WE'VE LET THE I. PIECE
YOU KNOW OVER THE LAST TWO
DECADES TO TRY TO SOLVE THIS
THING IF WE THINK THAT WE'RE
GOING TO SOLVE THE STATE
THROUGH THEM ONCE AGAIN. FOR
HIGHLY MISTAKEN I THINK IT'S
TIME THAT WE TOOK SOME OF THREE
HUNDRED MILLION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND AND CONDUCT AN AUDIT TO
FIND OUT WHERE THE MONEY WENT
AND WHERE THE DARK FIBER EXISTS
SO THAT WE'RE ABLE TO CONNECT.
ALL OF OUR FAMILIES IN
EVERYWHERE THAT WE NEED THIS IS
STATE UTILITY THAT WAS PAID FOR
BY OUR DOLLARS BY OUR RATES AS
RATE PAYERS. AND WE HAVE ACCESS
AND WE SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
THE KNOWLEDGE OF WHERE THAT
DARK FIBERS THAT SO WE CAN
FINISH THIS WORK IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT OUR KIDS HAVE
THIS SEAMLESS AXIS THANK YOU
FOR THIS CONFERENCE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR ORTEGA. RETURNING
CALLER PLEASE. OUR NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM THE LINE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I AM THE
PARENT OF A KINDERGARTNER AND-
FRIENDS WITH MULTIPLE SKILLED
TEACHERS THAT TEACH SPECIAL ED
IN FROM A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE. THIS IS A GOOD
STARTING POINT IN- AND FIXING
ISSUES WITH CONNECTIVITY- BUT
WE STILL HAVE THE ISSUE OF
YOUNG CHILDREN THAT ARE NOT
CLOSE TO HAVE AMOUNT OF SCREEN
TIME. AND SPECIAL ED CHILDREN
THAT DON'T THRIVE IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT THAT ARE BASICALLY
BEING LEFT BEHIND- ANYWHERE ALL
I SEE IS THAT TEST SCORES I'M
EXPECTATIONS ARE BEING LOWERED
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT PERFORMING
WHICH IS NOT GOING TO GOT NOT
GONNA SHOOT THEM WELL AS THEY
PROGRESS FORWARD IN EDUCATION
OR INTO THEIR ADULT LIVES. WE
REALLY NEED TO SIT DOWN AND
DISCUSS. WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
AND WITH THAT WITH THE COLD
AND- THE CASE RATE SO HIGH BUT
THE DEATH RATE SO LOW IS THIS
REALLY THE PATH WE NEED TO BE
TAKING IT THAT'S REALLY WHAT.
IN PLACE TO HELP OUR CHILDREN I
BELIEVE NOW SO THIS IS A GOOD
START BUT I REALLY THINK THIS
IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM I THINK WE PROBABLY
AGREE WITH YOU. MISTER
MODERATOR. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND THERE ARE NO. CUTS AT THIS
TIME. ALL WITH NO LEFT FOR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY I'LL GO BACK
TO OUR MEMBERS DOES ANYONE HAVE
ANY FINAL COMMENTS THEY WISH TO
SHARE. JUERGENS ALL DID YOU
HAVE ANY CLOSING REMARKS. ALL
RIGHT ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU TO
ALL OF OUR WONDERFUL PEOPLE WHO
TESTIFIED TODAY AND PROVIDED US
WITH A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
VARIOUS WAYS THAT STUDENTS ARE
CURRENTLY BEING SERVED WE KNOW
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO DISCUSS
AND SO MUCH MORE TO DO TO
ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
HAVE THE EDUCATION AND SUPPORTS
THEY NEED AND DESERVE. THANKS
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
CALLED IN TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFIED VIA
TELECONFERENCE. PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. AND OR AT THE SENATE
SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON PANDEMIC
RESPONSE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND ARE IN
SUGGESTIONS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO US. WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
YOUR CORPORATIONS. CORPORATION
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
AND SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
PANDEMIC RESPONSE. IS ADJOURNED
EVERYONE HAVE A GREAT REST OF
THE DAY.